foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to chess.com's coverage of the
Fisher random World Championship
presented by Brave I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me today my good
friend Grandmaster Daniel narodiski
Dania this has been a great tournament
thus far now we're down to four
contestants vying for that world
championship crown
we are indeed Robert I think it's
important not to over analyze this at
the outset has this tournament been
wildly entertaining has every single
hour counted has it kept us on the edge
of our seats the answer is an
unequivocal yes yes and yes and I don't
see any reason that today is going to be
an exception to the rule
no but the rules are a bit confusing to
some who are not familiar with Fisher
random chess so why don't we remind
everybody what this variant is like
because in Fisher random the pieces
start in one of 960 positions and that's
why it's called chest 960 as well and
black and white start in the same setup
all standard rules apply but I don't
know that's about kind of all sometimes
the similarities between chess and
Fisher random because a queen could be
in the corner a bishop can be in the
other Corner things get hectic
things get chaotic there's total Anarchy
on the board in most cases the pieces
they do move the same way they look the
same way the Kings even Castle the same
way some top Grandmasters could use a
little refresher course on that one
we're not going to name any names though
but the rules are the same the pieces
move the same way do not forget that
when there's total chaos going on on the
board
Say It Ain't So don't forget where your
Castle goes but here we are in the
semi-finals Wesley so is not one of our
four players who made it that's
surprising because he was uh the
previous world champion in Fisher rental
I guess he still is for at least two
more days but his title is no longer
going to be his in the format for these
semi-finals it's different than the
group stage and we will see a four
player single elimination knockout those
four players
Magnus Carlson and nakara Nakamura and
each game is four match the first to two
and a half wins So Daniel same old same
old two different starting positions I
really like this format and the time
control
it's simple it's elegant and if you're
late to the party the time control could
strike you as a little bit unusual but
the point is that it prevents wild time
scrambles it's a 25 plus zero game but
after 30 moves a five a five second
increment comes into effect and the
players receive an additional five extra
minutes this prevents anything crazy
from happening I think it's an elegant
time control and I think the four game
match format is simple and it caters to
some wildly exciting chess
it really does and wild and exciting
chess I think these days you think about
a player nordybeck Abdul sitarov is at
the top of the list and he's at the top
of his group a he absolutely obliterated
the field I mean he locked up a spot
here in the semis very early on and look
who else was in his group Jana pamshi
and Wesley so so he just slaughtered a
very impressive slate of opponents but
on the other side in group b Daniel
Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura arguably
the two biggest names in chess yeah it
was the tale of two groups on the left
in group a slaughtered I think is the
best possible word to describe what
Notre back I've just sort of did do his
competition he lost only one match and
it was the final meaningless match
against Wesley so when he had already
clinched not just qualification but the
top spot in his group as he opened up a
wild gap between himself and Jan
napomnushi it was an amazing display and
Magnus and Hikaru no real surprises
there they went neck and neck with each
other but against FedEx and blue Baum
they demonstrated their class and Hikaru
demonstrated his clutch I can't wait for
their potential matchup
well I'm sure all players are excited
for the semi-finals I think Notre back
in particular is going to be upset the
group stages come to an end because now
he has to venture into the other group
and he will be playing Hikaru Nakamura
so we have the most popular chess
content creator out there I should say
streamer I guess there's an argument
made for other YouTube Sensations like
Gotham chess and others but and the
other side of things we have the
previous World Chess Championship and it
could have been once more if not for
Magnus Carlsen abdicating the throne but
Magnus Carlson versus Jana palmchi that
is as mouth-watering a matchup as you
could possibly ask for it most certainly
is listen I said I can't wait for Hikaru
magnus's potential matchup this is as
far from a given as it gets janapamishi
is hungry he has a chip on his shoulder
when he's playing Magnus and as we saw
in the Madrid candidates when Jan has a
chip on his shoulder when he's got that
fire under himself we saw that in the
RCC as well he is a force to be reckoned
with as is of course Notre back the
reason I'm particularly excited for
Notre back against icaro is that they
have played in the RCC many times Robert
they have gone back and forth their
games have been neck and neck and I
think that this match is going to be as
entertaining as ever Notre back I mean
you just cannot shower him with enough
praise the kid is absolutely
unbelievable
he is a world rapid Champion he's an
Olympia Champion he is the bright
present and of course future of Chess
and let's put bring the spotlight on
some of these players I mean noribik
Abdul sitarov he won his group in
astounding fashion he made his way
through the qualifiers and you know he
just looked Mighty impressive the whole
way through and I mean what can you say
about this kid he's a teenager still and
yeah team is lighting the world of Chess
Ablaze
where was I at 18 I think I Was
preparing for my math test and uh you
know struggling to get up at 6 30 in the
morning where's Notre back at 18 he is
playing the world champion he's playing
kikaru Nakamura he is winning olympiads
receiving cars in apartments
and he's doing it with such class and
modesty and I think that's the greatest
thing about these young chess prodigies
they are so easy to root for both
stylistically both on the board and of
course how maturely they comport
themselves off the board as well I'm
becoming a big Notre big fan he's going
to go so so far in chess
he will he went far this tournament he
did and Wesley so was the only player
who could take him down in a mini match
and a car with Nakamura will have to
hope that his prep work and when I say
prep I mean like 10 minutes once the
position is revealed he and Wesley so
were often talking about what strategies
to employ he'll need to learn something
from Wesley in order to take down
nerdybeck but on the other side of
things is Magnus Carlson the world's
champion the strongest player in chess
history to many fans out there and well
Max had a great event only losing to
Hikaru Nakamura in round two he split
the other match against hicaro and won
the others so Magnus Carlson he's proven
that he's not just a force on the
regular chess set when fish are random
with pieces are all scrambled he can
also do his work there and Magnus
himself will be the first to admit that
his form in this tournament was by his
standard subpar and this is just a
vintage Magnus performance in that he
made some blunders he made some
uncharacteristic mistakes his allowing
stalemate against Vladimir fetusaev
comes to mind he under the rook in one
move against the car Nakamura blah blah
blah guess what he is in The Knockouts
one way or the other Magnus Carlson has
yet again demonstrated his class and
consistency even in the face of an
uncharacteristic number of blunders but
he is going to have to clean up his play
if he wants to defeat a hungry young
upanishi today
yes and young Department she made
blunders himself throughout the group
stage and for Magnus why is he the
winner of his group he lost head to head
to Hikaru Nakamura but he had more
points overall so same amount of match
points uh they both uh ended up with uh
well for hikar four match wins two ties
for Magnus um he was able to beat
everybody else not named Hikaru where
zakar Drew against fedo save twice so as
we but actually I think I did that wrong
so hikara had three match ties excuse me
and three match victories but we are
here in the semi-finals Magnus seated
waiting for janapamshi and Jan is one of
the quickest players on the planet but
perhaps not the quickest to a seat
and Magnus isn't the quickest seed
either but there he comes sitting down
first opening up the water
as yon settles down adjusts his suit
pushes his chair in and you could just
tell that tension it's that vintage
tension that comes from before the
finals of a knockout chess tournament
all the spectators gathered in that
beautiful playing Hall at the hotel
Natori as Jan adjusts the white pieces
okay seat belts fastened
oh I'm locking myself into this chair
here I'm very excited and Yonder Palm
she no longer wearing a t-shirt I know
much has been made about that on social
media but these two have sat across the
board from each other more than anybody
in the planet in the last year they
played a world championship match
they're well prepared for each other
stylistically
but not in this variant you cannot
prepare for somebody outside of the
about a dozen or so minutes between the
position being revealed the board and I
see Hikaru Nakamura he is making his way
to the stage and his game against
nordebec Abdus tarov and your point
about the lack of preparation cannot be
overstated enough mistakes happen on
move one in fisherman and they have it
on move two on move three the players
are thinking on their feet from the very
beginning of the game and that lends the
game such incredible additional
entertainment value where you just see
the craziest things happen and you look
at the move counter and it's something
like move seven or move eight you have
time pressure Often by move 10 so you
know when I say seat belts fast and I
mean seat belts fastened we are in for a
wild ride in both of these matches
and hikar Nakamura doing his best Levon
aronian impression that is white the
shirt that Hikaru has on and Nordic
going with the solid black shirt look at
this yeah yeah you know I guess I'm
still one with a boring suit okay which
is a bit surprising but the players well
dressed ready for the semi-finals the
action should get underway shortly and
Magnus right he had some
uncharacteristic mistakes he blundered a
full Rook against Hikaru Nakamura
against ferrosev he blundered an
exchange still was able to draw that
game so he will not be able to make
these mistakes he cannot afford to do so
against Yonder Palms now yon was not
great in the group stage now sure by his
own admission he was under his own
expectations but he made it here and in
any game in any match janapamshi as
dangerous as they come
yeah and his time management is great
his tactical Vision obviously needs no
introduction uh that is uh
that's adorable and
oh this is this is too cute the games
are underway but you're absolutely right
John is going to have to clean up his
play with a wide smile on his face as
the gong sounds and the game kicks off
yes and or not not yet
some announces to be made and look at
that there's a knight in the corner for
both and well the position is hard to
see now that it's just magnus's face but
uh that guy is calculating what's wrong
with just magnus's face there's nothing
wrong with that nothing at all
especially when his hair uh becomes the
size of the uh entire planet and into
the solar system I'm sure you saw all
those memes that chess.com was putting
out but that's not the huner there
because the games have liftoff I see I
believe it was F4 there and there's a
rook on F1 so I would love to get the
positions up so we can explain what the
Dynamics are to the fans the bird
defense I always like it when they
actually play the first moves of a real
chess opening but the point the ideas
behind the Fisher random moves are
entirely different as we see the players
blitzing out their first couple of moves
we have pawns on G4 and F4 already
Robert some flank action as neither side
really touching their Center pawns when
I see Pawns in F4 and G4 in two moves I
think of the quickest Checkmate
available in the standard game of chess
so this is not that there's a bishop on
E1 not a king and there was no Queen to
deliver that diagonal Checkmate that you
see in some in your games but Dania The
Bishop's in the corner nobody puts baby
in the corner but those Bishops are
particularly happy slicing across the
length of the board
yeah and openings and fish are random
the way that I like to describe them is
that they're all about priorities your
pieces are awkwardly sometimes arranged
and you cannot open everything up at
once you're going to have to keep some
pieces confined so the real question you
want to answer which pieces do you want
to open up first and which pieces do you
want to participate as effectively as
possible in the opening I think we have
our answer here both sides focused
entirely on their King side opening up
their Bishops and of course the queen on
G1 kind of nicely placed both from a
defensive and an attacking standpoint
and our first trade is a punch rate on
F4 what do you make of that
it's interesting because at first glance
I like White's active Rook on F4
compared to a more passive Rook on a f8
that has no moves but I'm also looking
down the G file there are open lines now
and so the move F5 comes to mind to
exploit a pin I see indicating that but
then you might be walking into a pin of
your own so the players might be walking
on pins and needles soon
literally and what's hilarious is that
after F5 white could slide the queen
over to F1 Shifting the pin from the G
file as you said over to the f file so
black has to be very careful what he
wishes for uh here in the early going on
the king side maybe H5 is a slightly
more prudent way to chip away at White's
G4 Pawn but it's not quite effective
white can play H3 I'm not worried about
why losing the G4 Pawn no but I'm
worried about those nights I'm A8 and C8
and A1 and C1 right are those that's
going the B and D files but that's a bit
awkward because
um you know now your Knights are just in
front of your pawns typically we want
our Knights behind pawns that way
they're both staring into the center for
example Pawn on D4 and Knight on D3 will
take control of more squares so it's
just hard to get a feel for the position
that's why Abdus atarav in order to Beck
taking quite an extensive think already
um so he is of course unfamiliar with
the position and just trying to figure
it out on the Fly and I think it's safe
to say that both sides if the castle
will Castle Queen side I mean King side
is now essentially wide open for the
rest of the game but one thing that both
sides have to be careful about is a c
Pawn landing on C5 if that happens not
only is one night restricted but
actually both nights are entirely
restricted so that's another thing that
both sides have to keep in mind and I
think Notre back once again is trying to
determine his priorities should he get
his Knight out to B6 Knight ab6 looks
like a reasonable move to me or does he
continue engaging Hikaru on the king
side with F5 or H5 or Bishop D5
something to that effect
H Drive I think was played we can see
the board on the bottom right hand side
of the screen and that looks like a Pawn
on H5 so and a quick response Bishop to
F2 for Hikaru and a bishop on F2 that
eyes the A7 Pawn so if we could just uh
throw those moves on the board just for
a second down here oh there it is they
come uh the A7 Pawn is targeted don't
sleep on that so many people missed that
especially online when they play Fisher
random but here it's kind of obvious it
was hikara's last move
and it's not just the A7 Pawn that falls
is what you're saying let's say black
plays the nonchalant H takes G4 after
Bishop takes A7 Knight takes A7 Queen
takes A7 all of a sudden black is
experiencing massive problems with his
entire King side if you slide The Rook
over the bishop jumps into B7 if you
slide the king over there is still the
tactic Bishop takes B7 and queen takes
eight you can see the evil bar not
entirely decided but I don't think he
car was in the mood uh to allow his
entire Queen side to get decimated this
early
yeah no this is what hikar is aiming for
nerdybeck says E5 striking in the Center
closing down that Bishop on eight by the
way yeah all good but
does that give up A7 like the Brooklyn
B8 is also King so I I feel like that's
too risky and even if it somehow works
out uh that's not a good idea for a car
because just to show that variation here
after Bishop A7 e takes F4 Bishop takes
B8 like that Bishop might survive and
wow the eval bar is still hovering
towards the center now it's saying black
is better yeah how could black not be
better there's a bishop on B8 that
really won't get out at least not easily
but as you're indicating the B7 Pawn
also tender this is the wackiness of
Fisher random but Hikaru likes to play
more consistently more quietly in the
opening I think this is contrary to his
style and this is right up notrex alley
I think notorbeck's strategy in so far
as you can formulate a strategy in
fisherman is to make the position
chaotic and we saw him Robert pulling
out objectively lost positions left and
right he did it twice against Jana
pamushi when the position gets
complicated he is so tricky from a
tactical perspective but drinking from a
tactical perspective those are perfect
words to fit Hikaru as well with that
being said I think that he's going to
move the rook and I think his main
decision is where he wants to shift it
to A4 maybe you can even consider moving
it up to F5 and giving up the G4 Pawn
there's also a check on H4 lots of
candidate moves here in the early going
well Bishop H4 check is one of those
moves you completely Miss and you lose
the game on the spot no yeah
nowhere to go you do have the move F6 to
save the day or Knight to E7 can jump
out there uh but this Rook is in some
trouble for Hikaru because if he goes
Rook A4 as you mentioned then the Knight
comes out to B6 from A8 attacking that
rook and all of a sudden Black's Pieces
come to life the G4 punt still is tender
and I'm actually liking the way this
game has started for Nordic we're what
four moves in and I already prefer
Black's position you called it
originally when the road came out to F4
I thought that was an unequivocally good
thing for white but not Notre back is
sitting pretty on fa kind of watching
the show and guess what Bishop takes A7
actually might be the only way uh to get
an objectively unbalanced position it
seems that no matter where white puts
his Rook there's a knight that will
attack it or there's a pawn that's going
to slide forward two squares or you lose
the G pawn and Bishop H4 check is not
that effective Robert because of this
move F6 yes you're closing down Black's
Bishop but once again The Rook has no
good spots and now Black's Queen is
opened up and controlling the C4 Square
yeah this is not a good look out of the
opening for Hikaru and he seems bothered
right his body language right now he's
resting his head on his hand normally
when he's happy he's looking at the
stars and looking at the ceiling pulling
a Beth Harmon before Beth Harmon even
did that but a card does not look
particularly thrilled Nordic on the
other hand he just glanced up at hikar I
don't want to read too much into body
language I say that and continue to talk
about it but noribbeck he seems
confident he's looking sharp and he's
played the best Fisher random of anybody
uh hikar probably might have an argument
for himself beating Magnus Carlson head
to head but noribbeck he's been
unbelievable
yeah this is already a difficult
position for moves in as you're saying I
mentioned the move counter you know when
do you get a situation like this in
classical chess after four moves
absolutely never so Hikaru is going to
have to adjust on the fly to this new
set of challenges and I think he's gonna
have to embrace the chaos and take that
pawn on A7 and then then we are in for
an absolute barn burner of a game and no
he's got Rook before
before
but this is just awkward right even
though the whole starting position is
abnormal or atypical in Knight a to B6 I
really like that move just start
developing and then you have this Rook
on B4 Rook on B1 that's not doing
anything it feels like White's pieces
are a bit misplaced in the early going
and black if you just look at the board
has an extra Pawn towards the center
white has H2 and G4 uh black has H5 and
F7 so you know if this g-pawn a G4 Pawn
goes out the way then black will have F5
is a follow-up and I really like the
Dynamics of this position for nerdy back
so good start for him I am curious
though what's happening in uh the other
one me too let's transition on to our
world championship rematch between
Carlson and napomnishi as we look at
both players there on camera and the
positions below them let's swing over to
nepo against Carlson Jan has the white
pieces in game one and what's
interesting is that they had a very
similar opening cue of just a tour of
Nakamura but with a slight deviation
yeah I mean the position of flank play
yeah you see the bishop on H1 the bishop
on h8 those Bishops in the corner coming
to life but unlike hikaru's Rook which
is ventured everywhere
um it seems like Jan he is playing with
his minor pieces and you're highlighting
that the 9c5 bishop nh1 team up against
this pawn and B7 which is defended by
the Knight on D6 I think it's very easy
to forget what's protecting what in
Fisher randomly because how many times
do you have a knight on D6 with a Pawn
on D7 behind it and you have to be
worried about your B7 phone
yeah and how many times do you not have
to be worried about your D7 Pawn because
hey there's just so happens to be Bishop
on E8 that's sitting there uh defending
it and A7 A5 by Magnus Carlson who is
now down seven minutes on the clock but
Robert the problem with nepo's pieces is
that they're kind of slipping away off
of the ledge yeah the Knight and the
queen looks impressive but there's
nothing to Anchor his minor pieces and
you give Carlson to Tempe he plays B6
and then he plays A4 and he just shoves
all of White's pieces off of their
active squares and I think nepo with his
last move is trying to prevent that from
happening he's actually threatening to
jump into E6 with a nasty discovered
attack against the king no surprise here
good tactical eye by you and one other
thing I note is in addition to White
threatening 96 check look at that A2
Pawn because at a moment's notice that
pawn might be scooped up even if they're
a piece of sacrifice right if your
knight jumps away from C4 and you take
on A2 it could be enough compensation
but I would first and foremost take care
of that Knight on D4 get rid of it I
don't want to see 96 check played so I
believe that black can take on D4 and I
actually was about to say followed with
Knight F5 but I might be blundering the
B7 Pawn in the process
so after Bishop D oh but then you have
the mirror threat of 93. oh what an
instructive line that isn't that is that
is a family Fork against these three
pieces let me just show this on the
board oh I have a free Pawn on B7 you
can see the eval bar dropping
precipitously Rook B7 Knight B7 and
whoop first whoop of the day ghost the
Knight fe3 and The Queen Is Lost after
de-93 Robert these unorthodox tactical
constructions that's what makes Fisher
random so fun and it's the risk of even
the best players in the world missing
something like this as Bishop takes D4
is on the board
yeah and I mean what a sequence that
would be those Knights are creating huge
threats in the position but I guess if
Magnus follows up with Knight to F5 the
simple Bishop F2 is good enough both
covering the E3 square and protecting
the D4 pawn and I have to say I'm
starting to like John's position I I
recommended Bishop takes D4 just because
I was worried about the threats but we
eliminated one threat but we have
long-term issues and that the bishop
pair a dynamic position that should be
good for yawn in such a situation plus
the lead in The Clock by the way yeah
that's what I was going to point out
he's almost up 10 minutes and let's not
forget there is no increment until move
30 and we we have seen uh players like
Matthias bluebellum and Vladimir fellas
and sometimes even the world champion
struggle to make 30 moves in time I know
the position as complicated as it is
this plays right into Yan's hands he
wants to force Magnus into an incredibly
tough position with two minutes on the
clock so Knight F5 potentially on deck
but then Carlson will have to take care
of his V7 pawn and this bishop F2 idea
is a super important defensive resource
I'm on the same page I like John's
position in the early going
I'm still looking at A2 Pawn hoping to
drum up some counter play with a queen
takes A2 at some point but I don't think
it's worth the cost of the Knight on C4
so in some positions that might work in
Black's favor for now I don't think
there's much of an attack or enough
compensation to give away that piece so
I think that Jan I mean look at him I
know he's hunched over there but the
move B6 just chosen by Magnus I think
the Knight can simply Retreat to D3 and
all of White's bases are covered that
Knight May venture to if you beat me to
it you know where I was going exactly
where you were going
I just feel like white has everything
you could dream of in terms of typical
chess Notions yeah I mean you could
almost think of these pawns as some sort
of a mirror marozzi bind what is the
bind inflicted on What's That E5 Square
which is being clamped down on not
really allowing black to free himself by
pushing the Eep on it it's important to
point out though that Knight A6 tempting
as it may appear is very
counterproductive because after Rook C8
hey I can trap The Rook on V7 my
opponent doesn't have a knight on D6
protecting so don't go Knight A6 and
self-imprison yourself I think we're
gonna see on uh wisely dropping the
Knight back to D3
yeah and the fact that he's thinking
here is a bit surprising maybe he's just
Gathering his bearings uh but Knight D3
you don't want to bring your Knights on
the rim Unless somehow Knight A6 you
know there's some tactic that we're over
looking which I don't I think we are the
Knight D3 Retreat seems very natural and
he can keep that huge lead on the clock
because it's only move nine just played
there B6 was Black's ninth move 20 plus
moves to make with 13 minutes on in this
kind of position good luck to you
yeah and I think Carlson may have
underestimated the defensive power of
the move Bishop F2 that's the problem
when you're banking on one specific
restarts to solve all of your problems
you realize that your opponent has a
defense to that resource and now you
have to accept all of the sort of
positional costs that you have borne by
giving up the bishop by giving up the
bishop pair and giving up the dark
squares and giving up uh Superior
central control to White
Donya bear with me for a second if white
plays Knight D3 is there a move like
Knight to A3 I'm really trying to go for
the A2 on and oh the Evo bar is hanging
in the center so I've been talking oh my
gosh oh my gosh
Knight D3 has been played and maybe
that's exactly what Yan was thinking
about Knight A3 what a cry Town move
that's right out of the doctor tank
ready Playbook B takes A3 you want to
take on A2 correct yes absolutely so
let's say for the sake of argument that
I play and the problem is if wherever I
go you're gonna have a check and a nasty
one at that you can also take on A3
I'm beginning to get on board with your
idea I mean hey you're preaching to the
choir I don't need any convincing that
Knight A3 is going to work I just you
know it was more of an intuitive
decision I didn't actually have it
backed up with calculation but Magnus
said I don't want to get involved in
this side of the board just yet I mean
it is a lot to consider he's such a G5
exploring the pin on the f file but if
Yan is not attentive to his King's
position doesn't have many moves right
he can go the C file but that's about it
a move like Knight A3 I've been harping
on this for a while now it could come
out of nowhere and really hurt him you
called it long ago that x-ray between
the queen and the A3 pawn and because
Knight A3 is to be taken seriously I
would be contemplating If I Were Young
castling Queen side here I know that
sounds weird but castling works exactly
the same way so I would be thinking
about making this move the eval bar
doesn't like it though and maybe it's
because Knight A3 is still a distinct
possibility here B takes a three Queen
A2 you don't see the Evo or dropping in
quite as much as you might think it does
and that night is literally Untouchable
here the king's toast right so all sorts
of night sack was available that is why
Jan just responded with the move B3
kicking that Knight out of there and he
is also covering the A2 Pawn so it's a
dual purpose move it's a very good
decision and the Knight goes to A3 but
no longer does Yan have to worry about
hanging upon just yet
yeah the point of this move is just to
blunt the queen and as long as the queen
is blunted White's King remains safe in
the center
what a fascinating position we have here
I mean seriously cool stuff you just
don't get this kind of chaos this kind
of Randomness for lack of a better word
as early as you do in fish random in the
game of standard chess so you see the
players they are really into it Jan
shaking his legs a little bit but plays
Rook C1 what a natural move and what
about A4 for yeah you're putting up
Bishop F7 takes B3 as well but we're
looking at the same Pawn A4 that
you block the threat so let me pry it
open with a move like A4 I guess white
does have the response D5 shutting down
the queen on the diagonal that will be
very important so Bishop F7 seems like a
viable decision and that could cause
yawn some issues but the problem with
Bishop F7 is that I think white can
respond with the relatively simple E3
creating some Luft on E2 and any
sacrifice on V3 is just destined to fail
because the king is so safe on E2
important that Bishop H5 is not possible
here Bishop F7 has been played and
Robert maybe Carlson is thinking about
combining our two ideas maybe playing A4
after white plays E3 but somehow even if
we can imagine that white plays E3 black
plays A4 I think even taking on A4 can't
be all that bad for white can it because
anytime you want the king can escape
toward the center and white can generate
his own threats against D7 if he so
desires
wow you just pointed the D7 Pawn I'm
like wait there's a Checkmate about to
happen and that is something you really
need to keep an eye out for so uh both
sides have tactical chances here the
foundation of the position should be
better for white thanks to the bishop
pair but with so many threats in the mix
here it's not going to be easy to
coordinate the pieces in a way that
actually allows yawn to maximize and the
time Advantage is still there Beyond
doing very well but what's going on in
our other game between Hikaru Nakamura
and World rapid Champion norderbeck
Abdul sitarov our other game is just as
entertaining
wow we have that crazy Rook on the
fourth rank which escaped its shell
early but that strategy potentially
backfiring for Hikaru Nakamura as he
faces down the barrel now Robert have a
clearly worse position he's given up
complete central control that Rook is
almost out of squares Notre bag has
managed to solve the problem of his
awkward Knights and with his last move
Knight c87 he is threatening to jump
into D5 and potentially just trap that
Rook on before am I reading this
position correctly this is just not good
for Hikaru is it no it looks miserable
because it seems like white has
developed two pieces and black even
though Black's pieces aren't out you
have all these pawns creating threats on
the G4 square that Rook as you
mentioning it's about to be trapped uh
so with the threat being a move like
Knight D5 what can white do to deal with
it that Rook on before is as misplaced
of a piece as I've seen in recent times
yeah it's just biting on granite and I
was about to propose to move Knight C5
and then I remembered that the queen is
staring at the A2 Pawn so you can't even
do that and obviously if you take on B7
black can always recapture with the Rook
B1 is hanging with Checkmate it's not
just the Rook that's hanging but that's
not possible either White's hamstrung on
the queen side White's hamstrung on the
king's side because if you take on F5 I
don't think the queen trade offers all
that much relief Robert maybe this is
the most prudent option but no that is
going to respond as much as I want to
see him sacrificing a queen listen even
an end game like this and I made the
most simple moves for black is no good
at all because with the f file wide open
only blackstroke is uniquely poised to
take advantage of it I don't know what
Hikaru should turn to in this position
and that work on before still might get
trapped or kicked around a bunch giving
black some free Tempe and more control
so we have some great feature chats here
someone should teach her not to bring
out the Rook early in the opening that's
usually true in a standard game of chess
and here in fisherendum it proves no
exception and it Carl you could just see
it on him right Dania like he does not
look comfortable at all it's not when
he's just destroying people left and
right in title Tuesdays and all sorts of
events and he did just make the move
Knights you're hanging A2
well does he hang a two or is he trying
to sacrifice it
I guess he should he should call it a
sacrifice even if it's a blunder exactly
it's a sacrifice I actually don't really
doubt that it's a sacrifice and my guess
is that he wants to lure the queen on A2
and just play the move Rook C1 I think
Woody Cara was saying is that finally
the pressure on the g-file has been
lifted the queen on A2 could potentially
get in trouble but in addition to all of
his other ideas Notre but could try a
move like D6 doing a little luring of
his own luring the Knights of B7
Shifting the king to C8 and asking uh
very politely or not so politely where
the Knight is going to go position like
this Robert looks borderline lost and
there's a very important point because
White's threat has been like Knight to
B3 with Rook A1 to follow but Knight B3
Cuts The Rook on B4 off from the B2 Pawn
so that black queen isn't trapped you
know even if White had a free turn so
that's a very important thing to point
out that it looks like a car is about to
trap nardibex Queen but as he's looking
off the side well he's going gonna have
to find some better answers because that
Queen is able to escape although in this
specific position you actually can't
take on B7 not because the queen is
trapped per se but because when the king
lands on B7 it is subjected to a nasty
discover check on A5 so in this
particular line black loses his Queen
but Notre back is under no obligation to
rush Rook takes B7 he could consider a
move like E4 slicing off the connection
between the bishop and the Knight and
giving the queen an escape route through
the long diagonal so I think these and
other complicated lines are going to be
what notorbeck calculates for a couple
of minutes here and he's calculated them
for a couple of minutes and he's made
his decision and it is to take on A2 and
that is what I love about Notre back
Robert he never never ever shies away
from complications he believes in his
own calculating power
and look at him he is calculating power
Fleet because he has his head pretty
much at his pieces uh he is leaned in
there he is fully focused and I mean
this is a bad position for Hikaru and
Hikaru knows it right Hikaru is a very
objective player he is somebody who
senses the moment maybe he should give
up some material to have practical
chances so I do think it was it is a
worthy attempt but Jessica Karu the way
he is sort of floundered with a rook F4
Rook B4 it's just a better start to this
match for Notre back and that doesn't
mean the game is over a car has plenty
of chances you have said this time and
time again actually defeating Hikaru is
like the hardest thing in the world you
could have a completely winning position
you could even be up like a queen
against the guy and he'll still fight
tooth and nail to the very finish but
just to think Donya after Queen takes A2
and then spends some time to me that's a
bad sign it's entirely possible that you
blundered this move I'm gonna change my
tune a little bit and these blunders we
we talked about this at the very
beginning of the broadcast and not only
are they possible but they're rather
common you just don't see these
geometric constructions Queen G8 takes
A2 how many times of those words been
uttered in the context of classical
chess so Hikaru with his Rook hanging on
B1 with Checkmate and one threatens has
to figure out some way to complicate the
game and he tries to do so by bringing
his King over to C1 rather than his rook
and my guess Robert is that he wants now
to implement your idea with Knight ab3
when Rook A1 actually will trap the
queen with a king defending B2 but it's
slow it's cumbersome and Notre back has
two entire Tempe uh to deal with that
that is an eternity in a position as
chaotic as this one
yeah and there are other things that the
move King to C1 does uh and and one of
them is a bad thing it allows black to
have some Checkmate on the back rank
because of the King on D1 that bishop
and some various shelter to E1 and keep
things uh nice and defended but with the
King on C1 I'm already looking at a ways
to exploit the back Rank and that move
looks like Knight to D5 by whoa whoa
and the Eva went up
white can play Knight ab3 anyway
can't oh you just so you're just giving
up your Rook on before and giving up two
Rooks for the queen oh my God James
Canty Knight ab3 that takes B4 Rook A1
now I think Notre back sees that black
can get two Rooks for the queen but the
problem Robert look at blacks Rooks
they're totally out of the game I would
take the queen any day in a position
like this his Knight ab3 the reason that
the eval bar
has taken a 180 I think it is
wow it lands but when you think about it
Black Series stolen upon right and now
you're gonna get two Rooks for the queen
so that is quite a lot of material for
black you have 11 points worth for nine
but the issue is King safety your point
of Bishop race for the B7 Pawn now
really is under attack so all of a
sudden there are a bunch of things to
worry about now I think that both sides
would have huge chances in this position
I wouldn't even know who's better if you
just showed it to me I actually think
that maybe black still has the better
chances because I it looks like the
attack isn't sufficient even though the
evaluation bar is suggesting that it is
so I don't I think noribbeck confidently
went into this just on intuition saying
I should have the good side of things he
may objectively be wrong but from a
practical point
he has some Merit but I'm going to push
back a little bit I think black just
experiences massive logistical problems
here what are they if you play King C8
to defend B7 I can take on B7 anyway and
follow up with the timely Bishop C5 if
you play for example Knight back to C6
let's intercept the bishop well now
white strikes at the other end G takes
H5 and again I'm not saying that these
aren't necessarily the best moves I'm
trying to illustrate the kinds of
challenges that black is up against in
this position without a queen and with
the Rooks are as passive as they are I
just feel like black is going to suffer
on one side of the board and the queen
is uniquely positioned to supervise both
sides of the board from G1 and any 980
is on the board you don't have to ask
ikara twice no you don't and Nori back
he doesn't seem rattled by the decision
just yet but he is taking a pause to
consider his options uh you know I'm
gonna give you some credit there Knight
ab3 and the Queen on A2 being trapped is
an issue and it just is interesting you
know I mean you can see the player's
faces Hikaru he understands that this is
his best opportunity and neither player
knows what the exact assessment is but
hikara says you know what this is good
for me and he is right so uh this Pawn
sacrifice in A2 is working out for him
thus far and Don if we just go back
before Knight to D5 was played um I've
been thinking about it maybe just
bringing the queen back to F7 was
sufficient and if you just drop your
queen all the way back with f takes G4
on the docket and back rank checkmates
in the works this is maybe what black
had to do it's easy to say in retrospect
hindsight is 20 20.
um and I wear glasses my vision's not
good but I feel like you know this is
where Nobody Breaks to be like maybe I
should spend a bit more time even if he
ultimately came to the same decisions in
the game so he had a huge opportunity
yeah I think I've
not just saying that because of the
e-ball bar he's down upon all of the
problems the white faced two moves
previously have been Amplified 100 folds
so the tune the the nature of the
position has changed entirely and Hikaru
kind of leaning back in his chair I can
assure you that he is breathing a deep
sigh of relief on the inside he now
knows that this position is a three
result game and he's got the best
position he has in basically since move
two so potentially a big turnaround
let's see how motorbeck handles this new
set of challenges I think he's gonna
have to take the rook and we're gonna
see that queen against two Rooks battle
and in the other game we have a ton of
developments as well so don't take a dip
into it Carlson land while you were just
diving into that position there is one
of the most beautiful tactics that
Magnus Carlson found so the reason why
his position is good we see in the
bottom right hand side of the screen
it's much better for him uh we'll Dive
Right into that because unmove
um 13. there was an amazing tactic that
Magnus Carls has spotted so what
position
check this out Bishop takes B3 check
peace sacrifice for a couple points
that's a logical move this all makes
sense so keep going
Rook F4 so the point everybody is to
distract the Knight on D3 you may say
why is that 19 distraction well after
well we can show actually with the game
continuation if Rook F4 is the best
illustration of it Knight F4 Queen B3
check King E1 only move Knight C2 check
and you can't sacrifice your Rook for
that night because Queen B1 leads to
Checkmate the Knight on D3 cover the C1
Square so with the Knight removed you
can no longer capture this Knight on C2
Black's Knight and if the king slides
back to D1 check this out 93 no double
check didn't and after King E1 I'm not
even taking your queen on G4 I'm playing
Queen D1 Rook takes Queen Knight C2
smothered Checkmate that is sick Magnus
Carlson spotted that from a mile away
and that is why he is the world chess
champion and the best player in the
world for over the last decade Rook
takes that for are you kidding me how
many times do you see not only smothered
mate uh that is rare let alone a
smothered mate with a white King on its
initial chest square that is absolutely
ridiculous and after Rook takes F4 Yan
was forced to do a complete 180 he had
to make a rather sad move Queen H5 and
Carlson follows up by grabbing another
pawn and here he does give that check on
C2 and of course Yan avoids getting
checkmated with Rook takes C2 but after
Queen takes C2 the back ring haunts
white again again you can't take the
Rook because of Checkmate you have to
let the Rook live Jan was forced to play
The Desperate move E3 and after Rook F6
it's time to take stock Magnus has seven
pawns Jana has four white White's Queen
side has been completely decimated black
as these connected passers and White's
King is still breathing with a lot of
difficulty here what a ridiculous
sequence of events Robert with that
being said the game is far from over
white has a lot of minor pieces and if
Yan can somehow untangle maybe bring the
king up to E2 black still has some
problems left to solve
that's true so how many pawns oh the
last move that Maxwell's Castle Queen
side whoa I forget that moves like that
are legal in uh Fisher random but he
castles Queen side to make sure the D7
Pawn is protected to bring the rook in
the game now I'm kind of with you the
bishop on H1 that open diagonal scares
me a bit but black does have three pawns
and a rook for those two minor pieces
and that A5 Pawn that may become a
runner in the near future it's gonna
Sprint down to the A1 square and become
a new Queen
and will it Sprint down in this position
or will Magnus try to take some sort of
prophylactic measures against White's
light Square control I don't actually
think that an action is required of
black immediately I think A4 is totally
possible here but maybe Magnus is going
to try to eliminate that Knight 95
distract the queen he plays H5 Magnus in
a Full Sacrifice mode right now
no he is in all set
top form because his point is the D7
Pawn is his weak spot so if this queen
is distracted by taking on H5 then his
Rook can't success to go to f8 and now
there are all sorts of checkmating
threats down the line the bishop is
pinned The Rook behind it and as Casey
Abel says nobody can survive this end
game against Magnus this is not an end
game yet there's still checkmating
possibilities so Magnus is doing great I
mean that idea that tactical sacrifice
was unbelievable
he's playing with such energy and he's
not panicking in time pressure Jan's
time Advantage has evaporated almost
entirely he's still three minutes up and
for John it's going to be important to
keep some level of complexity on the
board and hope for a mistake sometime in
the next 10 moves
Dion is
going to have to sort of pray that
Magnus Carlson somehow blunders a rook
like he did against Hikaru Nakamura
because the way Magnus has played this
game I mean you know this is giving him
all the confidence and you do not want
to face Max Carson down a point who
feels like he's in great form finding
all of these tactics my goodness
yeah I mean H5 Rook takes F4 and Magnus
just seems relaxed he's fully focused
and losing your first match game with
the white pieces is is not the recipe
for Success so I think Jan is doing the
right thing by taking his time he's
trying to figure out where how he can
maximize the activity between Queen G2
obviously creates a made in one threat I
think Magnus is going to see that
something tells me that he's just gonna
respond with C6 and Robert the more I
look at this the more pessimistic I get
about White's ability to defend against
the onslaught on the f file and
something called a past Pawn that is
going to be made into something called a
queen pretty shortly I appreciate you
informed me of how uh those pawns
Scamper to the other side it's ready to
rumble and Jan his best move might be
trying to trade Queens I mean the
feature chat we just had before with
Casey Abel said no one can survive the
end game against Magnus and I think
after Queen D1 a simple Queen swap yeah
I don't think Jan is really going to
survive that either it's three Pawns in
a rook for minor pieces and it's not
like there's a Target in Black's
position with the Queens off the board
so then black can just choose uh you
spend all the time that he wants
creating a past Pawn running them up the
board and ah Donna this looks miserable
you know actually I I still think that
Queen D1 might be the Lesser evil
because at first I thought hey black
just takes goes rook df8 and white has
no way even hypothetically to free up
The Rook on F1 but that's not quite
accurate white can play King E2 and if
black just sort of nonchalantly pushes
his bond then I can drop back to D3
liberating The Rook from F1 and if
you're not careful these three pieces
are nice and compact they're controlling
all of the penetration squares so after
Rook A1 Magnus will have to be very
careful not to lose uh the pride of his
position the a pawn obviously he is not
just going to blindly push his past Bond
but I think Jan just has to bite the
bullet hunker down and try his luck in
this end game I I don't see an
alternative in the end game you have on
the screen here I think what black
should do is change the variant from
Fisher random to connect four and play
A4 and after Knight D3 play C6 and B5
just like throw this we have B5 C6
whatever order you want but the point is
just create this Pawn chain and then
it's like well where do your pieces go
for white you don't have anything to
threaten and I agree with you that John
would have some chance to survive it
just feels really unpleasant
and this is just not his style John
needs to keep some Intrigue on the board
but I think that's one area he has
matured he has grown as a chessler even
compared to the Beast that Jan was a
couple of years ago he tries to play
objectively and maybe I'm over analyzing
over psychology but Queen D1 is on the
board is making every effort to defend
as objectively as possible this game is
not over Magnus still has work to do
oh it is not a young kid survived this
he'd probably feel like he can survive
anything so he's digging deep trying to
find that internal motivation because he
recognizes that while his position is
bad what happened go ahead go ahead no
you take the other game but finish your
cut no no my thoughts are over if the
other game is exciting so take us there
Donya icaro Airlines flight one has been
cleared for takeoff I think Notre Beck
has well I wouldn't say that he has
blundered but I think his position is
deteriorating at a very rapid Pace let's
rewind for a second after Rook A1 as we
predicted Queen takes A1 Knight takes A1
E4 by notorbeck to cut off White's
Bishop but Hikaru delivering a
well-timed check on H4
Bishop trade and what has the bishop
trade allowed white to do it has allowed
white to swing his Queen to D4 with a
fork against the knight in the rook and
Robert is notabeck just losing flat out
losing material here
yes a very simple answer to your simple
question is yes and wow you were correct
you sort of assessed this position
correctly I was thinking that the Rooks
should be good against the queen but
enough to move Knight defense
he doesn't even allow me to finish my
thoughts or kicking the night away and
Rook F1 check is a counter so that is
what noribbeck is relying on but I mean
to move Bishop G2 now covering that one
thread and oh man five's still hanging
that's such a calm move and look at that
Bishop the hero of the position
defending H3 defending F1 the queen
protecting F2 can white no black can't
play Knight F4 then The Rook hangs now
Robert just loses the Knight on D5 and
that Rook on B8 is still fast asleep and
missing all of the action and Bishop G2
don't ask him twice it's played when
Hikaru smells blood like this Robert you
just feel the life force draining from
notorbeck's pieces
and he just screwed that Bishop into the
square uh he was just like this is a
winning position for me and what a
turnaround notary back stole upon A2 he
knew that he was in the driver's seat
but look at a car now he is relaxed he
was not like this early in the game his
head was in his hand now he's just
looking around be like okay when's the
next game what time is that one start
yeah I'm just taking this one home check
Swatch that King C1 with so unassuming
looking Robert oh I'm desperate I have
to bring my king the goalkeeper has to
come out to kick the corner kick no no
no King C1 was an ambitious move and
that Knight B3 Rook A1 idea was simply
vicious and now the queen demonstrating
its total superiority over Black's
disjointed Rooks
there he is he's looking up that's the
sign he looked up he said thank you to
the chess gods for allowing me to play
this beautiful game I am taking this one
home and stealing game one and this is
bad news for nordbeck who struggled
against Wesley so in his final game yes
he had wrapped up his group he knew
where he was gonna be situated but you
started getting your own head right
Donya you lose one match you lose the
first game of the next he is going to
have to show resilience to uh you know
at a mature level he's a teenager but
he's gonna have to just really find it
within himself to not get frazzled by
what's happened here
yeah I mean the Silver Lining is that he
has lost to the black pieces he's gotten
white next game he's more familiar with
the position and you know he put
tremendous pressure on Hikaru straight
out of the opening so he's just gonna
have to do that again but listen putting
this game out of your mind especially
given the fact let's be totally
straightforward here if Notre back went
with your move Queen F7 I think I would
have assigned maybe 80 90 chance that he
would have won that game he was up upon
he was dominating on all sides of the
board and that thought is so infuriating
Robert we have all experienced it had I
just made one move the results of the
game would probably have been different
and match would have looked different he
has to avoid traveling down that rabbit
hole as he thinks about the next game
wow and maybe he still has some chance
in this position that we're not getting
credit for because let's let's look at
this let's take a step back we know
Hikaru is doing well the engine is
confirming as much black currently has
seven pawns to whites five so even
though uh Hikaru is about to steal a
knight and so he'll have a queen and a
knight it's gonna be for two Rooks and
two pawns and with a relatively safe
King for black maybe there are some
outside chances for Notre back to hold
on to this game to you know just fight
tooth and nail claw his way back just
like Hikaru did in the earlier stages
problem is I don't see a single move I
was thinking about playing something
like Rook D6 but once you give up the
Knight on D5 White's Queen also has the
Sally to F6 should The Rook move away
from the sixth Rank and Castle's Queen
side probably the best that Notre but
can do Hikaru immediately grabs that
Knight on D5 and maybe Rook D6 now maybe
you try to eliminate the pawn on D5 he
goes Rook F5
not totally over I agree Rook F5 and
Rook D6 do the same thing except Rook F5
allows white to push the pawn to D6 so
I'm very curious why he would allow this
maybe he's actually not concerned about
the pawn to D6 but and first glance it
looks a bit off and what else looks off
is 30X time he is under three minutes no
increment until they reach move 30 where
they both get five minutes added to
their clocks as well and that was only
his 18th move played so try playing 12
moves in this position
with under three minutes good luck
good luck is right and Hikaru grabbing
the pawn on G4 allowing the Intermezzo
Rook takes D5 now wait a second Rook
takes D5 ikara just wants to clarify the
position he wants to avoid complications
as he drops the screen back to C3 and
the next movie is going to take on e4
but two Rooks is
that's a large amount of material so
is notabic gonna try to push the Knight
out of C5 no he goes Bishop G6 trying to
cling to this E4 Pawn
I I like that decision because now he's
also freed up his Rook on d8 that Rook
can swing on over to an open file maybe
the f file at some point and he has two
Rooks right the good thing about the two
Rooks versus a queen is that they could
team up on Square so I would bring the
Knight out from A1 to B3 connect your
Knights make sure that they're defended
and finally you know get that one into
the game so obviously hikar Nakamura is
a better position but there are some
situations if we think about it we're
maybe being down this material with
limited other material remaining that
nobody can have some chances and it's
not like White's King is in the safest
spot either and not to be too much of an
email bar Andy but it did drop after
Hikaru plays Knight C2 and I think his
idea is to meet H takes G4 potentially
with the move Knight E3 but Blackstone
not just gonna give these pawns away
that easily he can play Rook G5 and it
really hurts white that the queen is
tied down to the Knight you would love
to play the move not Queen E6 but Queen
F6 here you have to waste another Tempo
protecting the Knight if you want the
queen to travel to F6 and this gives
black black some chances uh to defend
the key squares but listen I'm still
very pessimistic with two minutes on the
clock I just don't see Notre back
holding this for another seven moves I
just don't and did you see Nova kind of
looked to the side I wonder you know if
he knows what movies on I wonder how
that's uh made clear to the players but
there must be a monitor or something but
he did just take on G4 so the Knight C5
as you point out is loose so the queen
Estes they put the E4 Pawn can be
captured uh but you know Knight takes E4
for example for white maybe black just
starts trading off pieces Bishop takes
E4 put a rook behind your pass pawn and
you have two Rooks and two pawns for a
queen and a minor piece that is actually
quite a lot of material it really is
oh there it's all happening
Rook G5 now supporting the pawn and that
pawn gets to G3 you're singing a
completely different tune I think Hikaru
might have played inaccurately the last
couple of moves and now if he has to put
his Quinn on G3 Robert he's gonna have
to defend passively for a couple of
moves at least
and how do you attack right you can be
up material
and that's great news for Hikaru but you
need to attack something because if you
just shuffle your pieces around you're
not actually making progress meanwhile
black has a rook behind a pass Pawn has
a second Rook that can enter the game or
just defend the rook in front of it so
like let's say black does nothing brings
The d8 Rook to G8 and puts a Pawn on C6
maybe depending on how white plays how
exactly does white win this game from a
good position yeah it's I wouldn't you
you know use the Fortress word just yet
but every Pawn is defended by another
Pawn the initial pawn of B7 is protected
by the king and the white Bishop is
going to be blunted in hardcore fashion
if black puts pawns on D5 and C6
this is a rather difficult task that
awaits Hikaru especially if Notre back
can make move 30 in one piece and get
those additional five minutes he starts
shuffling back and forth you start
getting nervous we still have some chess
left to play in this game
eggs when they've hatched sorry I mean
you are right it's not interested in
this game Magnus Carlson is moved 28 in
the other game so they're heading
towards the time Patrol but Magnus not
much time left on his clock
um if I'm reading things correctly so
um I oh my gosh no I don't believe he's
going to zero seconds that uh must be a
dgt relay error we will confirm the
clock there but look at that position
the Knight on D3 does defend the bishop
and F2 but things do seem to be getting
better and better for Magnus
oh it's a knight on me H3 now so I guess
a bunch of moves haven't played and they
just there's one Rook instead of two
oh yeah there's
just one Rook instead of two
and he made his final move with 37
seconds it looks like uh to reach time
Patrol so how in the world did that just
happen
as we look at that beautiful camera
angle Magnus sacrifice another exchange
for another pawn and I think Jan is
probably looking better than he's looked
for the last 10 moves
wow
this is enigmatic
yeah wow I mean now Jan has a a new
lease in life the king for blacks
scooted over to d8 that could be some
problems and yes hakara Magnus are very
very strong but I wouldn't say
necessarily too strong considering the
opponents they have in front of them
yeah I think Jan with some excellent
defensive chances
as they both have made move 30 Magnus is
still better and he's still attacking
and you can see John twirling that on
furiously in fact both of them are on
the right side of your screen as we look
at the two board if you Notre back has
been forced to give up his G3 Pawn but
he has gone to town on White's Queen
side so that game is also I would say
almost a 50 50 kind of position
yeah and what done it means is 50 that
hikara wins 50 draw because the only
target is on D7 and guess what a rook is
about to slide back to F7 to defend that
pawn unless white can either get his own
pawns marching D4 E4 and so on but that
opens up the king to checks and let me
ask you something right when we think
about fortresses we think of potential
draws what happens if one of Notre damex
Rooks is traded for that Bishop is there
a potential to hold a fortress rook and
say four pawns as Queen and two
especially if we can trade pawns along
the way there absolutely is you can
never forget about these types of
defenses I think White's pawns are
nicely situated on D2 and E2 and they
can be used in some cases as a battering
ram you can imagine that epon landing on
E6 if black has only one Rook it may not
be capable of dealing with the opening
of the position but to answer your
question absolutely noderbeck has to
keep an exchange sacrifice in mind but
for the time being he's just chilling on
F7 he is waiting for Hikaru to commit it
and Robert I think Hikaru will have to
push his e-pawn but if he wants to
defeat this Fortress by hooker by crook
he won't be able to do it without the
use of his Pawns
true because he can't just sit and do
nothing otherwise he will not win this
game and meanwhile look at Magnus
Carlson's King in the bottom right hand
side of the screen there a pawn was
just grabbed on B6 the king runs the E8
it might run to F7 next but White's
pieces the bishop on G2 not an H3 those
are also quite vulnerable so what a game
we have what
the duo of games here both are awesome
yeah my eyes are darting to the left and
then to the right and they're darting to
that Bishop on G2 if young drops it back
to F1 the problem is that Magnus grabs
it with his rook and then takes the
Knight on H3 and then potentially also
the pawn on H2 so Magnus the only one
with winning chances but in that
resulting position Robert John kituck is
King away on G1 and with the f file
being open Magnus will experience some
difficulties with his Monarch as well so
that game is far from decided either
no and I'm liking this view you see all
four players sweating it out right here
I mean you look in the bottom left it's
a bishop and a queen trying to go after
black but the black defense is so strong
on the bottom right we have kind of a
chaotic position where black has two
pawns for a piece Magnus have a rook for
a couple miners one Rook was traded for
one minor and the white king the black
king both unsafe so uh that one is up in
the air but my body language Dania
Magnus he's back in his chair Jan is
really uh staring deeply into the
position uh now Magnus they're reversing
roles here I don't know what to make
well the higher space said this is going
to be difficult to convert now for
Magnus I am with you but I think Jan
needs to accelerate his Pace here I
don't see a single alternative to Bishop
G2 to F1 and that position after Rook
takes F1 it's unpleasant White's not
really harboring any winning chances
there but
I mean a check on B8 is totally
counterproductive Robert because it
sends the king to an even safer square
and it opens up an attack on the Queen
by The Rook on f8 so Jan he's taking
golden seconds right now as he drops
down to four minutes the last thing you
want is having this position and having
to survive on the five second increment
along
you know it would be amazing and this is
just uh for all you fish are random
aficionados out there if White's King
and Rook hadn't moved yet if you get on
magnus's board oh you want to throw
Queen ba check and then castle kingside
and deliver The Knockout that happened
in Fisher random right like where you
just forget that somebody can castle and
they go to the other side of the board
and you immediately lose that is
definitely happened to me you had me
fooled there for a second you had me
testing whether that's possible for a
second but of course the king hasn't
just moved it's traveled around the
world and back and landed on its initial
chest Square John continues to think
here what is he contemplating
what moves exist other than Bishop F1
don't have the answer he's just nervous
about giving up those two minor pieces
for the rook and maybe he thinks that
that might just be a losing uh
uh trade off and two pieces of course
more valid in the rook and then one has
a remaining Rook but Magnus now ahead on
the clock ahead on the position uh this
is not good news for Young Who has
fought so badly to this point and Bishop
F1 biting the bullet immediately grabbed
by the rook and Magnus taking the Knight
on H3 deliberate motions there and after
King G1 as I said My worry is that
Magnus will have to use his limited
material to not only pursue the attack
on White's gang but make sure that his
own King is safe especially given that
open f file
yes we could actually have a close-up of
this game here we see uh the dgt relay
is having some issues but the players uh
the king is in the corner the queen gave
it a check and now Magnus can make a
draw on the spot if he wants he can keep
giving that King checks and end the game
but why would he want that his King is
actually safe in comparison to his
opponents uh so this is a position where
Magnus is going to look he's gonna hunt
for a victory uh with the Knight and two
pawns for a rook yeah the only way that
Magnus loses and the disaster strikes is
he blunder some sort of Checkmate along
the f file that ain't gonna happen even
if he loses his a pawn even if he loses
a bunch of Pawns he basically has this
draw in his pocket whenever he wants so
what he's thinking about is how to
properly involve this Knight there's a
bunch of candidate moves he can push his
Pawn up to H3 and create a main thread
on G2 he can drop the Knight into E4 he
can push the a pawn this is such a
difficult position uh to make a decision
in in the context of a classic game much
less a decision when you have four
minutes on the clock and a potential
back rank check on Deck with Queen B8
and Rook F1 a serious force to be
reckoned with
magnets down to three minutes and about
50 seconds he's up a minute on the clock
still but he's gonna be using that
trying to make inroads against that
white king in the corner right this just
need that Knight to jump into F2 for
checkmate not going to be so easy and uh
well in the other game I'm just looking
at both these you see Hikaru and nobody
back nobody's gonna Shuffle that is all
he is going to do like look at his Rooks
he's gonna go Rook H7 to G7 he just
played it and then Rook G7 back to H7
and so on and so forth and he is going
to say that Hikaru is not going to be
able to beat him but you made the point
of this done yet at some point those
pawns for white need to get rolling
because you're facing three defenders in
the D7 Pawn you need to get an E4 E5 E6
something like that to really break open
the black king the problem though is by
pushing your e-pawn white king could be
in some danger not of getting checkmated
but of receiving Perpetual check
yeah and there could even be some
laddermate constructions although the
Rooks have to remain on the seventh rank
for defensive purposes Hikaru continues
to poke in prod he's trying to find the
ideal arrangement for his bishop and
queen the other idea for white is to
play D4 D5 that's kind of a compromise
because you leave the epon in place in
order to shelter the king and you're
trying to use the d-pawn as a batarang
Ram but that notebook could simply
ignore that he could say hey go take my
Pawn on C6 I don't really care instead
Rook F5 he's not even giving Hikaru a
single Tempo to push that pawn up to D5
and Bishop comes back to
G6 it jumps forward trying to dislodge
and disattach the Rooks from each other
can we bring up that board quickly
because I my question I posed earlier
what happens if black takes this visual
I don't want to do that I am just
curious if black takes the bishop on G6
if we can um you know get this going on
here in that position that you have
there
that evaluation what does that say plus
2.5 and that's totally
as much right that is totally it is
territory so there might be a time and a
place for The Rook sacrificing for the
bishop and just creating a draw like
this because your king is close to your
pawns there is no way for the white king
to get in just yet I would be scared to
do this I admit that I'm just always
curious is it possible and it seems
objectively speaking it's possible even
if practically speaking it will often
end in a loss for black and I think the
reason it might end at a loss is this
idea connected with pushing the pawn up
to E5 the point not being to play E6
because every Pawn trade brings black
closer to a fortress rather the point is
to pave the way for White's King to
travel all the way to Black side of the
board and anytime noterbeck pushes his
pawns these pawns become more of a
liability so I think he only goes
through this line if he sees absolutely
no other alternative but your point is
well taken it's very much under
consideration but can he find a way to
keep both of his Rooks alive that's what
he's trying to do
oh but this is starting to look real
dubious now Hikaru can play D5 and man
oh man Notre back has his work cut out
for him in terms of what these two Rooks
have to do
yeah I hate the fact that that pawn is
an A5 now because it becomes a Target
any car screws the bishop into F5 and
quickly Nordic brought the Rook over
there 25 and that's a double attack he
hits the point he hits the fork I think
Notre back is coming apart of the seams
here
yeah no I think it's one of those
moments where if he had all the time in
the world that could have uh figured out
with high degree of certainty that there
might be a fortress at play he could
have found it but with under two minutes
on his clock and look at a car he's just
looking away what's going on that other
board he's like I want to know is Magnus
gonna win is uh Jan hanging in there
he knows that his game uh is in his
hands this isn't quite Gigi yet the one
thing Hikaru has to avoid
and I'm going to show this really really
quickly as neuterbeck contemplates uh
this incredibly difficult position the
one thing Hikaru has to avoid is let's
say a move like Queen B6 because here
the sac on F5 I think just yields an
immediate draw The Rook Parks itself on
D5 cuts the king along the fourth Rank
and then you just chill with your own
King add infinitum but obviously Hikaru
is aware of that and he's going to avoid
that scenario and he won't touch it with
a 10-foot pole as he grabs on on A5
that's very instructive and if that's
the case white will likely have to try
for the move D5 at some point you were
highlighting that earlier maybe first a
queen E5 check just to keep the bishop
on F5 better defended and then go for D5
but he looks like he's going for his
King he's trying to bring his King up as
a weapon but no first queen E5 check
makes sense do not take that pawn on B7
Dania just showed why that would not be
a good idea as tempting as it is to win
free pawns it would allow the sacrifice
that gives the Fortress so Hikaru he
sees it he's calculating how to go
forward from here is it D5 is it giving
a few checks first is it trying to use
the king maybe King to E2 that's oh can
you choose a potential blunder oh look
at that takes that 500 Rookie seven yeah
and you you can give a check but then we
get the drawn for exactly we were just
showing these positions real quick I
absolutely should King E2 puts the king
in the queen in alignment Rook takes F5
you can't take back so you can say oh I
have an intermediate check but as you
are saying Robert this gets exactly to
The Fortress that Hikaru has to avoid
instead he gives a check on A5 and with
less than two minutes on his clock this
game is still far from Over You Gotta
tip your hat to Notre back he made some
blunders in this game but he is doing
everything he can to make hikaru's task
as difficult as possible and Robert one
last thing I'll point out this bishop
has to be very careful if you move it
and say I'm tired of these Rook takes F5
ideas well you're allowing The Rook to
infiltrate F2 and you have to be very
very careful as you pointed out earlier
to avoid Perpetual check
for sure so this still are chances here
for Notre back but with under a
minimalist clock and nearly two for
Hikaru things are looking good for him
uh and on the other game it looks like
Jan is really being so resilient he is
ridiculous fighting he even has chances
to win this game if Magnus overpresses
uh the pawn on H3 looks dangerous sink
his teeth into White's position trying
to allow for a check in the G2 square
but for now with Rook F1 Rook F2 uh
available for White and the H3 upon a
potential Target that does give Beyond
decent chances to hold here it most
certainly does he does have a minute
left on his clock Yan not someone who's
used to playing on increment Magnus
pushing that pawn up to D5 kind of
slicing and limiting the mobility of
White's queen I'm kind of pessimistic
here Robert I think johanna's just gonna
have to be perfect for the rest of the
game but I mean he's playing T3 and he's
gonna play for by the way the game is
over Hikaru is about to win
oh because he went Queen B7 and I
realized that Rook is on G1 in the
bottom left so there is no Rook takes F5
anymore uh because the Rook can't scoop
up the pawn that lands there so Hikaru
for sure is going to win game one that's
a huge achievement for him and
considering how it looked uh in the
early stages after a dozen moves it's uh
something that he is going to be shaking
his head about like cool got away with
one but it is a great book for you to
start this match and magnets down to 15
seconds
oh I'm just trying to figure out where
to go his King runs up
King runs up to E6 allowing white to
take on H3 with a check but Magnus
putting all of his eggs in the basket of
the a pawn he wants that pawn to promote
and in order to do that he will first
have to maneuver his King to safety and
Yana on his last seconds what is he
going to do queen F5 check or is he
gonna take on H3
how do you defend this with no time
I don't have an answer that question I
wish I did King D6 four oh gosh he was
running away and queen F5 check where is
it gonna go though the queen said King
C7 there's a check on E5 how do you
escape the checks and if King did it
you just run away G2 Checkmate that's
the idea for a Max cross in the bottom
right bringing the queen two squares
over in front of the white king and oh
that one's gone oh that pawn is gone but
now nepo's Queen is temporarily out of
commission and that gives Magnus that
one tempo that he needs to push his pawn
and one square away from promotion
oh my goodness meanwhile hikarma
Nakamura on the bottom left is mopping
up he's now up a couple pawns there with
the queen of Bishop Magnus takes a Pawn
on D3 and the bottom right hand side of
the screen you just saw that on camera
but the dgt is just uh struggling today
from locally in well not local to us but
locally in Reykjavik Iceland where the
term is taking place
um so apologies doing the best we can
there but that pawn on D3 scooped up
giving the E4 Square back to Carlson's
pieces
oh my goodness this is anybody's contest
in this overall semis but Magnus and
Hikaru looking good so far well Napo has
to be
with Harmony too and he was hurt by the
fact
making contact with the Rook so he's got
to waste more Tempe and give up even
more pawns to get to that pawn on 18 you
can see on camera there's a queen on B2
there is a queen trade and the Knight
swings over to E4 and 2c3 and goes and
Magnus somehow kept his Pawn alive and
he breaks through with C5 can he get his
King to B2 in time
wow yeah he wants to exchange pawns and
see if I bring the king up and protect
it
so Jan he can prioritize moving his own
King toward the queen side and that is
exactly what he does and Magnus with
evil forcing that pawn off of D4 what is
going on he really just wants to get his
King to scoop up whichever Pawn is
captured then use the d-pawn to run
forward so take on E5 King E7 it's gonna
be a race right now he can also play D4
to Anchor and the Knight but no you're
right he moves the king up I think this
is the draw I think Jan might be able to
save this although Magnus the only one
with chances here
it looks difficult for white here just
because of the night in the ponds but
maybe there's no progress to be made
somehow
okay and that's what Jana's claiming he
basically just has to go back and forth
with his King instead he tries to
reposition his rook and use his King to
defend that ape Pawn oh my God wait a
second though this King for black king
of four that H2 Pawn I feel like will
not be on the board for so long
here it comes and that is exactly great
minds think alike Yan trying to set up
that King side Fortress
and Knight swings on back to E4 okay so
if King D3 there might even be a knight
F2 check you have to look out for oh and
if the king went the other way then the
d-pawn pushes forward and Robert the big
problem is that even if black gives up
The Rook for the knight in the pawn
Black's king is too close to that H Pawn
I think he's winning losing this it is
winning because if the Rook comes back
do you want the d-pawns or D3 D2 and so
on and you won't even be able to get the
A2 Pawn in time because black will
promote so here comes that deepon this
is over
I mean even if black had lost the Knight
it would be winning but here black is
able to keep the Knight and NEPA with
one second on the clock is about to
resign oh and what a finale D1 equals
queen and a handshake from Mr nepo wow
because a night Fork on C3 was about to
happen nepo is not happy at all he was
just about to survive that game oh but
it wasn't meant to be so Magnus Carlson
the world champion shows Exquisite
technique down the stretch to steal game
one and I think what objectively had
been a position that could have been
drawn if Jan had more time but hikar
Nakamura on the other side he won that
game quite smoothly you know at the end
there Donna he just picked up all the
Pawns he picked up all the pawns he
avoided all of the fortresses and he did
it in style notorbeck really with his
back against the wall in a disappointing
first round result but the good news for
the losers is that they have three games
left to play in the match and Yan upon
is she tipping my hat to that defensive
resilience but Magnus Carlson as we saw
in the feature chat does it yet again in
the end game
unbelievable seriously what an epic game
won and I repeat game one that was
because we still have three more games
potentially unless it's a sweep in these
matches and Abdul sitar of Nakamura
Carlson napalmsidanya this is great
stuff
this is an all-you-can-eat buffet that
is why we had to stay on the two camera
review because we needed to give both of
these games equal coverage that is how
epic they were
oh my goodness seat belts still fastened
I can't wait for game two I cannot wait
either but before we take a break along
with the players who do want to give a
shout out to the presenting sponsor of
this coverage because uh Brave means
private browsing and so much more by
default Brave blocks ads and trackers on
every page and video you visit even on
YouTube no ads means up to three times
faster page loads faster streaming and
faster playback it means 35 longer
battery life while saving on mobile data
and internet bandwidth for Android iOS
and desktop get the best browser for
gamer streamers or creators switch 60
seconds at brave.com chess we'll be
right back for more from the Fisher
random world championship this coverage
brought to you by Brave
the only thing better than chess is more
chess so don't miss a moment of the
Fisher random World Championship or the
women's candidates we will be Squad
streaming both events so you don't have
to pick just one simply click this
button at the bottom of our streaming
panel to watch multiple events at once
click again to switch back to a single
screen don't miss a moment of top level
chess with Squad streaming on twitch.tv
chess
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we are back here covering the Fisher
random world champions coverage brought
to you by Brave I'm Grandmaster Robert
Hess alongside me Grandmaster Dale
nerdinski Donya we had an excellent
first round where Hikaru Nakamura and
Magnus Carlson won their games that
would not sound surprising on paper but
given how those games are going
topsy-turvy Donya big wins for those two
well if you want a sales pitch that
promotes the role of Fisher random and
argues that it has a rightful place
alongside classical chess show these two
games and you really don't have to talk
about anything else topsy-turvy
entertaining energetic tactics from
every single player involved at the end
of the day Notre back and yawn they're
the disappointed ones they are the ones
who have their work cut out for them but
what a series of games we've already had
Robert just incredible
that end game from Magnus Carlson I mean
I believe Yonder Palm she had a chance
but we'll look at that a little bit more
later but let's let everybody know I
don't think we've talked about this yet
the prize fund for this event is quite
enormous first place prize is 150
000 so if for example It Card Nakamura
goes on to win he'll take 150k here and
then have a chance in Toronto for the
cgc next week try to another 200k so the
prize funds are huge the players have
great money at stake I could it's 150k
that's a down payment that's 10 Toyota
Camrys that's a thousand Logitech mice
that is just an amazing amazing to see
no it's uh really something every single
place matters so uh even the loser of
today's matches they'll play for the
third fourth place matchup where there
is different prize money third place
it's 55 000 fourth gets forty thousand
to fifteen thousand dollar difference
that is quite a lot but as we see it
from the playing Hall in Reykjavik
Iceland host to the 1972 World Chess
Championship between Bobby Fischer and
Boris bosky not this specific location
but Reykjavik as a host City uh
tremendous chess history there there's a
reason why they wanted to put on this
event so we are very grateful to the
entire country of Iceland which loves
the game of chess yes such a story
Chester Edition and really the
conditions in Iceland are always amazing
I remember playing uh the Reykjavik open
uh one of the sort of most notable and
respected open tournaments on the
circuit uh which happens in March and I
had such a great time exploring
Reykjavik I still have a photo of my
phone of the weather listing the wins
speed at 100 kilometers per hour it was
hard to make it to the playing Hall but
once you did it was an amazing sight
love love playing chess and Reykjavik
and the horizontal rain that happened
which is like daggers to your face uh
it's like hail but it's not even hailing
it's a strange uh feeling but either way
beautiful country beautiful chess
history it's only going to keep on
growing and while this Fisher random
World Championship it's not over yet
there are four players still vying for
the title Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura
they have the inside track right now
based on their game one wins but yonda
Palm she noribeca busatarov they still
have chances to strike back so let me
ask you Dania between the two players
Abdul sitarov and napamshi who's the
better chances to rebound after a
difficult run one defeat
well I think obviously both of them are
facing a very very serious challenge
should they lose the second game we're
not going to say that the match is over
but we haven't had a single 2-0 comeback
in the cgc and coming back against
either Magnus or Hikaru is virtually
impossible so they need to step it up
and they need to do it now in terms of
who has the better chances well Notre
back is the one of the white pieces and
Robert you'll co-signed me on this the
difference between white and black and
fish are random is often minimize you
basically often sometimes see black
getting a much better position three or
four moves in that is unheard of in
regular classical chess with that being
said I still think Notre Beck is the
happier one Jan with the black pieces
against the world champion facing down a
1-0 deficit both of them have a lot of
work to do psychologically as well as on
the board itself
yeah it's just so difficult to recover
in just a few minutes from A Loss that
feels devastating but the players
they've suffered defeats before they
will have to right the ship right here
and now and I think uh given that Magnus
one with the black pieces it's going to
be tougher sledding for yonda palmshi he
gets black in game two we were just
saying that in fish are random sometimes
the player with uh the second move uh
still will get a quick Advantage just
because white will misplay the opening
stage these players can't consult an
engine right they're looking at these
positions with their seconds or with
each other or just by themselves so
they're just trying to do their best and
it's not easy to figure out a position
where your Knight's an A1 and C1 and
things are all over the place it just
doesn't come to your chest brain
naturally and so it's not going to be
easy for the nordbeck and for Magnus to
get an advantage of the white pieces
here as game two begins shortly
indeed and we look at the playing Hall
there are the final preparations being
made and of course sometimes the players
get lucky and predict some they analyze
some positions before the tournament we
saw of course magnus's by now famous I
think it was G5 offering up the bishop
on G7 blitzed out against the car
Nakamura so sometimes the players come
across a position that they have some
experience with but a lot of the time
they are virtually on their own and all
that they can really decide in those 10
minutes with their seconds is what first
move they make they can talk through a
couple of basic strategies for
developing their pieces but more often
than not Robert just because of the
richness of these positions by move
three or four they are entirely on their
own
and tank to bank says that nepo can blow
anybody off the board and recover from a
loss and that normally is true but when
you're playing Magnus Carlsen good luck
to you and I wonder Daniel if we can
actually
um maybe get us the starting position up
and talk about it a little bit because
we did not have that opportunity before
the first games went underway it is a
unique position
um to start with just like many of these
Fisher random positions are so uh you
know the knights being in the corner
things like that it's not an everyday
occurrence so
as we just get back to the start here
and you know we pulled it up Knight's an
A1 and C1 so at first I always like to
look for are there any hanging Pawns in
the position and the answer happens to
be no this is one of those Fisher random
positions where not a single Pawn if a
piece of attacking it is undefended at
the start
yeah it's kind of strange you pointed
out very early on the placement of these
two nights I made a point about a c Pawn
potentially landing on C5 but the
drawback of really playing on the queen
side at all is that your king is
situated on D1 and you want to be very
careful about not making too many King
weaknesses at the start of the game and
I think that explains Robert why the
players uh were so intent both of them
on starting the battle on the king side
and then transitioning it over to the
queen side once they had some pieces
developed and once they had their feet
under them
right because the knights are protecting
the queen side which in this case the
king even using the typical chest
terminology is confusing because when I
say queen side when Don and I say that
we yeah through D1 but that's where the
king is and the queen is on G1 which is
the king side so it's very weird but if
we actually cut the board in half as
Donya is doing right here and you look
at the eighth of the D file we have a
couple Knights over there they're
protecting important squares like A2 but
they're also stepping on each other's
toes a little bit like night to beat I
want to go to me no I don't want to go
to me give me that square don't give me
that square the Superfluous Knights and
if one Knight goes to B3 and the other
goes Knight goes to D3 both Knights kind
of want to go to C5 so the knights are
just vying for the same squares and in
that Silman frame of reference the
Superfluous Knights you already feel
that in the early stages and then you
put a knight on D3 and that Bishop only
one says Hey Brother Hey get off my back
I wanted that diagonal okay you play F3
to open up the bishop it's brother on H1
says hey now I'm buried alive so
whatever you do and that is the unique
Challenge and fun of fish of developing
your pieces and feature random can you
develop one piece without blocking it or
hampering impeding the development of
another
that's exactly the case and the players
are now seated getting ready for the
second game of four for the day so
abusatara gets the white pieces as does
Carlson jandapam she would see him
taking a drink of water over there in
the background we see a Hikaru and Nordy
back but oh gosh look at Magnus Carlson
that's careful now good after game one
he almost fell out don't fall apart
a great reference and from the was it
the world Bliss Championship yep yeah
that was the famous uh polish
International Master falling out of his
chair against the ground Patrol
if you haven't seen that clip where have
you been I'm sorry go watch it right now
you've no excuses that's been around for
a while uh so I know that was just
really funny honestly but we do not hope
to see that one of the players right now
and for Magnus I'm curious how he's
gonna start this game and we are about
to have our answer for the beginning of
the game and another bird from Magnus I
want to say that this is exactly
how the previous game started am I
correct or was it the Hikaru game that
started this way no it was not this game
it was the Magnus game so Jan saying
well what Magnus does is usually pretty
good let me follow suit and that was
bringing that knight from the corner to
B3 I feel like in the moves that we're
about to see in the out of the gates
not gonna surprise us too much I've done
that so many times Robert where at first
I'm gonna play differently than my
opponent then I realized I just played a
strong Grandmaster he played a certain
first move I'm just gonna default back
to what my opponent played
yes and uh we did see I mean we have the
Polaris enlarged in the off screen so
Magnus did bring his knight from A1 oh
wait wait do you see the position by the
way wait look at the board in the bottom
right these boards are wrong so we have
normal chest board something is
happening with the uh dgt relay so we
will address that everybody our
apologies
um what are you talking about they're
exploring opening Theory as we speak
they are blazing new trails
no uh this is just uh
dgt problem so let's just focus on the
players for a moment while we get this
fixed
yeah you can see the players there on
camera Magnus on the right side
motorbeck on the left side hard to make
any hard and fast judgments about body
language thus far as young glances
glance is probably being the wrong word
stares directly into the camera and now
looks back at the board and we will try
to fix these positions shortly right now
we're panning out to a direct view of
the board
yes and Magnus with the white pieces he
is on the clock and Jan spending almost
no time that strategy was working pretty
well for him in game one so we'll see if
he's able to keep that listering pace
that we know Yawn is good for but with
the black pieces with a Magnus Carlson
who's in great tactical form that is not
something you want to take lightly you
can't move too quickly against the world
champion
yeah and you want to avoid slipping into
a bad position especially given the
incredibly delicate match situation Yan
with very little margin for error as
Magnus jumps out to A5 with his Knight
and that is one of the narratives of
this position Robert that pawn on D7 we
talked about it extensively in hikaru's
game and now it's magnus's turn to take
a stab at that pawn
right and the Knight on B6 means you
can't push a pawn there to kick that
night out and this happens in various
openings from the standard position
right the Knight on A5 can be just such
a nuisance for opponent to deal with and
that's why one of the reasons a knight
on B6
G6 b3g3 the corresponding squares are
often frowned upon because uh not only
are they
um pointing to fewer squares because you
the side of the board is the boundary
but you can allow a knight out to square
the A5 and it's just such a pest
it really is and nepo straight out of
the gate has to make a serious decision
how should he defend the B7 Pawn there's
at least two enticing options you can
play C6 that's what he's just played I
think the reason he refrained from
putting the Knight onto D6 is not only
are the knights sort of stepping on each
other's toes but they are on a forkable
spot and when a pawn lands on C5 there
would have been hell to pay instead John
chooses the blunt whites light squared
Bishop and it looks like the positions
on the boards in front of you now
resemble the kinds of positions we see
in this tournament
okay the positions we're supposed to see
resemble you know it resembles nothing
that I am used to but it resembles yeah
um well in the bottom right C6 was
played shutting down the bishop on H1
and the bottom left the move D6 was
played by Hikaru Nakamura keeping
Knights out of C5 and E5 so it's just
interesting how the positions look quite
similar Donya but these little
difference says will add up
they most certainly will and actually
that is a huge difference between these
two boards yeah there are pawns on F4
and G4 but I'm just a tour of has indeed
positioned his Knights on B3 and D3 and
how is he going to deal with the
prospect of hikaru's Pawn pushing up to
C5 I'm being a broken record here but C5
is just such a serious idea the last
thing you want to do Robert is have to
move the Knight back to the first Rank
and unfortunately you might have to do
that because the knights don't have all
that many options
yeah that's uh a bit bizarre but that
may happen the Knight on C8 for hikara
by the way in the top left assuming
bottom left but top left of the board in
the body exactly top right bottom left
queen side King side
[Laughter]
yeah the whole world is upside down
without my fish are random but that
night on C8 from actually for both
players for both Hikaru and for Jan it
can't get out of there very easily and
the games kind of resemble like the
Dutch a bit but there's no D4 so I'm
gonna start stop trying to associate
this with normal chess openings and
terminology I am just going to talk
about specific pieces from now on listen
I'm gonna go out on a serious limb and
say the notorbeck is already off to a
very bad start in this game I think he
has seriously underestimated the power
of this d65 idea and he's taken on F5
and I think he might just have to trade
queens and and try to bail out here but
Robert you think it's fair to say that
Hikaru has essentially already solved
all of his opening problems
yeah I think it is fair and but I think
in fisherman even though the eval
suggests it's fine and the position
looks pretty good there's still these
odd characteristics that you need to
look out for that you don't fully feel
comfortable with the resulting positions
yeah but if the Queens are traded black
gets control of the G file black
controls the center by playing C5 Hikaru
just looks so relaxed and I think ever
since he trapped Notre back screen on A2
it just feels like there's been such a
psychological shift to shift in momentum
and as neuterbeck leans
toward the board you can see over on the
top left
he has some serious serious work to do
to come back in this match and
he starts this work by shifting his dark
squared Bishop up to H4 aiming at
hikaru's E7 pawn another ridiculously
unconventional Arrangement the bishop on
H4 ending the king that's on d8 Robert
it's even hard to say these squares
yeah it's like what is Bishop H4 when is
that
yeah yeah Bishop K5 what e one weird uh
but it's what you were saying before by
the way at least um in these games uh
that having the black pieces isn't
statistically the same disadvantage
because I think just people don't really
know what to do and sometimes just right
out of the opening you can see a player
getting Advantage with black and we have
been seeing that in this event yeah I
mean in some situations you could go so
far as to argue that black might have
almost a a practical Edge because white
is the first one who has to make
seriously committal decisions about
developing and black has the luxury of
either copying the opponent which is
often a solid strategy or taking a
different approach having essentially
learned from your opponent's mistakes
right and we saw magnets that look like
on the he was making a move he's really
thinking hard here all players are
diving into the position and all right
so Queen trade in the game between
nordeback and Hikaru on the other game
the Queen's still on the board no G
takes f-pawns to make that Queen trade
happen and I think for Hikaru
you have to be happy I mean it's just a
queen trade like there is no real risk
in this position
yeah he car was thinking hard about
whether or not to capture that Queen on
G8 I'm guessing he already took it and
yeah yeah continuing to have relay
issues unfortunately
um but you know the players very
concentrated right now and this is good
news for Hikaru he looks much more
comfortable than he did in the early
moves of game one
and I think we're going to see cars
making some risks in this end game I
think he knows listen he wins this game
with black the match basically ends
confident he's felt throughout this
tournament I think we're going to see
Hikaru stepping quite intensively on the
gas pedal but speaking of stepping on
the gas pedal it's Notre back stepping
on the gas pedal pushing his Pawn up to
B4 the evob are hating that move and I
think it might be because of the
response C4 what do you make of this
Robert does he want Knight takes C4 and
Bishop D5
but that doesn't work because of Rook G4
but just good tactical eye by you to
even see that Knight C4 knights from
Bishop D5 is really clever but too
clever for your own good actually you
can attack either piece The Rook or the
bishop yeah just a simple move is
sometimes just the best and but
seriously that's something to keep an
eye out for because uh that kind of
tactic is easy to overlook and I think
that noribbeck is going to regret his
decision to play B4 I think he's just
gonna dislike his entire position
because where's that Knight going by the
way oh
it has to go back to E1 and then Hikaru
could basically do to Notre back when
notrebeck was supposed to do to him and
build up a massive Pawn Center by
repositioning the epon to E6 the d-pawn
to D5 Robert blunting the bishop and
that knight from C8 can perfectly move
into D6 and look at this Knight on A5
yeah it's pressuring B7 but that's the
only thing it's doing and if a black
pawn lands on D5 that Knight is going to
be entirely stranded
yeah this looks very precarious the 985
might get trapped I'm with you it looks
like after a series of normal moves for
Hikaru the Knight is just going to be
stuck and there's no way to get it out
so that's the worst part now this is
really not good for Notre I think he's
feeling that pressure before that I
think he feels like he must win he feels
like after losing game one he needs to
strike back in game two so he is
exerting too much pressure on himself
and that's why moves like B4 happened
he's trying to force the narrative and
that's just not something that ever
works against Hikaru Nakamura who is now
playing quickly and confidently and I
think we're gonna see upon land on D5
and then upon land on E6 and Notre back
is in Dire Straits right out of the
gates here it's only move 10 and white
is already
facing the very unfortunate possibility
of going down two points
and if he loses game two I know that
there's always a chance especially when
we talk about players as strong as
abusotara but no you're not coming back
in Sakara Nakamura he is in great form
right now after a shaky start in game
one ever since then I feel like he's
played tremendously well including in
this game and I think black's moves are
so easy here done in D5 E6 next two
moves clear and after that sure there's
a bit of a debate on how to continue but
for the next batch seems very
straightforward yeah and you can just
chill after you put your knight on D6
you don't even really have to rush
there's ideas uh like what you hint to
that moving the night away from B6 and
replacing it with a pawn literally
trapping white snide on A5 so Notre back
is worse on all three sides of the board
you like to talk about this black is
control of the G file that's the king
side in the center well black will have
total superiority on the queen side
white is stuck with this incredibly
awkward uh Knight in Exile on A5 so
man tough tough sledding here for Notre
back and because White's pieces are so
misplaced even King safety is better for
black so if D5 is that been and then D3
why trying to Chisel at the pawn then
the Knight comes to A4 and into C3 and
that's a fork that you're not gonna be
happy to face and ugh just really bad
news okay let's uh you know let's let's
change the scenery a little bit let's
leave Notre back uh to this very
difficult defensive task
perhaps we could switch to the two board
view for a hot minute here you can see
the Queens still on the board in the
Magnus Carlson game the black king has
castled King side Robert so kind of an
interesting development there and once
again much like in the Notre bag game
that 1985 that Carlson Knight on 85 is
also in a fair bit of trouble
yeah no it's uh not a piece that is
happily placed on the rim it's feeling a
little bit dim though in the bottom
right hand side in Carlson's game at
least B6 is not going to be possible
yeah foreseeable future because the
bishop on H1 the 95 team up on that C6
Pawn so it's gonna be a little bit
harder for Jan to continue here whereas
for Hikaru I mean the position
sort of plays itself it really does and
Notre back trying as quickly as he can
to get his remaining pieces
and arouse them from their sleep the
night coming out to F3 icaro deciding
against pushing that pawn up to D5 for
the time being I suppose that there is
no rush with that move
D just has to try to generate some
activity maybe swing that Knight over to
G5 maybe find an opportunity to play D3
but
as you pointed out D3 always runs into
Knight B6 to A4 how does he even
coordinate his Rooks
well I think that you're right 95 is a
threat so H6 would be uh the move that I
would play and let's not forget that
white can still Castle Queen side I
don't know if that's a good decision
let's not forget okay
I wasn't trying to call anybody out
very good friend and co-commentator here
but in in that game right there is the
possibility that White Castles Queen
side which
um takes the sting out of Black's night
jumps if white is in fact gonna go move
the pawn to D3 so if we pull up that
game uh we can just show that yeah I
think the move Knight G5 as you were
mentioning oh wow he plays C3 not caring
about Knight G5 at all
C3 by Hikaru Nakamura what a committal
move opening up the bishop and I think
this is a prophylactic measure against
Knight G5 should white drop the knight
in the bishop will capture on A2 and
after Rook A1 Robert it may seem that
the bishop is trapped but in fact it is
not you have the D5 Square which is
secured by the Knight and in the event
of a trade all white has is one paper
tiger of a check on E6 it gives
absolutely nothing and White's position
collapses so kind of an active
prophylactic move by Hikaru Nakamura how
do you think Notre back is going to
respond to this with a sigh of relief
because his net na5 can in the future
Venture back to B3 now you don't want to
rush that move just because the C4
Square will be useful for a black piece
but I'm just pointing out that now all
of a sudden if he's playing with A3
saving that pawn keeping um the material
even maybe his Knight will just come
right back to B3 in the near future and
try to stabilize the position
yeah and you can do that immediately you
can you can actually still Castle Queen
side that's not totally out of the
question
and obviously you have to reckon with
the loss of the A2 Pawn but you could
argue that now the position opens up and
all of a sudden Black's King starts to
feel itself a little bit uncomfortable
especially if this knight from F3 moves
on to D4 threatening to move to B5 and
to capture the pawn on F5 and this is
exactly what Notre back needs he doesn't
need necessarily an objectively good
position he's a long way out of that he
needs to start making Hikaru feel
uncomfortable especially given how
risk-free hikaru's position has appeared
just a couple of moves ago I think
Castle's Queen side is a serious
defensive attempt here
yeah and it looks so miserable for
nobody back a few moves and I actually
don't like the bishop F7 for this reason
because with hikara's follow-up he is
freed up nordic's pieces so all of a
sudden he can threaten moves like Knight
G5 or in the position you just showed
the Knight swinging at the center of
Knight D4 the Knight A5 is no longer in
danger of being trapped so with all that
in mind I think ikar probably is going
to regret not going for the bind with D5
E6 and so on where all of his pawns were
limiting the scope of his opponent's
pieces
yeah and this this is a very very
important decision here for Notre back
one that he should make in a timely
fashion he's already down to 15 minutes
where again we're only 11 moves in
that's just what I love about Fisher
random it's already an end game there's
already been so much contact between the
two armies and you know we've barely
made a Baker's Dozen moves it's crazy
so Baker's Dozen is 13. I apologize
right
what's 11. yeah
makers doesn't
I don't have the answer all right uh no
just the time it's just the time to make
a wish you know 11 11. so A3 was the
choice of nerdy back there and you know
just like Hikaru in game one where
noribbeck with black sees the advantage
took that A2 Pawn but then Hikaru was
able to fight back it feels like
abusitarov in the near future he's
getting those chances for himself I mean
he's only a few moves away from
coordinating completely the Knight on C8
is not getting out without some help
from another piece moving out of its
path so all right it's just a position
you could feel a little bit better about
Bishop sliding back from H4 to F2 to try
to put a piece on D4 uh I still prefer
black obviously but I think that
notibeck at least feels like he has some
chances yeah and generally given his
stylistic preferences the more open the
center the more chaotic the position the
more comfortable Notre back starts to
feel we know how incredibly tricky he is
and that is a Hallmark of every player
in this exciting new Young Generation
whether it's notabeck or nehal or Arjun
all of these players who are now 17 and
18 and have crossed 2700 they are so
wildly resilient you just can't easily
bring them down and the smoothness with
which Hikaru converted that advantage in
the previous game is really an exception
to the rule and in this game I think
we're going to see a lot more Intrigue
despite the bad start from nutterback
yeah no he even looks more poised I just
look you know he he seemed very
disheartened after losing game one but
here in game two he's finding more
chances for himself and the clock it's a
slight lead for a car there but plenty
of time for both players and I think
that it's just a matter who is going to
proceed better in the upcoming series of
moves
indeed and Hikaru taking a very
significant think here trying to decide
between continuing to operate on the
queen side with something like Knight A4
or making a slower prophylactic move
such as your earlier idea maybe it's
time to push that pawn up to H6 and
cover the G5 square but not an easy
decision at all
or the American Grandmaster yeah because
H6 which he just played it's one of
those moves that you know is useful but
you also feel like it's slow you're not
actually creating threats of your own
you're stopping your opponent's threat
which is necessary in chess but it's
like a position where you am I
maximizing am I getting the most out of
the Dynamics here where white is kind of
on his black Blackfoot back foot so yeah
he plays H6 good move by Hikaru just
trying to restrict whites pieces as best
he can so it's uh early stages here and
the other game I'm looking at
I'm just trying to you know wrap my head
around what's going on there immensely
complicated but starting to look like a
normal position for nipponishi and an
abnormal one for Carlson
yeah this is really does resemble a
Dutch with not only that pawn on F5 but
White's pawns on D4 and F4 black spawn's
on D6 and C6 is something you often see
in the Leningrad as well so the move
uh is blacks Carlson has just shifted
his Queen over to F3 B6 it is important
to indicate it's still not possible
because the C6 spawn still hangs and
Robert I think you called it that is not
a problem the black can really solve
black can never really turned B6 into a
serious threat so Carlson is fine
chilling on A5 for the time being and in
the worst case scenario if you can push
his b-pawn up to B4 and vacate an escape
Square on B3 for his Knight so this game
is not going to be defined by the 995 I
think it's going to be defined I don't
know on which side of the board maybe in
the center maybe black will try to push
his Pawn to E5 and that is one of the
sort of ideas behind the way that Magnus
has positioned his pieces he's trying to
make it as difficult as possible to NEP
for nepo to free himself with the
typical E5 Pawn push
you know what I was just doing while you
were talking besides listening or in
additional listening I was looking if
any of White's Rooks head mood or if the
king and move so why can Castle in
either direction right now and that's
important to keep in mind because that
King on D1 may go over to G1 or it may
go to C1 with the Rook on B1 sliding to
D1 in its stead so just want to make
sure that everyone's aware that in the
game between Carlson and the palm tree
that Magnus is able to Castle and the
last one played by Young E8 to d8
what a sneaky little move he is trying
to go 96 now I mentioned that B6 is
never a problem but 96 is actually a
massive threat it wins The Pawn on D4 so
I think Magnus his hand is forced he has
to play the move before and press the
eject button in order to obviously to
defend the Knight so that 96 can be met
with E3 or Knight B3
and is he looking at some kind of E5
with the queen on d8 and the King on D1
as well is there like some sort of
tactic there you mentioned the G5 Pawn
so I feel like it's a double threat 96
threatens to win a pawn because the 985
and the pawn on D4 are both under attack
and also this E5 move just trying to pry
open the position King safety is
Paramount Black's King tucked over there
on G8 White's King on D1 kind of a no
man's land but the fact that white can
Castle might become more important than
ever if black strikes in the center with
E5 also I draw your attention to the
clock Magnus experiencing clock problems
in both of the first two games in the
first game he managed to surmount that
problem with very rapid and accurate
play in the critical moments but here
the position hasn't even opened up yet
and he's already down to nine minutes so
after B4 E5 I would pay very little heed
to the evaluation bar this position is
chaotic it can absolutely go either way
before is on the board there's after
this move E5 I think white is fortunate
that there are no useful discover checks
what does that look like if the D file
is cleared I have a de5 de5 knight takes
E5 Bishop E5 Pawn takes there's no
useful check with the bishop 1 D7 you'd
love to like Bishop takes own Pawn on C6
on F5 or Bishop G4 some move like that
but the only moves it has Bishop E6
check or Bishop eh check and that's not
actually creating a big threat so white
can successfully start taking these uh
Pawns in E5 and that whoa E5 is played
and this might be we're gonna get this
position I think we're gonna get
precisely this position now of course
black is under no obligation uh to to
deliver a discover check so Queen takes
G5 is very much a possibility here Jan
can try to get his Rook to d8 maybe
reposition the Knight on the blockading
E6 square or you could give the check on
E6 not in order to win material but in
order to try to get black skin to move
to E1 and lose castling rights one way
or the other I think we're going to see
John recapture this Pawn on G5
okay we see a double capture D takes E5
okay and now it's a big decision from
Magnus and I'm looking as clot Dania he
is has half the time that Jan has here
and nepo just using the clock as a
weapon is Magnus F takes E5 he just
likes Knight md3 yeah he like that
Knight is a nice stabilizing piece again
it's not that he's trying to defend
against the discovery he's trying to
keep this Knight as a general kind of
supervising piece uh to keep the center
closed and here
I think John's hand is virtually forced
I can't imagine that he will be able to
resist that delicious morsel on G5
I don't know maybe 96 is possible here
it's like no but Queen G5 there's one of
the H4 H5 very quickly just yeah go for
Black's King that's a worry
that's definitely where also the queen
doesn't have that many good squares
after H4 if you drop back to E7 you run
into Bishop C5
and green H6 is sub-optimal because
you're stumbling and bumbling around on
the king side while white storming up
his h-man
not looking all that Pleasant for the
queen after Queen takes G5 but if not
for Queen takes G5 the only other move
that really comes to mind is F4 that
just to open that Bishop on D7 maybe
you'll go to F5 but as soon as I say
that it looks like Jan has captured this
Pawn on G5 he says I have no fear uh
breakfast this morning yeah no but he's
even material like let's not forget
about that that's six pawns uh each and
Black's Pawn structure is actually
better because they're a double isolate
e-pawns for white I think the reason the
evaluation bar prefers white is some of
the activity that he's about to get I
think H4 H5 looks like a great idea for
Magnus and we should mention once more
white can still Castle in either
direction
yeah and like you said Black's pieces
haven't all finished putting their
clothes on in the morning yes did he did
he go Queen E7 after H4
whoa did he isn't that that's what it
looks like tomorrow I do see a piece on
E7 I hope it's not a knight because that
would not be good he did flick when he's
seven so he's sacrificing
I find it impossible to believe that he
missed Bishop C5
no but I mean we can even zoom in on the
board for a second here and we see that
the last moves were H4 the queen went
back to E7 and Magnus didn't even want
the exchange he says my Bishop on the
dark scores is very strong let me just
play H5 and go after Jan's King and he's
keeping Bishop C5 in reserve he might
play it in the event of G5 another
reason against playing Bishop C5 Robert
is that you would have lost the H4 pawn
and that pawn is the only battering ram
that white can use to shatter Black's
King side which is precisely what Magnus
is doing the H file has opened up whoa
the G file is open for white so it's a
semi-open file the HR is completely open
and this is the good thing about not
having castles is The Rook on F1 is not
blocked by this King that would have
been on G1 and he castles queen size oh
oh my gosh we know what he wants he
wants both of his Rooks coming to the
party he wants blood and he wants to get
that Bishop off of H1 as quickly as
possible and put a rook in its stead and
maybe even put the other Rook on G1
Robert I'm not doing any calculation
here and obviously nepo's still up 10
minutes on the clock or so maybe eight
minutes now but this is getting scarier
and scarier for black
and nepo continuing to Blitz out his
moves
I might be a strategy in this game he
might not even be looking for the best
move every single turn he's saying
Magnus is under seven minutes and has a
bunch of moves to make
he's positioned his Knight on B6 putting
pressure on White's Queen side currently
both of the queen side pawns are
protected by the respective Knights on
D3 and A5 but the situation is far from
stable especially if Magnus diverts all
of his resources to the king side
and we just saw the moves Rook G1 oh
Bishop eight player eight just defensive
maneuvering for Jan and well the white
king isn't exactly that safe either your
pawns on B4 and C4 at this point for now
both are defended but it isn't exactly
the most stable situation over there and
Black's next move can likely be Bishop
to G7 and how exactly is White gonna
check my EU to go Bishop G2 Rook H1
bring the queen to the H file and even
once you get a queen H7 check it's not
actually mate so it takes a lot of time
for white to even launch this attack and
in the meantime for black maybe you
start pushing your g-pawn I know that's
strange but you can play G5 at some
moment to actually keep that pawn uh in
a better defended Square yeah and listen
it's hard to attack without the services
of your Knights and white is nowhere
near being able to involve the knight in
the attack maybe Knight D3 to C5 is an
eventual possibility but even that move
doesn't do all that much the 996 is
protected by the queen uh so so let's
not pretend that just because the H file
is open it's somehow just automatically
translates to Checkmate Magnus has a lot
of work to be done and he's only got
five minutes to do this work uh and 10
moves to make until uh the additional
five minutes on move 30.
right and then D3 is doing a very
important job of defending the E5 Pawn
so this configuration of pieces it looks
like it's not very stable From magnus's
perspective he needs to try to figure
out how to attack I mean queen H5 is one
move that comes to mind just exploding
the pin on the G file he starts with
queen H3 it's instead and I think that
makes more sense because Queen H5 would
have been parried by just blocking the
pin on getting up yeah I was like all
right just gonna take a little stroll
here but for
for Magnus he moved his Queen out the
way so Bishop F3 Rook H1 other Rook to
G1 that is the onslaught that he's
looking for I would be terrified to have
this position against the world champion
and the ball is squarely in yon's court
Jan has to figure out either a way to
douse the Flames of the initiative with
maybe a move like Queen H7 or whip
something up on the other side of the
board as unsafe and as unstable as these
pawns are I think they're stable enough
to buy Magnus a couple of Tempe enough
Tempe to generate decisive King side
threats I think Jan's in a lot of
practical trouble here
Knight to D7 it looks like he played the
move very quickly did not think for a
particularly long period of time there
and
he's giving up so Knight D7
um if we just put them the board quickly
the A7 Pawn can be captured I would not
go upon grabbing this position that's
just opening up files for the black
world
it most certainly is Rook A8 and B6 and
you know you want every one of black
spots is actually doing white a
tremendous favor here so Magnus he has
to defend E5 you don't want to open up
this bishop on h8 but how does he do it
without disrupting the coordination of
his pieces
is that a rhetorical question am I
supposed to answer that because I know
you're supposed to answer that
I was asking specifically Robert Hess
maybe the other commentator can answer
I was like Bishop G3 but that feels way
too defensive I feel like I'm only
reacting to the threat you created the
eval bar is very high after the move
Knight D7 so Bishop G3 doesn't look like
a move like Bishop takes c6's spot I was
I was about to mention that I played it
what a move and this is a complete
transformation of the advantage what
Magnus is saying is that after BC Knight
C6 yeah black and play Queen H7
congratulations you earned yourself a
queen trade guess what white now has
three three past pawns on the queen side
and look at how discombobulated and
passive blacks pieces are on the king
side
what an idea no Magnus really evaluate
that properly because he sees that he'll
have a pawn storm the best black can do
is trade off those queens and hope that
the minor pieces will out duel a rook
but Bishop takes C6 I mean a shot out of
thin air if you're young to Palm machine
because he was moving quickly he was
just blitzing Magnus and now look at him
does that look like a guy who
anticipated Bishop takes C6 it most
certainly does not and guess what you
might say well didn't we just say that
white shouldn't touch the pawns on the
queen side well this is the only Pawn
that you can touch because if black
doesn't take the bishop that Bishop is
swinging back to D5 and terrorizing
black along this diagonal I don't see an
alternative for yawn he's gonna have to
take on C6 and for the second time in
two games he's gonna have to deal with a
bloodthirsty Pawn Phalanx on the queen
side
this time it's going to be three pods
rather than one and I agree with the
higher space 960 chest gives so many
cool texts Bishop on H1 that Bishop
started there it had not moved to this
point and then wham bam thank you yawn
C6 give me all your pawns on the queen
side and here comes the pawn storm so
what is Yan gonna do queen H7 to you
know my eyes to my intuition just feels
like it's going to be losing in the long
run so he plays Queen G7 that's exactly
what I was gonna recommend I see the
eval bar is going Sky High it may be a
losing move but I feel like Queen H7
would have lost anyway from the
perspective you're playing Magnus
Carlson and game where he's three pass
Pawns of the queen side so you have to
try to keep things messy and that was
move 23. Magnus has to make the next
seven moves in under three and a half
minutes and the yawn it has to be on a
high alert because he will not get
another I mean he has to pounce whatever
chance Magnus gives him and Magnus now
taking this time once again he is not
rushing with Knight takes B what he's
saying is that this Knight is a
tremendous asset for right I think he's
seriously contemplating a move like B5
but at the end of the day given the time
situation I think Magnus kind of has to
cash in his chips and cash in his chips
he does not Queen F3
by Carlson
and the email hates that move he's
trying to get to D5
but probably because of uh what you're
saying is that the queen F3 Rook C8 just
like savior
yes
and now there's a discovery against the
queen Knight dc5 and all of a sudden
Black's pieces start to coordinate
really well Robert this battery don't
sleep on it because the E5 Pawn is a
very very flimsy cover
and I mean you're showing what might
happen Queen D5 was played Rook takes D6
might be the only move here and as
you're indicating Knight D7 to C5
move to uh followed up with the queen of
C6 is loose in the Skirmish of tactics
here towards the center the E5 Pawn will
fall and if that pawn Falls I think many
of Black's problems are solved I think
Magnus simply overcooked it I think he
over thought it in the critical moment
he should have grabbed the Rook it still
would have been a very double-edged
position we see the danger of just
parroting the eval bar yeah it gave plus
three guess what White's position was
incredibly difficult to handle anytime
your opponent has four minor pieces all
of which are threatening to jump out of
the cage and I think if nepo grabs on C6
he will have the best position he's had
all game long
and if we just go back a quick moment
when Queen g7's plays what we were
talking about Queen G7 according to the
engine was worse than Queen H7 but
Magnus could have played so many quick
moves after Queen H7 instead trading
Queens taking on B8 taking on A7 and so
on that Magnus would have reached time
Patrol with a huge advantage and
probably would have win that position 95
out of 100. so Jan made the best
practical decision and now he needs to
follow it up with a good decision in the
live board with Rook takes C6 and Knight
DCI that doesn't end the game plenty of
life remaining there yeah but E5 will
collapse and that all of a sudden gives
breathing room for yawn's pieces but I
love that he's taking his time he can
sense that Magnus is kind of losing the
grip on the position Jan sees Rook take
C6 this move is on his radar he's also
considering ways to try to keep his
material advantage I think the only
feasible alternative is Queen F7 but
this runs into Rook takes G6 check and
this is most certainly not what you want
especially given Rook day C6 Robert he
might also be thinking about the
follow-up move which players sometimes
do he might have already decided on
taking on C6 but he's thinking you
should I play Knight C5 or should I play
a calmer move like Queen F7 in the
consequent position
and that's smart time management Blitz
skills by nepo because what he's doing
is he's trying to keep Magnus on the
clock though you don't want to make a
move and then Max is an obvious reply
and then you have to think again he
wants to make a flurry of moves so Rook
C6 with Ignite C5 and then have Magnus
figure out the position without having
looked at it in advance because actually
looking at the position on the board
helps you as you go forward in your uh
variations and your trees so a big
moment here in this one how is hikar
doing oh gosh very very well indeed I
think it's almost over
yeah Sakara looks like he's winning game
two let's go to our lovely two camera
view here as we see Hikaru on camera top
left his game on the bottom left and he
is taking all of Notre back abducator
response I think this is resignable
and the reason why is a tactical
sequence right Bishop can take the
knight in the bottom left but then when
the pawn takes back yes Black's Bishop
is hanging but so is White's Knight so
that is why he was able to steal that
pawn in the center and the eval bars
sinking to the bottom and that may sink
near me chances of winning a second
world championship title unbelievable
performance by Hikaru taking somebody
who ran through the field preliminarily
maybe that lost to Wesley so Robert
maybe that impacted Notre back in a
subtle way but all credit to Hikaru
Nakamura this second game with the black
pieces has been so smooth and he clearly
managed to navigate the complications
once the Center opened up
and I think his pose says it all he's
basically already done all the thinking
that he needs to do at this point the
position plays itself
yeah he is just up a bunch of Pawns here
too if I'm my math is correct the 985
still hasn't moved and yeah look at
norbeck's face he knows that this one is
look at you Mr history major counting
all the pawns correctly
I know I'm an overachiever
now this is uh there's just nothing to
analyze I mean we can go to the game but
I there's just not much to talk about if
Notre back does not take on B6 the
Knight on A5 remains stranded and he car
was planned maybe put the bishop on e4
move the Rook away from H3 and promote
the H1 it's really as simple as that
right and that's why Hikaru does not
look particularly entertained he's like
this game's over I don't even need to
think much it is anymore and On The
Other Board things are heating up
between Magnus and yawn uh the move
Bishop F7 just opening The Rook on f8
yeah opening up that Rook towards the
queen side and the E5 Pawn can be
captured but a queen trade probably
isn't what Yan really wants look at how
many pawns white hat has there it's five
on three but really it's like these
three in the center are just marching up
the board and oh gosh
D4 by Magnus continuing to spice things
up the drawback of that move though
Robert that pawn on C4 is now like Hey
Hey where's my Defender but if you try
to attack it in frontal fashion with
Rook C8 it can shift up to C5 and then
all of the pawns are defending each
other
what a crazy crazy position
right and Magnus has one move to make D4
was moved 29 so he's a minute and a half
for an additional move that is plenty of
time for the world champion but right
now is a big opportunity for Jan Napoli
so he can put more pressure on Max's
King he can pressurize the pawns that
are in the center C4 you mentioned D4 uh
could also become a Target at some point
but I just don't see the clearest way
through and look at magnus's Queen
Slither into the E7 squared I feel like
black could lose in like two moves yup
absolutely you could blunder some sort
of Rook takes G6 tactic the queen
beautifully slithers is the best word it
knifes its way into the paint into
Black's position and nepo delivering a
side check on H6 is his own Queen going
to take a trip into White's side of the
board well then Rook takes G6 Robert
becomes a force to be reckoned with
yes you were mentioning that idea and D5
another threat to remove the defender of
The Rook on d8 so he made Rook D2 but
doesn't that blunder the E5
Bishop takes C5 you're absolutely right
oh that's a one movement what is that
move you I knew it was right into the
pin it was the first move after time
control Woody
Notre back has officially resigned
Hikaru has one we won't go to that game
just updating everybody Hikaru is up to
zero the game is officially over
did you see Magnus Bishop takes E5
slowly his head and Jan is like all
right I'm gonna do what Dania says when
I hit a good position drink some water
and if I'm reading the evaluation bar it
says a minus three and change that
turned the game around completely that
is a shocking mistake from the world
champion who's made polenta official
random Championship another one move
blunter another one and Magnus had made
time control he had those five extra
minutes Rook D2 is inexplicable and I am
usually the first person uh to justify
blunders and explain that the position
is complicated Robert this one is
totally out of left field this one is
crazy
he's like cursing himself he's really
upset about this because that was a one
move mistake the D4 Pawn is pinned if
you take a bishop you lose a rook with
check and the bishop and everything
falls and look at Magnus he cannot
believe it he is beside himself because
just go before Rook to D2 uh for a
moment on our analysis board here he
just plays King B1 and the complex game
continues this is a mess both sides have
chances who knows but Rook D2 ends the
game on the spot essentially giving away
such an important Pawn that left the
bishop blockaded uh controlled in the
corner now that Bishop is springing to
life D4 is hanging Bishop F4 is piling a
pressure on a pin piece this is just
terrible no that was simply a pawn you
could not afford to lose and Magnus
looking to the side and just the
consternation is evident we can feel it
all the way in the USA he's played the
move King C2 unpinning his Rook but it's
a dollar are short a day late and yawn
Robert he has to continue being accurate
the game is not completely over he's a
couple of moves away from winning but
Magnus is not just going to go down
without a fight here how should Yan keep
his foot on the gas pedal here what
comes to mind for you
I think for starters he should take a
couple minutes because uh you're right
Magnus against ferosev earlier in the
group stage he completely blundered and
he was able to salvage a half point from
that blunder Jan is in a great position
however it's not that clear his king is
not the same as king we've seen
um the queen on E7 is just poking a
prodding A7 is loose there's pawns on B4
C4 and D4 that might go up to C5 and D5
so while we acknowledge that black is
much much better it's a position where I
think that Jan needs to calm himself
because I'm sure there are nerves at
play right now and does he just Retreat
Bishop G7 that's the move I like most
shielding the black king making sure
you're not hanging any pieces but also
acknowledging that the pawns will start
mobilizing towards your king uh and
towards the other side that's such a
mature move Bishop G7 you know you're
not resting on your laurels you're
bringing every everything back to home
base making sure everything is defended
and Robert another important factor is
that D5 doesn't actually carry a single
threat not only that it opens up a
pathway for the black queen to access
the C4 pawn and that Rook on D2 is the
bane of White's existence D takes C6
Queen takes D2 is simply Checkmate but
yan yan taking a more concrete approach
as he captures the pawn on D4 and
something tells me that we are in for a
couple of Adventures in this game you
don't seem like you like this move all
that much
I I think I'm now understanding why it's
acceptable it's like what happens to
Rook Gita D1 it looks like you're just
piling a pressure on a pin piece but
there's the move Rook E8 as you're about
to play attacking the queen that way
your Bishop is free to go now after uh
rookie ate there I think there's a queen
trade on H4 and well there are a bunch
of Pawns and white has on the queen side
so I feel like Magnus he's the type of
player who will look at this position
and say well I don't see a way to to
lose right away which means that maybe I
can survive get listen anytime the
Queens are off the board against Magnus
you are feeling that those butterflies
in your stomach he can pull anything out
in the end game this is undoubtedly a
winning position for black but that c
Pawn runs pretty fast the rook and
infiltrate to D7 Yan
still has to demonstrate a lot of
precision I think we're very likely to
see this end game appear on the board
and no move yet from Magnus
what about Rook E1 maybe that's a
trickier way
oh to induce the end game I don't know
just kind of throwing out possible
defensive moves
yeah I guess black will take the bishop
on F2 and then white takes the Rook on
d8 and
against keeping the Queens on the board
there's also something to be said for
that for the time being
there is also Queen takes D2 but this is
I think a situation Robert very
instructive that you want to avoid
Bishop F6 allows Queen takes d8 and
white picks up both the rook and the
pawn on A7 and if you take on F2 then
you get a position where the queen is
uniquely positioned to supervise White's
passers this I think is anybody's game
and rookie one is on the board
rookie one call by you
oh it was a great call by you there I
think that black should just take on F2
uh White is able to take on d8 in that
position after Bishop two Rook d8 Knight
d8 Queen takes d8 it's still going to be
two minor pieces two Bishops in this
case against a rook but Black's King I
don't think is in a tremendous amount of
danger the king just slapped the G7 and
white king is the one that is going to
be hunted
yeah no that's absolutely correct the
bishop on F7 such a nice multi-purpose
piece serving both a defensive role
blocking the seventh Rank and an
attacking role as it aims at the C4 Pawn
just a couple more decisions that Jana
has to make accurately but he is
knocking on the door of an incredible
comeback Victory which will enable him
to tie the match at one apiece
I mean look at Magnus he's so upset with
himself yeah how could I just blunder
Bishop takes E5 a one move tactic and
that's what Magnus needs to clean up and
it's weird to say that about the
strongest player of the last decade plus
often considered the greatest of all
time but he's just been so sloppy and
just giving away pawns giving away a
rook for free against Hikaru he's
getting good positions he's putting up
resilience and if the fights are there
but just something's off some things off
I mean the stalemate allowing stalemate
against fedes in a position where he had
forced made the reason we're putting an
accent on this Robert is because of how
rare it is right we wouldn't be making
such a big deal out of these blunders if
it was common but Magnus he never does
this he never allows this kind of
sloppiness to creep into his play but
the big question will it pay a price or
will his incredible class supersede this
uncharacteristic sloppiness let's find
out Bishop B6 by Yan upanishi
essentially forcing a rook trade I would
imagine
yep
so takes takes and well Magnus grabbed
the pawn on A7 in the resulting position
I mean D6 at the end as well just keep
all of Black's pieces threatened like H6
is not participating in a great way so I
it just feels like black doesn't quite
have the coordination needed to end this
game uh but of course still better for
young so it takes it just takes and
where is it in the way Magnus is moving
you can see the the consternation the
frustration and now a big decision as
you said Queen D6 or does he get greedy
and take on A7 I guess Queen A7 there's
some sort of Queen F4 move that could be
very very nasty
uh because you can't protect C4 and your
Bishop one F2 needs the Queen's defense
over there on A7 that's a good point and
after Queen D6
Queen F4 could lead to one of those
Queen trades where A7 drops and there
are definitely chances for white to
salvage that one so
yeah I'm just gonna meet Queen D6 with
Bishop C7
most probably and then the queen
actually I don't know where the White
Queen goes from there
sorry to interrupt you you were gonna
make a point no I was just um thinking
about the position about what he might
do and I mean he looks like
he's ready to put up that fight like he
looked just like he was gonna resign now
he's calculating he's really back at the
board trying to come up with something
because he has passed pawns so let's say
you go Queen D2 and the Queens get
traded here
and that's what he plays those past
pawns are running B5 B6 the A7 Pawn is
hanging uh the knight ever moves his
rookie seven so Jan says Queens on the
board my king assistant he says the end
game is out of the question I love the
move Queen H3 and he's ready to start
pushing his pawns he he's ready to
rumble them forward
the side of the safer King is usually
the side that's happier to keep Queens
on and the King on G8 is tucked away
from all of the opponent's pieces
whereas the King on C2 and that's not
where you want your king in this
position you want your king actually I
don't really know where there's nowhere
safe for it
yeah I mean V1 A1 whichever kit
whichever diagonal you put the King on
there is a bishop that can access that
diagonal whether it's E5 or the other
Bishop could land on G6 when the pawns
clear the path with F4 and G5 Magnus
continuing to try to insist on the queen
trade and the elephant in the room
Robert is that he's got Now 49 seconds
or so for the rest of the game see
John's eight and a half minutes
and John's playing really well right now
Queen G2 another nice move and uh I'm
just worried for Jan his position is
great he probably should and will win
this game but there are these moments
where I just feel like he plays a little
bit too quickly impulsively not that
this is one of those moments it just has
happened in his history
it most certainly has and I think he's
apportioning his time well thus far he's
leaving himself with enough time to
convert this Advantage but the game will
not win itself he will have to set his
Pawns in motion at some point and the
question is is now the time to start
currently A7 is hanging and I don't know
if that's upon Jan will want to easily
give up
no he certainly will not want to give
that one out without getting something
in return and I I just want to say he is
doing the right thing he is spending
time now so it's not the yawn that was
heavily criticized uh before the world
championship match against Magnus Theon
who just uh in moments where he could
spend a little time and make a better
decision he blitzes a move out no it's
clear he knows he has a great position
he knows his winning chances are high he
does not want to let this slip away
because he can even up this match
against Magnus
now if he if he lets this one slip I
don't think that that is going to be a
blow that Jan will be able to come back
from whether this game ends in a shock
win for Magnus but even if it ends in a
draw that would be an absolutely
miraculous result
and you can see Jan taking his time for
the first time in the last couple of
moves trying to make that decision where
does he want his Queen where does he
want his Pawns
and queen G4 is his choice hitting that
pawn on C4
creating another threat
E2 isn't there Knight D4 now
they're for sure is Knight D4 you have
to take it the queen takes back and C4
is loose uh both light and dark squares
are going to be a problem so Magnus he's
making moves quickly and it looks like
Jan once again taking his time Knight D4
check is excellent but he has not rushed
decision and there it is this is the
growth of Jana palmushi phenomenal time
management good technique and just a
couple of moves away from claiming the
victory in the second game he now has
the ideal two minor pieces is he finally
ready Robert to start pushing his pawns
or do you think he should launch some
sort of frontal assault against the king
with a move like A5
I kind of like the move King G7 because
I actually keep saying my love no Queen
B2 C4 hangs but I was gonna say Rook D1
is a move that I want to play as white
and it is available with the King on G8
or the King on G7 there are tactics in
Black's favorite but he plays your move
A5 so you're calling it and rookie
You'll Play Bishop takes C4 let me just
show that that would be wrong because if
Queen takes E4 with a check on the black
king can't take the Rook
and Jan doesn't blunder that he moves
back to B6
a trade on before and what is the final
blow here Bishop D6 there is still Queen
D2 so the white king is somehow still
breathing still kicking
it ain't over just Bishop f8 but look at
those Bishops C4 and B4 and now the G
and F pawns can start rolling so what
Magnus needs to do now is somehow just
create counter play it's a queen T3
shirt most Magnus will be more or less
the same but what he needs to be able to
do is like Stop Those Pawns in their
tracks but he's got too many tasks and
not enough pieces to accomplish them
with I guess he can play Rook F1 and try
to stop the pawn like this but then the
other Pawn comes to its rescue and just
these combined threats against White's
King coupled with the prospect of
promotion I think is too much to bear
Rook D7 desperation by Magnus I think
that book can play F3
but look how carefully he's converting
this queen E6 so patient
he's playing this extremely well and
white has no ideas all of black pieces
are defended uh the pawn F4 is loose for
the moment but of course he's not going
to drop that one so just great play from
Jan and Rook too don't play Bishop G7
because d8 check that's his idea just
trying to create create a little trick
okay Queen up to F5
between up to F5 by
nepo Queen D3 Magnus still trying to get
those Queens off the board and even
though the queen trade Robert at this
point probably was winning
I don't think that was even thinking
about it he wants to go for checkmate
it's good to avoid it just because the
bee Pawn running quite quickly I could
give white some chances and there's no
chance with magnus's clock under now 10
seconds that he is going to survive this
one the finishing touches being put Rook
Dade Magnus still trying to muddy the
waters I think it's time to push that F
Pawn and it's basically resign time for
the world champion
four three okay last move Queen D4 still
trying
yeah just trade and play G5 I think now
the pawns are just too quick for
Magnus to stop you can play Queen E7
just Retreat your queen that's also very
strong but and attack me before at the
same time
is there
oh
okay
oh wait a minute
okay and what about you if one the king
runs away somehow to A4
what did he just do
that was definitely a big mistake the
evil bar still says completely winning
for black but I don't hold up Janet
evaluated before playing he blundered
Queen D6 and guess what Robert I think
the only correct move is actually to
still play Bishop E6 that is not an easy
move to make it is not easy to evaluate
that there is no Perpetual in that
resulting position this is insane and
God has to keep his composure take a
minute and decide that the queen ending
is winning which it is I don't think
there's an alternative
I don't think there's another winning
move
he went Bishop V6 this all happening did
it okay the five second increment can he
navigate his way out of the checks here
that's the big question
I think actually quite easily it was
Queen CHF King G7 no more checks
so Magnus has to drop back to E1 and
block the pawn from behind but with the
queen as passive as it is it's over
yeah wow
so I guess the ultimate question even
though the result doesn't seem to be in
doubt now was that an oversight that
just so happened to still work in his
favor or did he sort of have the
calculation there but either way
janapamshi he is taking home a very very
important game if he doesn't throw it
away in F3 check and of course you want
to try to get the queen that you won but
the white gang is gonna have something
to say about that
how about G5 G4 G3 G2
not a bad idea what can I say and not
argue with that King A4
and at this point oh Queen E3 he wants
queen G2 he's still trying
I think G5 is is the most clinical
approach
yeah yeah because white is Frozen 2
oh
my gosh if still need to be accurate
here
King G7
I mean B7 check Maybe
yeah
so there's B5 instead pushes
this is how does Magnus like how is he
still alive we have a Queenie one Queen
B7 check King H6 there are no more
checks oh that's goodbye that's curtains
great call
we need one as curtains
yeah that's a two move line napo's gonna
see that
but Magnus somehow you know almost made
us believe that he was going to survive
this game and that's that janapan she
takes game two evens up the score it is
one to one the world champion loses to
his 2021 Challenger and he looks
disgusted he blundered upon the sound
the board.net and he can never quite
bounce back
to be honest when he initiated that a
trial attack when he had the pawn on H5
I was I was sure that that would be a
vintage Magnus Victory you just feel
he's up a point he's attacking nepo's
King but all credit to Yonder pondichi
he was resilient he was gritty and he
pounced on his opportunity when he got
it didn't shy away from that exchange
sacrifice on C6 and that Exquisite
filigree Precision to drive the point
home and tie the match what a game
what a game indeed and well we have our
scoreboard as such with Hikaru Nakamura
he is leading two games to nil Magnus
Carlson janapamshi they're all knotted
up at one game a piece so Hikaru he
looks almost guaranteed to make it to
tomorrow's final and all Magus Carlson
was in the driver's seat and all of a
sudden the momentum is swinging yeah
it most certainly is he wins a game with
the black pieces Magnus he's been
frustrated all tournament long you can
tell that the sloppiness is getting to
him Robert he's so annoyed he tells
himself this is the last time I
blundered and then there's another
blunder so Magnus he's got his
psychological work cut out for him
obviously the good news for the world
champion the match is still tied he
hasn't done all that much damage but the
next game is going to be absolutely
crucial
it will and yonda palmchi will get the
white pieces but they will have a new
position entirely so uh whatever just
happened happened it's not like you're
playing an eight-game match of Chess
where you just start over with a normal
setup and work on your opening
variations no you don't even know what
the pieces configuration will look like
uh speaking of eight games and regular
chess I'm pretty sure there's a
tournament coming up that is in Toronto
with eight what there is oh and eight
players and I believe that's eight
commentators as well it is the chess.com
Global Championship coming to a head in
Toronto the live finals begin Wednesday
November 2nd with 500 000 on the line
who will come out on top after the
upsets we have seen throughout this
tournament it is truly anyone's game do
not miss a single minute of the cgc live
finals including a special guest
appearance from the one the only the US
champion Fabiano caruana streaming right
here on chess.com type cgc finals in the
chat for details and Donya well
ran to a break after the break new
position will be revealed the players
will get set for game three for more
from the Fisher random World
Championship our coverage brought to you
by Brave
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck
quack quack
how to play duck chess the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
score to play as the dog
foreign
moves of opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the points King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still mated player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast
fast oh no no no no no no slip no no no
no no no
duck chess champion give me those points
baby
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the tens of thousands of
you watching this Fisher random World
Championship coverage brought to you by
Brave Grand Master Robert Hess alongside
me today is Grandmaster Daniel nerdinsky
and Donya the matchups have been
exciting thus far and we wanted to
highlight one of the best moves really
not just of the day but one of the best
moves I think I've seen in recent memory
this was exciting this was amazing and
this happened in the nepo Carlson game
one the world champion has the black
pieces he has just sacrificed a bishop
on B3 now that is not the brave move the
day that's a pretty reasonable sacrifice
most people would recapture
automatically with a queen but Robert
Magnus is not most people and he doesn't
recapture on B3 what does he do instead
what an amazing sequence is what he he
first throws in Rook takes F4 and you're
like wait what there's a knight on D3
that can capture the more valuable piece
but he has wanted to rook in this
tournament but not this right you don't
always believe him in this one but this
whole combination works because that
Knight is needed to defend the C1 Square
so after Knight takes F4 which is not
what Jana Palm she played there was
Queen takes B3 check and the King has to
scoot over to E1 and after Knight C2
check no longer can white capture that
Knight on C2 because his Queen not
captures Rook but Queen B1 check follow
followed by Checkmate of Queen takes
Rook on C1 the Knight on D3 would have
been essential protecting that square so
the Knight is needed on D3 it was a
distraction tactic and just to finish
off the beautiful sequence if the king
slides the D1 Dania you take it away
from here
well smothered mate is one of the
prettiest mates of all time I can see it
a million times it never gets old and
what a particularly beautiful
instantiation of the smothered made this
is a double check to start things off
King has to move back and queen D1
forcing The Rook onto D1 this is the the
Zen of the smothered mate and the Knight
travels back to C2 with a lovely
gorgeous Checkmate and because of this
line and because of these variations Jan
was forced to decline the poisonous Rook
on F4 that gave Magnus the pawn that he
needed and the open f file that he
needed then he takes on B3 and he went
on to smoothly well maybe not quite so
smoothly but in typical world champion
fashion convert the advantage and win
the first game when all was said and
done he still took that game home he won
that game and that was your Brave move
of the day it's time to make your move
from chrome to Brave try it now at
brave.com and we mentioned that Magnus
won that game one in wonderful fashion
we just showed you that crazy tactical
sequence and he won game one but Janda
Palm she was able to strike back in game
two so it's one to one between these two
Juggernauts and in the other matchup
well unfortunately for notibeca
busatarov his magical run in the group
stage it seems like it's fizzling out
here in the semis
yeah that was a really disappointing
game too for Notre back and I I really
think that he wasn't quite able to push
the memory of the first game out of his
mind had notabeck just made that one
move had he evacuated his Queen we might
be talking about a completely different
narrative we might be talking about
Hikaru Nakamura having to make a
comeback instead he is sitting pretty up
two games to nil and all he needs is a
draw to clinch the match and a ticket to
the final yes and at first it looked
like it would be Hikaru versus Magnus
the matchup that you know most people
have seen and enjoy every single time it
happens but right now young department
is saying not so fast Magnus may have
won the 2021 world championship and is
not fighting me once more in traditional
classic chess but we are gonna duke it
out here and Fisher random it is one to
one it is not enough and it remains to
be seen who is going to make it to
Championship Sunday
and we cannot emphasize enough how
shocking it is to see Magnus making
these one move blunders once per
tournament understandable but it has
become a regular occurrence in these
Fisher random World Championship uh in
this Fisher random world championship
for the world champion that was quite
the tongue twister a lot of tongue
twisters on this show talking about the
queen side of the king side and the
world championship but Magnus he's gonna
have to step it up in these next two
games because I don't think he can
afford another one of these blunders
Robert no he cannot and well it's tricky
because in Fisher random you see the
position revealed in front of your eyes
and then you have to scramble just to
come up with any semblance and of an
idea and let's be honest the players
they spend about 10 15 minutes analyzing
maybe with a second Maybe by themselves
but either way you're not going to get
to the heart of the position in that
little period of time so it means that
these players who is in best shape on
this day will move on into the next
round because it's not relying on
opening Theory nope preparation no
computer evaluations none of that it is
just who is going to sit at their chair
and play the better moves
and the other complicating factor is
that they have already played out one
particular position now the position
changes for the next two games and that
reminds me of those famous you know
psychology experiments uh visual
experiments where you stare at a
particular caller for a long time and
then you know you see the world tinged
in that color you have to avoid that in
the context of Fisher random you have to
put that previous position out of your
mind completely because one tiny
difference the night sitting on B1
instead of A1 the King sitting on H1
instead of E1 can entirely change the
tenor of the position and the last thing
you want to do is borrow ideas from the
previous position which will often lead
you down the very wrong path
yes and that's you know when you play a
game of chess like oh I remember this
position I had it doesn't work the same
way you're like oh I remember this
Fisher random game where actually the
Knight and Bishop were you know where it
flip-flops and you're like oh I think
it's the same might as well try no you
can't get away with that but uh the
players they know what's on the line
here they're not trying to uh be the
most creative they're not trying to come
up with a Brilliance prize they're
trying to win the big prize that first
place 150
000 prize and there are four players who
still have a chance but for abusitar if
it looks like his chances are about to
uh run out so ikaru Nakamura he looks
like he is more or less guaranteed
unless abdusitarov can come up with a
win in game three Hikaru Nakamura is
going to guarantee himself minimum 85
Grand
and then he's going to hop on the
Iceland Air flight to Toronto and
compete for a 200 000 first prize at the
chess.com Global Championship you
mentioned Robert that he could be 350k
richer okay minus taxes we won't talk
about that uh in only a couple of weeks
but the prizes for this tournament are
incredible everybody has earned
themselves at least something incredibly
generous and I guess for Notre back you
know
in a way he kind of doesn't have
anything to lose anymore I'm sure he's
already come to terms with the fact that
he's probably going to lose this match
and there's something to be said for
being in his position just having a good
time right hey he wins the next game
he's competing for one of the greatest
match comebacks of all time so from a
psychological perspective I think he car
was the one uh who really has to calm
his nerves and obviously he is
very very experienced at that and has an
incredible track record so let me get
this straight you're saying you know you
can be relaxed as an 18 year old winning
minimum 40 Grand after already winning
the world rapid winning the Olympiad
having all these kind of successes
doesn't sound like such a bad life fail
2022 for Notre bag what a terrible year
I mean you keep talking about him some
sort of major Prodigy as we see him
chilling there on camera with I think
Peter Heinen Nielsen across from him but
would have been nice if notterback
actually won some tournaments or
achieved something maybe like a team
tournament but sadly he hasn't yeah I
really know what the fuss is all about
do Olympia gold he is in absolute force
and you see everybody there waiting
strolling pacing not even knowing what
to do with themselves because as chess
players they just want to get that next
position and immediately study and then
get to the games but they're waiting for
the position to be revealed we see Peter
honey Nielsen Magnus Carlson's trainer
we see Jana palmchi getting a bit of
nourishment there we see nordebec off to
the left
that's right sorry let's let's float to
the chatter question can you guys
identify who is there behind Yan who is
currently next to Hikaru let's see how
many of you just from that shadow can
identify this very strong Grandmaster
sorry for interrupting Robert please
continue but now the camera has taken us
completely away this is not under in our
control
we see young fans it looks like oh
Magnus being wanted
and tactics and swindles got it that is
indeed a Nikki very nice guys that is
Nikita vitugab one of yon seconds super
Grand Master
good stuff good stuff
yeah the Iceman the legendary Russian
player who won the Russian Championship
I believe uh recently so a very talented
and a trusty second and we see the
position about to be revealed all eyes
on the TV screen it's like a Netflix
special yeah at least
and I'm curious what do you think Donna
what's going on A1
what's going on A1 I'm gonna predict uh
Bishop
okay so a bishop oh pawns just got
thrown there maybe well the pawns are in
the second rank incredible oh and
knights on A1 I think if I'm seeing
correctly it is very difficult to seek
and I wish we had
um access to the people taking this
footage because it would be really nice
to have a close-up I
don't even
is that a rook on C1
oh yeah I can't really see oh thanks
there beautiful look at that camera work
I jinxed it now and you guys aren't
seeing what we were seeing we were
seeing a close-up of the board and there
we go
wow Knights on A1 and H1
B1 yeah Knights on the rim they say are
dim but here there are two of them I
don't know what to make of that
whoa
I'm kind of wrapping my head around this
so I'm just gonna be silent for a couple
of seconds there was a night and they
want a queen I'd be one
and then a bishop on G1 a very
asymmetrical weird position I like it
yeah I think you know we're gonna take a
few minutes just like the players
because they're darting to a spare board
just to make some moves and see how it
feels I think we should do the same
because when we get back we will talk
about the starting position analyze a
bit for you all and then round three
will be underway so stay tuned we'll be
right back for more from the Fisher
random world championship this coverage
by chess.com brought to you by Brave
run for my life
okay
what's up man hey just solving some
puzzles
for coffee
oh
which one is that is that our new one
yeah
I can't get this one man
what's wrong with you man
and run oh this is hard
[Music]
you sure you're feeling okay
uh one got it oh shoot
Bishop ac1
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
the Fisher random world championship
this coverage brought to you by Brave we
do have the positions for game three and
four Dania King in the center that much
is normal everything else all over the
place
yeah I mean I'm still I'm still
adjusting my eyes it's been what four or
five minutes I've guzzled down some
coffee I still can't quite get the hang
of this position and I can't even
imagine what the players are going
through right now as you said the king
is anyone but that's about where the
similarities and as always when I look
at this position
I have no idea what the priorities
should be do you get the night outs
first do you play C4 and try to activate
the queen that Bishop on G8 is actually
a really nice defensive piece guarding
H7
Robert I am completely at a loss here
and I'm not even ashamed to admit it no
I don't think I would just flub this
terribly if I were playing it I think I
just try to help myself by talking about
a few individual elements for example
you can Castle in three turns you move
either your C you know your E Pawn as
well but like let's say you move your F
pawn move your bishop and then you can
just Castle you can do the same on the
other side of the board by moving your
light Square bishop and then castling
Queen side so castling is not very far
away that's something to immediately
note which side you want to Castle on is
an interesting question Donya and no
pawns are initially hanging right every
single Pawn is defended by a piece
yeah so you're nope g-pawn I forgot
about that ah but it's not easy to
attack I guess you could film Kettle the
queen but that doesn't seem like a very
effective measure wait Dunn you want to
see an immediate loss Knight G3 okay
Knight G6 Knight H5 oh my God hilarious
that's so funny you can't defend the
pawn and you can't Castle because The
Bishop's in the
way oh I positive somebody's got to be
playing Knight G3 this is too good of an
opportunity to press up I can guarantee
you we're gonna see at least one Knight
two three it's just so funny I guess
Knight G3 now that we're talking
specific moves I can see F5 not a
reasonable response because Knight H5 no
longer is you know so threatening you
can even just push your Pawn to G6 and
the Knights
check I win the night is not long for
this board as the one in the wise words
of one particular commentator the funny
thing is you can try out for look at
this light oh I won the knife back but
you don't because black has E5 this is
like classic Fisher random you just look
at these moves and black is up a piece
anyways I've gone officially down the
rabbit hole
please save me no no we're talking about
opening Theory we are actually helping
Everybody by talking these things so
Knight G3 move one seems reasonable
um
yeah I don't I really I think we're
gonna get this
you think so I think we're gonna get an
F4 F5 because if white plays E4 move one
which is also plausible to be black
could actually take a page out of
hikaru's book this strategy didn't work
well for him in game one Robert but
maybe here with the King on E1 this is
more enticing because the Rook could
actually swing to E5 kind of playing
like a beginner you know A5 Rook A6
rookie six it's almost Checkmate right
rookie five the only movie Bishop E2 to
block it so oh my God what an odd
starting position we have and what about
to this what about this traffic between
on B1 I feel like I've learned so many
times like that in NFR oh yeah it's
really difficult to like see where all
the pieces are aiming because it's you
look at the you know Knight on h8 oh
it's a rook that's not doing anything oh
wait that Knight can just hop out from
the corner right away so
um yeah as we go back to the starting
position Knight G3 definitely comes to
mind any sort of Central Pawn push is
for the top of our brain yeah F4 for
certain
um see three maybe to open up the bishop
like I've also seen players try this
kind of modest approach but this seems
like it lacks Pizzazz yeah
I'm with you I think see there's a
little I think why not play C4 if you're
gonna push the C Pawn
why push the two squares and I can push
a one square but here yeah here I guess
black plays the Dutch
and this idea of pushing the pawn to F4
to restrict the Knight on H1 actually
comes into play here so my guess is that
the players are going to prioritize the
development of the Knight first and
foremost which is why I think Knight G3
is a likely first move
and I love that feature chat we just had
said this is how regular uh people see
normal chess trying to figure out
opening Theory from move one
you know what this reminds me of is
those experiments in the 60s uh by Dutch
psychologists and master named Adrian
Degroot uh where I think he tested the
ability of Masters to remember certain
types of positions and he found that the
stronger you are the better you are at
remembering and reconstructing a normal
chess position but when he jumbled up
the pieces and he put eight Queens on
the board and the kings were touching
each other he found that there was no
significant difference in the recall
ability between Masters and beginners so
this is kind of similar everybody's on
the same page we're all incredibly
confused and none of us have any idea
what's going on that's the way I like it
I'm with you there and I'm still trying
to figure out what first move is good no
clue the player is doing their best to
gain any insights from uh their second
we were mentioning Nikita vitsuga Peter
honey Nielsen
um but they're all just working on the
Fly and if you're Abdul sitarov you lost
game one from a good position with black
you made a bad decision to take two
Rooks for a queen and
obviously a nice little message here
featured chat
I wasted all their time memorizing open
moves in this version is 10 times better
ah there's Beauty in standard chess as
well
not really I mean come on yeah who plays
that game I know the cool kids the cool
kids have switched long ago
to 960. yeah Notre Beck has his work cut
out for him absolutely you know what I
think he has to avoid what he tried to
do in the second game he tried to force
it right he tried to force that b-pawn
up the board he has to play the position
he has to play objectively and he has to
do what brought him success in the
preliminary portion just playing his
style of Chess without trying to force
anything and without playing for too
many tricks because you can't trick
Hikaru
nope you can't do that
um so
the players are about to enter the Hall
they're about to sit at their boards and
get game three underway now game three
might be the final game of Nakamura
abusotare if Hikaru draws unlike
standard chess it's very difficult to
force a draw with white in Fisher random
in a typical game you just play any
opening find a line that's maybe have a
four sequence and then if your opponent
evades it they'll just have a bad
position here you don't know what your
first move should be so how in the world
are you going to say oh yeah I know A
variation that leads to draw's
tendencies
yeah no it's it's impossible and that is
the reassuring thing for Notre back I
mean you can basically be guaranteed
uh that you will at least have some
chances if you play reasonably in the
opening as we see Magnus Carlson taking
his seat and sipping on some water he
seems like he's kind of calmed himself
down that break is really really
important for the player who has a
disappointing game too and he just seems
a little bit calm again I don't I'm
trying to make an effort not to overdo
it on the body language front but you
can just tell that he's relaxed he's
taken some deep breaths and perhaps a
conversation with a second was was
helpful to put things in perspective and
I realized I misspoke that the players
who had white in game two get white
again in game three and that's only fair
because when you're seeing a position
for the first time you know getting the
white pieces in a standard game of chess
that's an advantage when you get in
Fisher random you don't know what you're
supposed to do so actually you might
learn something playing with the black
pieces in game one and then use that to
your advantage in the second game so
it's only fair to switch off colors uh
the way they're doing it so Magnus had
white in um game two in black and game
one now against white in game three and
black in game four and
um Hikaru will have the black pieces
once again
yeah and Cara will have the black pieces
and players continue to take their seats
it's hot in the playing Hall the suit is
off for Jana pomdishi the gloves are off
and the piece is getting adjusted that's
a lot of waters on the desk it's
important to stay hydrated I guess
is that Dirk Johnson over there behind
him with the camera that definitely
catch Eagle Eye by you yeah
Derek young just hanging out there oh
and look at this we have a chess kid
representing first move in this game
always nice to see young players get a
chance to interact with players although
Dirk did change his last name he's now
Dirk John 9 van guzendam
I mean it was 11 A.M start time three
hours
I'm making progress hopefully the last
day and that was jenya surakina who was
uh you know a chess Kid star making that
first move
yep and guess what we do have a night on
G3
and in fact we have both nights on G3
neither side can resist the urge to set
that trap
[Music]
not falling for that I remember the
Knight H5 that we were showing yep I
remember when spaski was giving a
similar years ago uh rather than making
the same first move on all words he just
announced to the uh to all 20 boards
play E4 on all boards just dutifully
executed that move
also you're you're a young guy but
saying I remember a Simon makes
it sound like you're at least 30 years
old than you are
well I'm getting up there in age I'm 30
than I am to 20 I'm turning 27 so don't
remind me yeah but you know saying like
oh I remember a spaski symbol was just
something I think happened in 1970. it
was in uh saraiavo in uh zonal
tournament and Mario del Plata okay
anyways on we go to the games
we have nepo there on camera in front of
us
and who's the one taking their time
it looks like we have an English I know
we don't like using the names of real
regular openings and applying them to
fish and random but you see for white C4
and B4 you need a fiend keto Bishop on
the long diagonal and on the other side
of things for Jan napomishi uh he is at
pawns on G6 F5 and E5 and done it those
pawns look very imposing to my eyes they
look imposing but currently they're not
supported by any pieces so Yan will have
to
oh wait I'm I'm confused yeah John is
playing Black so Yan will have to bring
out at least some pieces to guard those
pawns but the Knight on G3 very nicely
restricted by the pawns on G6 and F5 so
it's up to Carlson to justify the
placement of that Knight
yes because a pawn three squares away
from a knight really restricts that
piece we love mentioning that that still
holds true even in Fisher random so
um look at the clock situation you see
that a lead for black in this game that
is very standard in fisherendum as the
players try to figure things out white
kind of has the onus of that first move
quote-unquote Advantage it often feels
like a disadvantage in fishing random
yeah this is actually already an
incredibly Rich position
and I guess the sort of fundamental
choice that Magnus has to make is
whether he will try to actively contest
Black's kingside control or will Magnus
continue sort of his Queen side campaign
with a move like C5 followed by Bishop
B3 that actually looks kind of kind of
neat as a way to try to impose some
pressure on Black's King in the early
going well you say Magnus I say Abdus
Atara you say Nakamura I say napomnishi
look at their positions Dania same
positions
you don't see that every day it's not
like these are that conventional of
moves
no this is a very odd looking positions
and before was played by that's Abdul
sitarov so I can see the board I can
also see
um we have off the side a view of the
cameras where I could see the black
sleeves so I know that's noribbeck uh
but E4 played challenging the pawn
structure in the center and Magnus has
not yet made his move from that
identical position I don't think
swagness is gonna play E4
I don't think we're gonna see four I
think I'm gonna predict C5 by Magnus I
don't know why I just get that feeling
you were talking about the move it looks
pretty good just trying to open up light
squares and go after uh the black king I
can buy that but Magnus has been down on
the clock in both games thus far against
Yan and Jan used that to his advantage
in game two remember uh the position at
some point looked very uh promising
Magnus but Bishop takes C6 which was a
wonderful tactical shot but Jan had like
a 10 minute lead and kept the pace up
and then Magnus made a big mistake so
Jan is using the clock as a weapon he is
and that's what makes him such a
terrifying opponent in a rapid and he
says hey if it ain't broke don't fix it
I'm adopting an identical strategy in
game two I'm gonna build up that 10
minute time Advantage even if it means a
dubious position from an objective
standpoint and Magnus man he is just
diving into that clock already down five
minutes and he hasn't even made move
four
right he's going in for a deep think and
he must like the Contours of the
position and he
F3 never play that move nope this is bad
and I'm not even looking at the board
I don't even care what the position it
is
and F3 he's probably gonna try to play
for D4 next and opening up quick Bishop
1g1 trying to control the center
um and very importantly is in the bottom
right if the black Bishop was all the
way out to H4 pinning the Knight white
does have the simple response oh my God
to block in the PIN that's a hilarious
sequence Bishop d8 to H4 Bishop G1 to F2
the first the first time that these two
moves have been uttered in uh in a row
yeah not something you see pretty much
ever and whoa looks like whoa whoa whoa
whoa
did you see what I saw
yeah what just happened we need to check
out what's going on there's a Pawn on F3
which black is just given up on that
square
imagine it's nice
it's gonna take back with his Rook on fa
but black has no development whatsoever
so he wow gives away the pawn and once
Bishop H3 whoa how do you defend against
that is there even a defense against
that
I don't think there is
um
also there's a bishop on G1 can we just
talk about that for a moment we can
like that it we're talking you know
those those famous games right where the
bishop goes on a roundabout and goes
like Bishop G5 H4 G3 and never gets back
in the game yeah here from the start
that Bishop is stuck which game am I
thinking about what's the classic one uh
let me guess is it um a season of the
year yeah yep it's not summer it's not
spring it is William winner against
Kappa Blanca man do I love someone who
knows their classics
uh well even if I didn't know my
Classics you make such references and
we've commentated so many times together
that I learned from you so I've shown
that game so when I'm flattered I've
shown that game so many times
but anyways but so but yeah I think that
you know those players will be rolling
in their graves looking at Bishop on G1
because it's buried and you are not
going to be able to get out of there
right you have to push F4 which and he
does as soon as I said it and then play
F3 next just to save the bishop but
you're also saving your Rook so it's
like awkward pieces left and right
yeah so now the big question for
Nakamura and I think I know how he's
going to answer that question you can
play Bishop H3 but that would be
somewhat myopic of an approach because
you can't miss the forest for the trees
after F take C5 congratulations let me
give you a medal you've won the exchange
guess what you've also allowed the most
monsters on failings of all time so
something tells Mr Nakamura is going to
take on a four what no he went Bishop H3
oh he did
whoa are you as surprised as I am yes no
that is shocking to me because at the
very least you hand nordebec optimism
it's like wait I have two pawns and a
bishop for a rook and I have this
Phalanx in the center it's gonna be a B4
to E4 with an extra Pawn on E5 as well
so oh my goodness F takes E5 here seems
automatic for abusotarev and I like it
just if he doesn't play F6 C5 I'm
quitting I'm done for the day then I
haven't earned the right to commenting I
think
I'm gonna Hazard a guess at what Hikaru
has in mind Robert wait but that doesn't
work either I thought that it might be
Bishop takes F1 King takes F1 and then
maybe he wants C5 to sort of drive a
stake through the middle of White's Pawn
Center but after bc5 you can't stop the
pawn from getting to D4 and it's
simultaneously defends C5 let alone the
fact that p7 also hangs
I think the onus is squarely on hikara's
shoulders to demonstrate the rectitude
of this idea and you know because this
is very important in that sequence
you're showing the bishop on G1 because
H2 is defended
you'll love that Bishop oh my gosh what
this is very surprising done in the line
You're just showing with bc5 it's very
simple you can play bc5 play D4 and
you're happy
um
I really think that nobody back should
be ecstatic right now like
she absolutely should what is the car
looking for
uh and Hikaru has started to think after
F6 E5 don't tell me that he forgot I
mean Dwight had no choice it's not like
white can move the rook and oh I forgot
the my opponent can sack The Exchange no
this is virtually forced and before I
let you continue Robert I have another
reference to flex on you okay are you
familiar with the bronstein game with
the bishop that sat on G8 in the Karo
Khan with black
no
there's a there's a series of David
bronstein games where he put his Bishop
on sheet voluntarily with a Pawn on F7
and upon on H7 and like 20 it was one of
those games where 20 moves later the
bishop opened up perfectly wait so how
could you upon F7 and H7 or no no it was
a bishop on
there was a
where were Black's pawns yeah that's not
possible for them to be a pot on F7
I know exactly what you're talking about
in a line where you play caracon Bishop
F5 Bishop H7 and that's some point
Bishop G8 okay I I got you
so I guess there was a Pawn on H6 to
open up the pathway but anyways the bad
Bishop bungee one defends the very
important Pawns
what is going on here and what did they
make of this no need to capture an F1
right away because the Rook can't go
anywhere so you kind of want to keep the
tension not that there's much tension
there but the issue is you're not going
to get to the E5 Pawn Knight F7 is met
by D4 just defending that pawn and oh my
gosh this has gone wrong
this definitely has this is the dream
scenario for Notre back eight moves in
and he's got exactly the kind of
position that's up his alley
stylistically I mean whose alley is it
not up you have a massive font Center
and Hikaru is thinking here Robert do
you think it's more of a what did I just
do I'm going to recover mentally think
or is he actually deciding between
candidate moves
I think he is more upset than
calculating if I'm being honest because
you don't give up this F3 pawn and then
E5 pawn and then start thinking
um you know you would have had that
prepared so I feel like he is just
upset with what's going on he played the
move C5 so he's going for the variation
you were showing but white is in the
driver's seat and very happy and I think
we should take this moment while
nuribeck will you know calculate whether
or not to take on C5 to look at the game
between Magnus and yawn because that
well first of all Magnus looks like he's
about to fall asleep but yep more
important or more relevant is it kind of
looks like a sort of King's Indian in a
way where you know white expanded on the
queen side well I'm not trying to call
out your opening but it feels almost
like a bayonet attack but the best thing
for white is that there's tension in the
center because Lex King is still there
and yes black can Castle in either
direction uh but the kings in the center
so opening up the center should be
beneficial for white yeah I mean Black's
position is incredibly precarious and
the first thing I don't understand is
what Jan has in store against e takes F5
is that Bishop takes G3
what is because GF just Knight takes up
five and this is
I thought out of the question maybe he
wants to go for this and
produce compensation but how
yeah I'm just giving away a pawn what
what do we missed what's happening C6
takes takes takes logical
I guess I guess black can just trade
everything take on F5 and like castle
and claim that white is a bad Bishop but
why doesn't have a bad Bishop he can
swing to C2 and threaten checkmate
and it's on the board it's wrong
I think he might be going out for Bishop
takes G3
but simple Bishop takes G3 Bishop takes
F5 and
Queen A1 even or Bishop C no not Bishop
C2 with Queen A1 I think that's the key
move in the sequence because uh should I
show that yeah yeah just Bishop Bishop
G3 Bishop F5
you don't want to play Queen B2 because
Knight D3 is a fork
you don't want to play Bishop C2 because
my E2 check is a fork and so let me
interrupt you for a second it's a
testament to how good White's position
is that even here white is not that much
worse maybe you were thinking the same
thing no it says White's better I'm
looking the eval bar off the side
okay cool yeah you win my Rook good for
you now Black's kings in the center so I
mean I guess Queen A1 just solves all
your problems because the king's still
in the center you're not giving material
Bishop G3 pins the Knight on F4 Pawn E5
Dynamic we're coming to E1 oh
this is nasty ugly name the adjective
this is borderline lost so I actually
think that nepo
he clearly overlooked something
underestimated something he's still up
on time he might have to fight the
bullet and take on F5 and give up that
pawn
but that looks just as nasty he's not in
his chair so now he's back he just sat
back down uh as I said anything yeah
goes gf5
nerves of Steel here
also just he is determined he is has
made a plan maybe with vitigov agreeing
on it is I am going to play as quickly
as I can and I'm going to make good
moves and not necessarily perfect moves
because he is just blitzing out almost
every decision
and now so as Magnus as we go down that
exact line and this is the big moment
what does nepo have in his pocket my
guess is that he has to eliminate that
night enough of I don't know how you
survive with that night sitting pretty a
bone in Black's throat and if you Castle
immediately Robert you run into the fork
on E7 that's totally out of the question
yeah and then you're gonna Castle the
other way of your Castle oh yeah
Direction
how do you do that I keep forgetting wow
even even that decision is very awkward
to Castle Queen side here so I just feel
like
correct me if I'm wrong Dania I just
feel like white is up a pot
you know
I spent a long time debating I was going
back and forth swinging and this way hit
there and then there but I am inclined
to agree in the end of the day okay
so you're saying I'm correct that's the
most important thing and you're also
success is right yes I am saying that
Magnus is up a pawn so if we count seven
is greater than six
yeah I mean I also think that Magnus has
three Pawns in the king side and black
only has two
and on the queen side there's a four on
four so if we do the math and carry over
the two multiply the five you know at
the end of the day white is indeed up a
pawn so while you're doing those
calculations
nepo takes on F5 but what has he
calculated he's gonna Castle Queen side
goes he probably just came to see it and
just scoots The Rook over that was uh
pretty sweet so he's claiming that he is
going to have an open G line to attack
the white king that Black's King is
safer on C8 the queen on B8 actually
plays a part in this game because it
stares on the diagonal all the way
towards E5 and F4 so I know I was harsh
I know I was like what is Yan doing
maybe there's just Merit to this or
maybe he's down a pawn and he'll remain
down upon I don't know but tell me he's
also steering the game into a kind of
position where Magnus might feel
uncomfortable because of how much he's
blundered it's very double-edged I can
assure you Magnus knows he is better I
don't think the evaluation here
objectively is in question but it's one
of those positions where you make one
little misstep you allow one Little Fork
and the entire landscape of the position
changes so with the time situation what
it is with magnus's form what it is I
think this is actually a very astute
decision by yawn it's a risky decision
but it's one that might pay off and he
wants to win this game with black and
put Magnus against the wall
so that would be incredible I'm
ambivalent on whether I like this from
yon but it will definitely give us a lot
of entertainment value as this game
heads into the middle game yeah I'm glad
you're ambivalent and not indifferent
it's important to me that you care but
you just see the pros and cons of the
situation but I'm I'm kind of starting
to think that Black's position has a ton
of life to it and yeah I mean this Rook
on f8 putting some pressure down the F5
rook's coming to G file at some point
these Knights can hop around and maybe
infiltrate on some of the dark squares
so yeah there is definitely huge life in
this position and Jana had in the clock
but why don't we hop on over to the
other game since we've been here for a
little while now we can look at the game
between Hikaru and noribbeck because I
feel like hikaru's sort of just giving
up all of his pawns and then trying to
say I'm going to
attack your extra three pawns that White
currently has ooh and I think Hikaru has
posed a a vicious trap oh pad oh okay
scratch all of that I think we need to
look at the move that's just been played
E5 E6 giving away one of the main parts
of White Center For What in order to
open up the black king what is his
follow-up after de
maybe C5 and just try to use the light
squares to his Advantage okay let's say
I dropped the Knight back
and are you going to push that pawn up
to C6
I was thinking about it
if Queen takes B1 then of course this is
shakaruski and then you take the queen
up you won if 95 all of a sudden
and
this is just oh and there's no Rook B1
at the end I was going down exactly the
same rabbit hole because the Rook can
drop back to C1 at 992 guards it
Wow That's essential actually
so is this what Notre back has whipped
up now obviously black is not forced to
go to D7 you were going to make a point
here
um no I was actually just looking at the
position calculating
um some of the lines counting the pawns
but
your car's hovering over the E6 Pawn so
white currently if you go to the live
position for a quick second yep what
white has seven pawns to four so three
pawns for the exchange that was lost in
F1 black has two Rooks white is one
black white is actually minor piece he
goes Queen whoa whoa
whoa Super quickly
why did he Rush that move now I think
after Knight D7
you forfeited the opportunity to push
this Pawn to C5 while you had a chance I
would have at least spent some time
considering that move
why did he move so fast
I think Wayne B5 is at least my
instinctual reaction is that it's
inaccurate due to Knight D7 and I think
the email bar agrees
yeah maybe he has some follow-up just to
like I I don't think he wants to trade
Queens he wants to keep the Queens on
the board but where would the queen go
to
I mean I wouldn't I'm not sure he
doesn't I mean he wants to trade Queens
if the circumstances are right if he
could push response to D5 and C5 it
would be different but that's precisely
why Queen B5 isn't accurate because it
makes it harder and more cumbersome of a
process to push your Ponzi Karo don't
have to ask him twice he says thank you
for the possibility of trading queens
and I t7 on the board but if he had won
a trade Queens he could have played C5
to do so right like we were just talking
about exactly is C5 somehow not a move
you want to include I feel like it must
be a
good position for that pawn like why not
to pass Pawn so that's why I'm was
thinking he doesn't want trade Queens
but I don't like Queen A4 that looks
weird your Bishop wants to know so no
you have it
and he does so maybe he's just you know
seeing much deeper than we are that's
would not be so surprising he is nerdy
back Abdus atarov after all but he did
not want to push his Pawn to C5 that
early there must have been some
oh I see what it is okay check this out
if C5 was their Knight C4 somehow I was
thinking about that and then Knight
takes D2 Intermezzo but here
there is oh oh my God let me just show
this is great tactical awareness but
you'd say oh King you want to attack the
Knight no I'd have three he drops back
to F3 and if you go to G2 then I take
the queen and White's on Center is in
shambles
oh my gosh a great call
well I mean I only made the call because
it just doesn't make logical sense that
you would trade Queens but in this way
if you could play C5 first so I figured
there was something that he was not
overlooking that I was it's not the end
of the story though maybe a move like
Queen C2 to keep the Queens on the board
still maintain a big Advantage but okay
that actually explains a lot of it and I
can totally see why Notre back wouldn't
want to go for this position and let's
be real he is still much better he still
has a massive Fun Center he has
basically kept all of the advantages of
his position and he should still win
with accurate technique
yeah this is practically speaking
extremely difficult for a car to play
those three pawns C4 D4 E4 maybe later
an f-pawn will join the party but the
Knight comes out to B3 some of White's
moves are very obvious Bishop A4 check
Knight B3 Pawn C5 maybe Pawn D5 if you
allow it so I feel like the follow-up
here is a bunch of obvious choices for
white and for black not a single piece
has left the back rank some pawns have
Shore but all the other pieces on the
back rank you need to come up with a
plan and you need to do it right now
yeah you literally have no time to waste
these pawns are going forward the bishop
on G1 has always kind of lurked in the
shadows as the hidden engine of White's
position protecting F2 stopping any
Shenanigans down the f file this is the
best that Notre back has looked well I
was gonna say all match but in game one
he did have essentially a winning
position but this one seems you know in
a way even easier to play because there
just isn't as much risk but that doesn't
matter he has to win so he will have to
take whatever risks are necessary to
keep his winning chances alive a draw
loses the match
yeah so it's win or go home well
actually no not go home he still has a
match to play anyone if they lose today
so okay third fourth place matchup we
need to go back to the Magnus game
because crazy stuff is happening there
crazy stuff is happening there
okay whoa
and you blame me for wanting to go to
this game no now it really does feel
like a king's Indian in the best way
possible see I was giving the opening a
compliment your favorite opening is now
um living up to two reputation
touche so what has nepo sacrificed he is
now down two Pawns
is kingside is decimated but that
actually might be a good thing given the
potential of his Rooks
right blundering pawns is good because
it means that the files are cleared
so apparently we had according to the
chat a series of mutual mistakes I'm not
totally sure about that we don't really
have to delve
dude deeply okay so there was a trade on
D4 Rook d8
Rook D1 95 and Magnus deciding to grab
that pawn on H7 so is nepo going to play
the natural Rook h8 here
and I just want to point out that I
don't think it was much of a decision to
take on H7 because Queen G5 instead
allowed this beautiful Knight HD check
Fork upon us to take him Rook G8 winning
the queen and somehow it's even
better says zeros Queen G3 apparently
leads to an equal position if anybody
plays that you can go find the Arbiter
that is not within the purview of human
ability
androcate shade is on the board as is
Queen back to F5
and the Knight can actually jump into C4
and then into E3 where it attacks F5 D1
C2 and that pawn on G2 and it also
the H2 line because after Knight C4 if
that second Knight hops in somewhere
Queen takes H2 is on the docket Knight
C4 is a very scary move to me
oh it's ridiculously scary from All
perspen Black's King
is safe and another important detail is
that Knight takes C6 which looks
actually like a pretty devastating
tactic at first sight I think black has
this move 90 to check
but then we're going to rookie to Queen
H2 King yeah there okay and uh
I guess I take
you take the Evo bar is still not
dropping takes here Quincy too wait does
that work but then it's an equal end
game it's a beautiful move but in the
end I can take on A7 I think the move is
Knight B2
oh wow keep it simple
yeah yeah that whole thing very very
simple this whole variation nope that is
not how you end the line
that's so easy to calculate Robert I
think it should take about five seconds
right just very obvious moves there and
so okay in this position that that is
I'm glad you just showed that and I mean
that sincerely because in showing this
variation it illustrates why Knight C4
if we go back to the live position for a
second Knight C4 is the best move but
you have to be willing to allow Knight
takes C6 and what looks like a
devastating attack for white doesn't
actually pan out the way Magnus would
hope so Knight C4 is available but not a
move you can play without calculating
eight moves deep on the consequences of
Knight takes C6 which is why it's so
dangerous just look at the evil birds
and why isn't he playing the natural
move well oftentimes there is a move
which like you said has to be calculated
and they don't know in advance that the
eval bar shows plus 2.5 if they did it
would be so much easier just to assume
that the complications work out as it
stands they don't have that luxury
they're calculating from scratch and you
can just smell the wheels turning in
nepo's brain as he contemplates the
Knight Sally to C4
and he plays it and he's done the Palm
she is in fine form right now when he's
trusting himself and calculating he's
putting pressure on Magnus over the
board and on the clock and now Max is
looking this position like wait Knight
takes C6 oh no maybe Knight takes his
isn't what I thought it was and if
that's the case what other moves come to
mind Dania because Knight Discovery you
know night pick up the 9 F4 and just
pick a square with it Queen takes H2 to
follow is going to be devastating
first of all point out that Queen takes
D7 does not work unfortunately that's a
little too much to give in exchange for
a futile discover check
other than that ID3 is a devastating
threat the X-ray on H2 could be
devastating as well
Robert I
it beats me get me away from this
position I wouldn't touch it with a
10-foot pole I don't know how Magnus is
going to deal with this and his clock is
ticking down
yeah so as I look at this I'm just
trying to come up with any possible
resource for him G3 is obviously not
good there's E3 or my H3 that's not
gonna work out so
oh
how about instead of Knight C6 can you
move your knight back to B3 maybe
something like that
okay
this I can get behind so now you're
threatening made if I go for the same
idea 92. then what you're saying is that
this is an improved version yeah
oh can we show something very quickly
instead of Rook season two
a king F1 is with my knight G3 check oh
I mean there's also knife yeah neither
is good but this is cooler this is
beautiful so I have to take you take now
let's compare King goes where
I guess you go to F2 two I think
oh and Robert the key difference
remember that night used to be on C6 so
it could be captured at the end of the
line here black can do the same thing
but white is able to preserve both of
his minor pieces which obviously
complicates the game tremendously white
shouldn't be worse here and obviously
it's zeros because
what else could it be
I think white has better winning chances
in that final position with the minor
pieces but
I agree and the king is as safe as it's
been the entire game so 92 of course is
not forced black can take a template to
defend maybe with Knight D5
Knight D5 looks like a really good try
and then one of those Knights is going
to E3 probably the C4 Knight
what a game this is and this is split
play and see that line
rookie too Highlands there it is there
it is
oh my gosh that is very curious to see
how Magnus Carlson reacts here so
um you know
he's calculating once again
but now he's Frozen
and it doesn't really matter right
because if one king F2 will lead to the
same place exactly if King F1 you're
just extending it by one move the queen
can force the king to F2
has Magnus over plundered something
again and you can't really call this a
blunder Robert because at that point
there were really no alternatives
but I'm so curious what he missed
and Jan can force a draw at any moment
here like Queen H1 Queen H4 that would
just be a draw on the spot he's totally
gonna do that
no he certainly will not he's going to
calculate and find here it goes Queen H1
and I wonder if Magnus missed Knight B2
at the end or what the deal is exactly
or maybe he forgot that the B Pawn can
capture the Knight on C6 he thought the
Knight was saved due to the PIN
I mean but this is crazy
yawn's calculation has really been
um lighting the chessboard up in the
last couple games
just want to indicate that Jana's taking
a couple of seconds between each move
he's not rushing anything
and that's a great lesson for any young
chess players out there even the
greatest even after he's convinced
himself that the line Works double
checks on every move he knows and
understands the significance of this
moment there's that check on B2
and can Magnus go up to D4 I don't know
whoa young D4 winning King of the Hill
but probably losing fishing randomly
even just BC is game over
yeah that King is just gonna be hunted
Rook H4 Queen right yeah all sorts of
chips goodbye
oh my God is this curtains can Magnus
extend the game
yeah right he played King C3 and then
once the capture on D1 to capture on C6
happens he claims I have a bishop and
one Pawn uh for a rook and that should
give some chances at the very least to
survive Bishop C
[Music]
sector Rook H2
what really helps black is this Luft
Square on B7 rendering
any check on f8 totally futile right
how about man is there B5 or something
I'm just trying to open up that King
desperately
yeah you're trying to muddy the waters
you're being Robert Hess
and I think that if Jan were in time
trouble this could work out but I sure
John's not in time for a king B oh and I
think I can get away with grabbing this
Pawn
oh cause you protected the D6 and F4
squares that's amazing
into a winning end game but why does the
Intermezzo CD so
King T4 played oh my God
what is Magnus doing
this just loses on the spot
and he's gonna take the Knight bc6 and
Jan de palmishi he comes back from what
many would have considered the dead he
is the Undertaker he was in his casket
he sat up he is rising and right now
he's about to win his second game in a
row against Magnus Carlsen with the
black pieces this is over Dania
and with 11 minutes still on the clock
the strategy that he formulated before
the second game has worked two
Perfection Magnus is reeling he is not
himself
and the situation is more desperate than
ever if he moves his Rook he allows the
check on D2 and Robert if he doesn't
move his Rook then he loses all of his
pieces I think he's going to resign in
this position
and look just look at mag I mean he is
just beside himself
his confidence is in shambles I mean she
everyone said oh he can't play against
Magnus Carlson in the world chess
champion 2021 that may have been the
case look at Magnus right now he is just
getting blown off the board roke H4 ends
the game because if the king then drops
back to C3 you don't even take the Rook
you go Rook to C4
and you win everything you mop the
entire playing field here you take all
the white spaces
and Nepal gives that check
have you ever seen a position like this
involving Magnus 27 moves in a king on
D4 obliterated
this is Fisher random yes but I have
never seen Magnus lose in such one-sided
fashion I mean this was just so
one-sided it looked like Magnus was
better after he took on F5 but just
totally failing in the complications all
credit of course
to nepo for exhibiting nerves of Steel
giving away all those kingside Pawns
just Exquisite calculation
to see that Knight takes C6 loses and
over the course of the last few years
janapanashi has done what won the
candidates twice won the rapid Chess
Championship here in the Fisher random
Chess Championship in Reykjavik he is
looking like he's about to take down
Magnus for a second game in a row he is
proving himself in like every single
tournament he plays in I mean this guy
is not to be trifled with
no he's not I mean confidence is a great
word
to use in the context of Yonder promise
in the last two years he's a new man
he's playing with tremendous maturity
with objectivity and yet he still has
that vintage courage that nepo has
exhibited for his entire chess group
playing for a win with both colors
and now getting rewarded but Robert the
match is not over we have another game
Matt and he's resigned
the match is not over but Megs didn't
even wait for Yan to move he said I
cannot look at this position for a
second longer he is out of the playing
Hall and John de palmishi picks up his
second straight victory over world
champion Magnus Carlson Magnus in
disbelief he cannot fathom what is
happening here and Jana pomzy just
playing Stellar Fisher random chess and
we still have one game going here as uh
Magnus and Young's game is concluded
look at Hikaru Nakamura he is fighting
he is trying to claw back into this one
but I see Pawns in C5 and D5 Dania I'm
not liking the sight of that and I'm
totally ignoring the evil bar here the
position is wild it's complicated but
Hikaru has made a lot of Headway here
Robert he's situated a knight on F3
keeping White's entire King side at Bay
the overarching question can he keep the
past two pawns at Bay and neuterbeck has
something to say about that I think he's
ready to play C6
yes and he would love that Rook on A4 to
be on a score like B5 and an open file
uh this is a ridiculous looking position
and that Bishop on G1 that continues to
be the problematic piece for satara of
the good news is seven moves to make to
move 30 and he has five plus minutes
remaining so plenty of time to reach
time Patrol
yeah C6 is coming five minutes as you
said to make seven moves
this is close I mean notorbeck has done
everything he's needed to do and you
could argue that hikaru's Bishop H3 was
a gift
but all credit to Notre back and all
credit to Hikaru for as you said trying
to claw his way back in this game is far
from over the next seven moves Robert
are going to decide a lot
what moves should black even make right
now
yeah we're kind of procrastinating on
that question
so
I'm trying to think of logicals like
Rook F4 comes to mind just to be
aggressive in some way throwing Rook G4
oh that's one idea
oh
okay but you know moves somewhere he's
you have Rook B8 so it's neither here
nor there rugby it on the board
okay
okay so he his idea is to meet Knight
takes A5 obviously with
the infiltration to the second rank
white should probably keep this Knight
stationed firmly on B3
but then if you keep it there what yeah
what do you play with this night there
keep this night the bishop on G1 is
immobile
why it's just kind of running out of
fuel here
and C6 check I think would just allow
the black king to escape along the dark
squares right like you need to have your
pawns mobile and C6 would remove all
Mobility
all optionality when I first looked at
this position I I thought that White's
winning chances are still excellent the
more I look at this Robert the more I
simply don't understand
how white makes progress and how white
untangles on either side of the board
and I think that's exactly what
noterbeck is trying to do king G2 Bishop
H2 Maybe
but even if you make those moves black
takes and then captures on F2
right and Rook B4 here is an option for
hikar trying to trade Rooks not sure if
it's good but it is available to him
those C and D pawns I don't think
they're running fast enough and
the card plays H5 wow
and he's happy to keep the status quo he
basically says not a break hey
I mean come at me show me what you got
and if King G2 maybe just Knight H4
check and Knight back to F3 things like
that a rook coming to F3 if you're not
careful
and if okay Rook C4
another big settings almost
then a b
wait your move Rook before is also
yeah actually Rook B3 might just lose in
the spot for black like it's funny you
think oh I'm liquidating I'm getting a
cool tactic it's actually just really
bad I can show this on the board rook
b3ab3 and what happens as a result is
that you free up the bishop and allow it
to get to H2 and
I mean nothing more needs to be said all
I have to do is highlight these Pawns
yeah Knight B5 C6 C5 D6 Etc and that
would be done so you see that Bishop H4
oh here come notorbeck's Pawns
and maybe here comes a knight to C5
although Knight D2
oh shoot
I completely overlooked Knight D2 that's
so easy to miss though
wait so
what is this Rook C5 Maybe
so he goes King C7 I think it's Rook C5
yeah I completely missed that fork on uh
D2 there no but Rook C5 Knight takes G1
there's
Fork on F2 what is White's move here
is it rookie oh my gosh oh my gosh
no no Dania you yeah Knight C5 look just
put it on the board for a second Knight
D2 King E2 Knight C4 oh and Knight E6
and if you go to D6
I move my f-pawn and I check my unc5 no
wait where do you go do you go F4 oh no
you do go F4
oh my God this is a mate threat
okay black takes it but now Robert you
go Bishop C5 and you simply take on f8
and the pods promote oh my God there's
another main threat Knight D7 is
literally a mate threat
that's this is ridiculous I saw one
Checkmate threat so I was like okay let
me go for that I did not actually yeah
well no I just I'm a piece of funny like
a funny looking Checkmate I didn't see
any of the resulting complications what
a lot oh
but you can't believe that's it
he's just trying his best to Stave off
the immediate pressure but now it looks
like black is stabilizing completely wow
I've seen all these different checkmates
like in my head I'm calculating some of
the other lines and that is insane
because Knight C5 I completely
overlooked Nikes you check and it's like
wait it's actually trickier you have to
ask that question what happens if I do
it anyway can't stop calculating but so
much easier said than done and Robert at
the risk of jinxing Hikaru I feel like
that might have been notrebec's final
chance to stay in this match that insane
Rook sacrifice in the end game
and now Hikaru is firmly in charge he's
blocking the Pawns
do you see the universe where another
bike turns this one around
no because I don't um
he needs to free this bishop on G1 but
it's never getting out of there there's
just no way to free maybe if you can
trade off this then F3 somehow
but
somehow is the hard part what about
Knight takes A5
just grab a pawn or rugby one ugh
yeah off me Rook takes G1 mate
Black's the one who checkmates the white
king
so he goes out with Knight to E3 and if
you get a rook trade maybe that Knight
goes back to D2 to at least get rid of
that annoying Knight that is blocking up
clogging the position
what the queen
yeah so
what should a car do here you can't
force a draw right there's no Knight H4
Knight F3 back and forth because then
white will just make some other move
yeah that's the slightly tilting thing
here if you're Hikaru is that you can
sense that you're probably already much
better but there is no way to like force
the result that you want what about A4
oh A4 D6
oh good eye it ain't over D6 clearance
sacrifice and then the Knight leaps into
D5 with a fork still actually not so
clear
it's unbelievable you like make a what
looks like game
saving or game winning move and it's
just still better for black yeah because
after a b a b there's a move Knight to
D2 dislodging the road and taking the
night what's with these lines where you
allow a full Rook to be captured and
then somehow you're still better
yeah no this is just
a ridiculous position and he trades on
C4
and plays Rook F4 he's going right after
the E4 upon nice move
Exquisite technique by Hikaru because if
the Knight drops back to D2 you trade
and send the bishop over to B4 and once
this Pawn Falls it's like removing the
the wrong Block in a Jenga game the
whole structure topples over
it's actually a really good analogy so
uh yeah this is really bad news for
nordbeck because he can't even afford to
draw this game he's worse and you think
okay fight for a draw no no you need to
win because you're down two games to
none so
Hikaru Nakamura look at him right now he
had what seemed to be a bad and really
tough position and as we zoom in on him
he is straight chilling over there he's
got a fashionable shirt on he's about to
lock this match up winning just three
games
he's a force yeah I mean it's just it's
just insane
and it's so easy to forget that Notre
back scored the highest point total by
far
of anyone in the tournament in the
preliminary stage he was beating
everybody 2-0 but then he meets ikaro
and that in initial moment leaving that
Queen on A2 Robert that was the straw
that broke the camel's back that set in
motion a ridiculous chain of reaction at
the end of which Hikaru is sitting
pretty and ending the match even without
the necessity of a game four
and I'm just trying to come with any
possible idea for black excuse me for
white in this position uh for North Beck
and there's nothing Knight H4 check
followed Rook takes E4 is on the dock
and as you pointed out once E4 Falls a
pawn chain is only as strong as its base
Pawn uh the E4 Pawn is decent the D5
Pawn easy to Target so they're just
gonna collapse like a stack of dominoes
there and
too strong on this day yeah just nerves
of Steel able to squeeze and wiggle his
way out of any situation this game I
honestly thought was likely to be over
in like 20 moves I thought it would be a
white victory
and Hikaru just hunkering down not
letting his blunders get to him
in contrast to Magnus
right and Hikaru has he hasn't lost a
single game nope
in this entire tournament oh wait did he
yeah he
no he drew uh all four games to photo
save he beat Magnus one and half half in
the first match and then they tied one
to one in the second right
just unbelievable
just the guy will not be defeated and
that's the thing about hikaras even when
he has bad positions he is so incredible
at muddying the waters about finding
tactics making his opponent's life
difficult and at the start of this
queenless position done he was like wait
Black's piece on the back row and then
where we are now is just like uh
uh how why where ridiculous and it's not
just the fact that he is able to pull
these games out it's the consistency
with which he does that I think that's
not mentioned enough because everybody
at the top most grand masters from time
to time will hunker down and exhaust
every last chance but Hikaru does it
with ridiculous regularity it seems that
every single time he has a bad position
I can't remember the last time he lost a
lost position it's crazy
what were you just saying he hasn't lost
in this event so yeah I can't even think
the last time he lost the game
uh the guy just refuses to lose in the
global Championship as well it's a rapid
format he has made his way through the
top eight and in his matches he has not
lost the game he beat um Rodrigo Vasquez
he beat
um Dave Navarra he beat Leonard
Dominguez and he drew some of those
games and didn't always look like the
Hikaru that we're used to but he did not
lose a single game there my coach would
always say that in response to me saying
that I get really upset when I lose said
there's two options well the first is to
get over yourself the second is just to
never lose and I met that rhetorically
but apparently Hikaru has taken that
wisdom to Heart
he's just not losing in games at this
stage I mean of course he lost a
heartbreaker to dingley Wren in the
final round of the candidates that is
what allowed the Chinese number one the
number two player in the world behind
Magnus Carlson to face Jana palmchi for
the new Crown because Magnus Carlson
won't play but look at hikara right now
right it's the guy is just on cloud nine
he is just looking around and he is
ready to go through sail through to the
finals and face the winner of Jana
pomshi and Magnus Carlson we are
watching Notre back's final two minutes
takedown he has already made move 30.
he's gotten all of the additional time
that he will get
and with every ticking second the
desperation of the situation is becoming
more and more inevitable
the car will rest he will watch what
might be the final game between Magnus
and nepo a must win for Magnus Robert it
is a crime for anybody to leave cancel
your weekend brunch
don't you dare turn on the TV you are
staying here because this I think is
going to be an epic game 4 between
Magnus and nepo
I already looked at the time I was way
past brunch time I'm getting hungry just
thinking about it and hikar is thinking
about wait what am I going to eat after
this he's like look at this what's for
dinner I have to say
in my time in Iceland uh I'm not a big
fish person but the best fish I've ever
had has been in Reykjavik the fish there
is unbelievable
do you know who is a big fish person
oh
fedo save
really I should know that about him oh
[Laughter]
it's a shame that we weren't on oh there
now everyone could see your reaction
oh
oh come on Donya you'll be okay even
though Rebecca's cringing at that pun
that was good and you know that was good
I like it I like it I I am just jealous
especially in context of my Dirk nine
one Goods
yeah that was not the best one you've
ever come up with I'll be honest
you could be honest okay you won't hurt
my feelings
I can find a new commentator tomorrow
no no no need you here buddy all right
and I didn't that resistance did not
take long wait also 20 seconds remaining
like noribbeck hasn't
moved over he just went Knight D2 no but
it should be four
yeah this is you just didn't find a move
simply this is tantamount to
capitulation
mm-hmm
no fun here to have the white piece in
this game so swap swap Bishop B4 at the
end and you're dropping E4 and your
pawns still are not moving anywhere
if a drug kept wide in the match we
would still be talking about this game
given that a draw wins the match for
black there is simply nothing left to
discuss and I think Notre back might
simply either resign or offer a draw
same thing after Hikaru uncorks these
last two moves
and he does
and that is all she wrote ladies and
gentlemen
yeah Knight G5 maybe one last try
the problem is you get one check on E6
and then it's still not good enough yeah
Bishop D6 I think is the most prudent
just solidifying securing at Pawn on E5
yeah
one check and that's it the king moves
away and your pawns are still stuck so
Bishop B6 looks great
I guess Bishop D6 5
oh no no no if you play Knight F7 then
the king Still Remains on C7 you can't
give for the check on E6 and then go
Knight F7
yeah and Hikaru very patient very
methodical
and Nutter back you can just tell in the
way that he's moving he knows that the
result is inevitable
yeah you gotta feel for him right
because he was dominant if this had the
same format or the same tournament
structure as the world rapid
Championship which he won he would be
the Fisher random Champion but it was a
group stage on the way to a knockout and
sadly for him he will find himself in
the consolation match tomorrow against
the loser of napomnacy Carlson but still
I mean you know it's going to be tough
to take in this defeat to Hikaru but
Hill
be proud of himself he should be at
least he's playing great chest this is
the part where we're supposed to say
that Notre back is only 18. and I feel
like that phrase has to be added to the
end of every conversation
in a tournament that he doesn't
necessarily achieve his best result in
first of all winning his group is
nothing to sneeze at ikaro is in
ridiculous form right now this is not an
embarrassing result and there's still a
lot of money on the line tomorrow so I
think neuterberg is a comeback French
French he's gonna come back maybe he can
play the French it will change his
Federation tonight
and he will be joining alireza on the
Olympia team yeah I was going to say
there's another teenager very talented
one who became French but it's not
already back in okay pieces are getting
traded off so okay that's it
yes King takes D6 looks
nice takes the Rook all right yeah so
good knight E5 I guess but the way I
guess Rook D5 F4 Rook D2 yeah
or immediately Rook D2 he's just gonna
go for the a Pawn Win It And
take it to the house a white resignutto
very shortly
for a signature yeah
as they say in Italian
nice rocket too Knight C4 only way and
then push that pawn to A4 to a safe
square if
if it's Schoolboy approach you take on
C6 and then go King D5
he's like no I have to draw
I think a car wants to win
yeah A4
he does he does he did it Jesus I can't
talk anymore we have another game to
commentate
you'll be good for when that one comes
around Rook C3 take a three and
this
is it
there it is resignation Hikaru Nakamura
makes his way through to the finals of
the Fisher random Chess Championship in
Reykjavik ice on the Arbiter stopping
the clock but Hikaru Nakamura in three
games a clean sweep I think there's
should be a round of applause for him
but he's gonna have a tough fight
tomorrow no matter whom he faces but for
now he can eat a nice dinner and then go
to sleep a happy man because he secured
minimum 85
000.
the consistency is simply unbelievable
does he play mistake free chess
absolutely not nobody does especially
not on Fisher random but every time an
inaccuracy is committed it's like he
redoubles his efforts and I don't think
at any point in the match did he make
two mistakes in a row it was clean the
technique was Flawless the resistance
was vintage Hikaru and a 3-0 result
against a beast of a player in Notre
back I was just start off tells us
everything we need to know
for sure so who will the car play we
don't know that just yet Jana pomshi he
has the lead he won two games in a row
with the black pieces I mean the guy is
in great shape and if you're Hikaru I
don't know who you'd rather face on one
hand you're like oh anyone who's not
Magnus is the best opponent to face
because I don't want to play Magnus but
the way Jan is playing I don't think you
want to face him either
I don't think you do and I think your
car is just gonna settle down with a
nice dinner
and watch the festivities unfold we have
one more game to commentate it is game
four and it is a must win for Magnus
Carlson this is epic the stage is set
Robert we simply could not ask for a
better finale
no I couldn't and for Magnus Carlson who
has suffered two straight losses no time
to get timid he's got to bring out his
best stuff his Fighting Chess and while
we're talking about being brave might as
well give a shout out to this prevent
presenting sponsor of this coverage
Brave means private browsing and so much
more by default Brave blocks ads and
trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com
chess don't you switch the channel away
Daniel noraditski and myself Grand
Master Robert has we'll be right back in
a few for more from the Fisher random
world championship this coverage brought
to you by Brave
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
seconds for black so not too much time
there either Rook C7 A7 is falling uh it
is E4 he pushes the pawn this is getting
a little messy takes a knight F1
91. move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played
hey
Google
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that was there and instead he
played here
oh my God A7 wins for white oh my gosh
[Music]
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest muscles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we are back here at the Fisher random
World Championship we see world champion
Magnus Carlsen looking agitated done in
I think that's putting it nicely
agitated shifting his seating position
holding his head in his hand something
that he has been doing a great deal in
the last two games and the last thing
that one can do is blame him the world
champion has struggled with blunders all
tournament long and it has come to a
head in these last two games
listen he was up 1-0 what a complete 180
we have had and all credit to Yan his
strategy has worked to perfection
it has and there's a reason he's won two
games in a row with the black pieces
against the strongest chess player on
the planet but this is Fisher random and
right now the player who has the most to
celebrate is Hikaru Nakamura because
while Yanda Palm she has his lead thus
far Hikaru has
cemented his spot in the final he is
receiving minimum 85
000 and now it's a matter of whom he
will face not whether he'll make it
there he swept nerdy bear sitar of 3-0
listen given the world champions Forum I
think he almost would prefer to face
Magnus and the point that I wanted to
make is that for yawn it is absolutely
crucial not to try to artificially alter
the strategy that brought him success in
the previous two games I think what an
inexperienced player would do is say hey
now that I need a draw let me try to
modif modify the amount of risk that I
take let me try to play more
conservatively that is not how Yanda
Palm Desi achieved success he has to
play the same way every game and I think
we're gonna see the same yawn who plays
quickly in the opening Pace takes risks
as the position demands and somebody who
is actually playing for a win in this
game as the best way to achieve the
desired result
yeah I agree and there's no real way
we've talked about this to play for a
draw and Fisher random you just don't
know what to do in the early stages
there are no forcing variations there's
no theory that you can rely upon so for
yawn what do you think is he can going
to continue playing at that ridiculously
fast speed or do you think the nerves
might get to him and he might slow down
a bit and that actually might be bad for
his overall met strategy well perhaps
that's something to discuss with Nikita
vitugov I think for yawn to keep his
nerves at Bay playing quickly will
actually help him because John's
intuition is so legendary that I think
when he plays quickly chances are he at
the very least makes very strong
practical moves when Jan starts to
second guess himself and double and
triple check things I think that that
will have a detrimental effect of his
play so my prediction is that we will
indeed see the same kind of
janapomnishing craziness in terms of
clock management that we've seen in
these last three games
and we look at Magnus Carlson who is
staring at the floor trying to figure
out his game strategy here because
um you know with the position the
knights in the corner maybe we can pull
up a board and show everybody what that
position is just our mind our viewers of
the randomness of Fisher random uh there
are knights in the corner right there
are Bishop on G1 and the bishop on G1
never got out for noribeca busataro so
you know when you look at that other
game you remember what has happened in
your own you just looking around this
board like this is weird
and I think Magnus is probably expecting
on to repeat uh dream of which was also
played in the Hikaru game
but I wonder if Magnus will adopt Yan's
strategy of pushing a lot of these
kingside pawns something tells me Magnus
will try to play a little bit more
solidly in the opening
but we'll see
we'll see yes because Jan played
ambitiously he was like playing a king's
Indian we are discussing that opening
before and he sacrificed upon then a
second opened up lines and was able to
defeat Magnus Carlsen so young now gets
white will we saw the handshake we see
him sitting down jacket is off and will
he play Knight G3 on move one looks like
a reasonable try but I'm most curious
about his speed more than anything the
moves of course will tell the story but
the speed with which he plays them I'll
be curious if he keeps up that confident
style that has allowed him to win two
games in a row
well seat belts fastened ladies and
gentlemen as the ceremonial first move
is made and then retracted as is
traditional
and Magnus still with his head in his
hands and still showing the signs of
Agony he's gonna have to put all of that
behind him Magnus Carlson has delivered
time and time again Robert something
tells me that he isn't just going to
melt into a heap and give Yan an easy
game
although I mean I mean look at him right
now he is not going to give Yan an easy
game but he looks like he wants to be
anywhere besides the board that he's
sitting at
wants to be
on F5 or H5 Knight G3 has been played
and Magnus
play F6
F6
now that is a surprising move Robert are
you kind of puzzled by F6 as well just
instinctively
I totally understand that move if I've
removed the Dynamics I am surprised but
then when I think about it that Jan you
know can draw and win this match that
perhaps Magnus is just trying to play
a random first move and say John
couldn't have looked at this with Batu
golf right they looked at all these
other moves F6 is not one that was on
their radar and yet it makes White's
life pretty easy because F6 doesn't
restrict the Knight on G3 in any way it
does open the bishop on G8 but what
about that Bishop on d8 where is that
going and I guess it's going on the d8
A5 diagonal yeah Bishop A5 uh or Bishop
C7
is to be expected Magnus copies Jan's
Queen side approach with C5 and at least
the tempting move for me is Bishop C2
building a little bit of a battery
and inducing perhaps another weakening
move on the king's side so I'm curious
if Jan will go for that or will he
instead put an accent on Queen side play
he does with Knight A1 to B3 totally
logical move as well Robert getting the
Knight out of there sure
and what you give Megan some hope is our
featured chat that you know black has
won five out of six films today and I
actually wonder what the overall scores
are because I wouldn't be surprised if
black playing with the black pieces does
uh wonders for players here and Knight
B3 about this particular position just
normal development here for Magnus he
already seems like he's struggling to
make early moves as Beyond continue to
play quickly and this is obviously the
kind of strategy that Magnus has to
adopt as he focuses on unbalancing the
position as quickly as possible
breathing some chaos into the board
yeah I like this move this move looks
combative but in a measured way it
doesn't look like a tilt move and the
genres knows immediately
and now c4 and if a knight jumps to D4
then play E5 just start throwing your
pawns forward and it was a worthy Pawn
sacrifice but I think you're about to
win the pawn right back
yeah C4 now does the Knight have any
alternative scores I don't think so you
basically have to play Knight D4 and
bear the brunt off Black's early Pawn
storm
and it's on the board Knight D4 has been
played
so after 75 where's he moving his Knight
to F5 I guess and then would you follow
up with D5 or would you capture that
pawn no no no no no I apologize
to hang the G7 Pawn as well let me just
show this line E5 Knight F5
Queen takes B5 there's no Knight D6
because of Bishop
that's a roof stopped me in my tracks
I'm sorry oh you're you're all fine so
back we go
after Knight F5 I think the move G6 is
likely so I I don't think that John
wants Magnus to keep pushing Pawn after
pawn and just move his Knight all around
the board so I feel like a retreating
move
is a good option but where to so you're
you're having your eyes on Knight F3
perhaps
I guess by elimination yes Knight C I
mean Knight C2 looks like it makes less
sense it blocks in the queen and the
bishop
I'm not playing nice to ever yeah no get
that out of my face
so Knight F3 I guess black will play D5
and perhaps John will take the
materialistic approach and just cling to
his extra Pawn on the queen side and say
hey you don't have any pieces developed
I'm not worried about your pawns alone
and maybe that's a fair
statement right what is black gonna do
there's no Checkmate anything of the
sword uh but the question I was asking
before the game started how would Dion
spend his time uh so far it's about even
match up on the clock I mean I think
y'all will spend a little bit more time
figuring out his move here but to me
that's a good sign for Magnus that he
finally has Jan sitting and thinking and
not just confidently making amazing
moves
and I haven't uttered this phrase
because I've been so enthralled with
Jan's strategy but I actually think he
rushed it on the first move C takes B5
was far from Forced he could have
defended this Pawn with D3 He could have
counter-struck in the center with D4 I
think those moves merited a little bit
more consideration than he gave them I
guess D4 was not possible because of it
made on A5 but still it just seems like
Jan has been dragged into the kind of
position that he would prefer to have
with the black faces that's right this
is a sort of style he just won that game
with the black face a good point there
Dania that he is walking into a position
that he would prefer from his opponent's
vantage point so he's thinking he's down
on the clock for the first time in
forever and again this is good news if
you're a Magnus Carlson or one of his
fans you have yawn exactly where you
want him in a position that's Dynamic
where their chances for both sides or
Yan is not just blitzing everything out
where the pawns are storming for black
and you can see how White's pieces are
restricted I think this is all you could
ask for if you're Magnus it most
certainly is and Jan senses the gravity
of these next few decisions investing
perhaps the longest think of this entire
match before deciding to drop the Knight
back to F3 and intuitively this makes a
lot of sense to me I agree that Knight
F5 maybe would have further doused
uh the initiative in flames and G6
Anyway by Magnus Carlson even though
there's no Knight on F5 what do you make
of that wow
big decision there by Magnus uh he just
wanted to keep a night out that's clear
I guess Queen takes B5 was met by that
Knight F5 tactic hitting the G7 Pawn we
can show that real quick uh G7 Pawn
would have been under attack and a fork
on DC or Monster Fork a family Fork so
he oh you can't Castle I thought you
could no I was just showing that there's
a darn Bishop on G8 and even if you
could there would still be Knight D6
true so here black would have to part
ways with this incredibly important Pawn
on G7
so Magnus with a prophylactic move
restricting
that Knight on G3 who needs development
anyway
I just like the speed with which Magnus
is playing he is playing like Jan does
and it's worked out perfectly for yonda
palmshi so why not for mags in H3 Bishop
H2 and castles is what he wants wow what
a setup
I like it
I think that's brilliant
like completely seriously I think that
this little quiet move H3 which I did
not have my I was looking at C4 upon
using A4 for white or B3 or do something
he just was H3 and his next few moves
are Bishop H2 and castle like you're
saying and he's saying well there are no
more weaknesses in my camp and you're
lacking development all eight of your
pieces on the back Rank and the scary
prospects for black as Magnus continues
to push his spawns forward is that
ultimately One swipe completes his
development Bishop H2 is played all nepo
needs to do Robert is Strike once in the
center and if Magnus doesn't develop in
time his entire position could turn into
dust like in the span of one move
wow really nice play here from Jan
fianchetto randomly fun
good move there and why is she just
castle and I played D3 as you're
indicating
and it looks like just don't play D3
right now
and he casts but D3 would have been a
huge blunder instead of castling because
that Bishop A5 checked that you're
showing now and that's how you lose
games of fish are random exactly you
miss these unconventional Avenues and
diagonals and yawn picking up the pace
the clock still totally not a factor
both sides are for 20 minutes
and it's clear to me Robert that Magnus
has to
accelerate his development but what does
he develop first nothing is developed
yet his King is still in the center this
is a difficult decision for the world
champion to make
right because he needs to win this game
so he knows that B3 or D3 is kind of
probably E3 at this point is offering
some trades and you know he's playing
with a piece that he's captured the pawn
that he just took on B5 but I mean it
just doesn't feel fun to have this maybe
Knight B6 just try to figure out where
your pieces below other pieces belong
after and just cover everything that
might be attacked but yeah it's such a
challenging moment
yeah maybe solidify the pawn on C4 in
order to take the sting out of B3
another situation where I would pay very
little heed uh to the eval bar at the
very least until black is able to set
his development in motion I would take
white here any day of the week
especially on Saturday
yeah I'm with you I think one thing that
I'm trying to keep in mind is normally
when we hear Queen trades in a must-win
game we think that's bad for the side
that is trying to catch up so for Magnus
you don't want to trade Queens but just
because the Queens are traded doesn't
mean the game is immediately a draw so
B3 and B takes E4 as the next couple
moves I actually don't think that Magnus
should fear the queen trade so just
let's make the move B3 just for uh
argument's sake and then I'll make the
move Bishop E6 so I can play Knight F7
next
and he played bc4 Queen B1 Rook B1 and
take back on C4 here I feel like you
know the game just continues right it's
just a position where black has a strong
Center the bishop on H2 is a little odd
but you know White's not in trouble but
it's kind of just a position in who
plays better from here will be the side
that uh can claim the advantage
especially given Magnus Carlson's
legendary endgame prowess
I'm totally on the same page I don't
think that this constitutes his greatest
fear I think his greatest fear is
precisely the opposite that the Queens
will stay on the board and that NEPA
will be able to open up the center and
punish black for delaying is kingside
development
I think his greatest fear is not that
he's inadequate but that he's powerful
beyond belief
okay I know this is I know the drill
right the drill and the procedure is
always the same I know it's a reference
get the reference I'm supposed to get it
you explain it
and then we move on so what's that
reference from you'll have to look it up
later okay
positive of course they will but I don't
have chat open so you know I biscuit no
it's not Limp Biscuit okay great
eating
this is how you play for a draws wedge a
solid balanced position but E3 what is
smells a little bit this move he wants
Bishop B2 and B3 I think that's pretty
obvious
but doesn't this you get black time just
develop yeah that's the thing it's
really cumbersome
so what do you play Bishop E6 Knight F7
and castle
I like that for sure
huh so let's prognosticate let's say
Bishop B6 Bishop E2 Knight F7
uh clearly the idea is to play B3
and what you're saying is that black can
just ignore
yeah BC already is a better end game for
black
right yeah no this is not what you want
if you're you're on the punch I actually
agreed with that feature chat before the
movie E3 was played I'm like everything
looks perfect just played B3 you hang
out but yeah now it's looking a little
shaky
I think Jan has overcooked it a little
bit Yeah E3 immediately nothing wrong
with that
now he's given black all the Time in the
World to get all of his pieces to
perfectly coordinated squares he plays
B3 without Bishop E2 but then that begs
the question why did you play E3
you know what was the upside of delaying
B3
did he somehow not want magnusly D4 or
something like that
yeah maybe
although D4 does yield the E4 Square
although then there's Knight F7 to guard
D6
I'm just trying to figure out why he
would have thrown in E3 just feels he
gives black the time and for Magnus he
can Castle right now or just bring the
king Over The Rook he can play Knight F7
which
think he's gonna play
oh this is exactly what you want if
you're a Magnus and give a position with
chances
a position with chances and in which you
have taken tactics largely out of the
equation at least for the time being
they're never truly out of the equation
in fish are random as Magnus does indeed
decide to Castle first but this is
essentially as close as it gets to a
wildly solid position in Fisher random
with excellent winning chances
problem
for Yawn is if bc4 Queen B1 Rook B1 if
those are our next few and actually we
might just see this happen now they are
I think Magnus can even take with the D5
Pawn on C4 that may seem
counterintuitive against the principles
that your coaches have taught you in
chess oh you want your pawns together
um you know you don't want to create an
isolate upon for yourself and he does
just that because look at the pawn on D2
that is a backwards Pawn you can't push
it up to D3 or D4 because the C4 Pawn so
now black needs to move the Bishop from
d8 bring a rook to d8 and just play down
the D file and Magnus for sure is better
here
oh no question about it he's he holds
all the cards he's better and this is as
you pointed out exactly the kind of
advantage that he prefers if he could
choose between a tactical Advantage an
attack or a clear static advantage in
the end game it's not even a choice for
the world champion this is where he's
made a a living this is where he's
earned his titles
this is a dangerous dangerous couple of
moves for John upon the she has to stay
very precise
if he doesn't want uh this position to
sort of slip from his grasp
grasp
it might have yeah this plan looks so
simple Bishop E7 Rook d8 Knight F7 like
we see
a series of moves for black all of which
are logical take zero effort what's
White's plan right Bishop
C2 maybe for white and then what I'm not
so sure
and what seemed like a brilliant plan
just a couple of moves ago putting the
bishop on H2 oh he's going to play F4
and open up the king side now all of
these plants lack luster because the
Queens are off the board they take a
long time and White's resources are
strained as it is
opening up another front is out of the
question Magnus though with H7 H5
preventing G4
was that worth preventing Robert in your
opinion I think maybe also opening up G5
followed by G4 for himself to kick this
Knight out of F3 I I was not expecting
H5 I generally trust Magnus and his uh
intuition in these types of positions
but it felt like it wasn't playing in
the part of the board that he ultimately
needs to aim at
yeah and Jan immediately trying to
exploit it by deploying his Bishop to C2
that was the only obvious move he had in
his position now as you've hinted at the
big question how does he follow up if
Magnus plays a move like Knight F7
well the G6 Pawn is a bit loose so I
could see an argument against 907 and
whoa what just happened yeah Bishop Rook
B5
they're what a sacrifice on E5 at some
point or something like that
well that's definitely not out of the
question or the Bishops aligned and
undefended as they are also The Rook can
swing over to A5 wow and harass perhaps
Black's only weakness
a485 is another idea for white to go for
and if black plays C3
then you can actually just take on CP3
and meet Bishop C4 with Bishop B3
counterpinning the black Bishop that's
actually a really really important
variation because otherwise C3 would be
a nice idea for black does not work in
this position
yeah and is it too early to say Robert
that H5 might have been somewhat
unnecessary maybe it was important for
Magnus to get his pieces out as fast as
possible precisely to prevent a move of
this sort that generates activity on the
queen side yeah what did it what did H5
do for him that's what I'm trying to
figure out I mean is GeForce such a
dangerous idea like isn't even trying to
play F5
at least not in the immediate future
and H5 is one of those moves the
evaluation was something a slight
Advantage for black right like it wasn't
mine can we just can you just show me
what the evaluation was there yeah the
evaluation was something like point
0.7 for black
okay point seven territory yeah and
immediately after H5 it's already like
0.1.2 and White's favor
and it's interesting because I think
when we considered terminology blunder
inaccuracy mistake error whatever it may
be
um when you go through a game quickly
okay H5 is just a move like it's
whatever but it actually seems to be a
huge mistake from Madness right it
didn't give away the advantage to yawn
it's like John's winning after them it
wasn't that kind of blunder but it just
gave young the one move he needed to get
active and start creating ideas of his
own whereas H5 doesn't it just prevented
G4 maybe but I really am having a hard
time
breaking down the rationale for the move
h7h5 I do as well I'm on the same page I
think Magnus just didn't have his
priorities in order the priority should
have been get your pieces out ASAP pile
up on the D2 Pawn make it difficult for
white to attain any activity and he's
given Yan that one extra Tempo given his
Rook a chance to dive into B5 with that
being said Robert the position still
probably the magnus's liking if you
showed him this position before the game
he would probably say give me this I'm
I'll take it any yawn doubling Rooks on
the B file
making strides to free himself
and get his pieces active Rook fd8 is
met by
what exactly he's met by you do but I
guess we're about to find out Rook fd8
is on the board
could it be Rook A5
and then Rook D7 I guess just keep
defending everything yeah that's a bit
of a paper tiger maybe sending the a
pawn down the board
is you know a little bit has a little
bit more meat on the bone
right but F5 is is too difficult of a
move for black to make work
yeah it's important to point out that if
the night drops Back in Black plays E4
you say I win the D2 Pawn no you don't
because the F3 Knight swings over to
this beautiful Outpost
that black creates by pushing the E Pawn
and then black can resign exactly with
such an idea okay yep
if you allowed such night you get kicked
out immediately
uh you should I mean the bishop on H2
and the Knight on D4 yikes that's a
problem for black so F5 is
not even about to happen so Rook A5
seems fine and maybe King F1 just
bringing the king toward the center
ah but then maybe already C3 is possible
oh okay so I walked into a tactic
but even like C3 is not totally the end
of the story white could even second
Exchange in some lines but of course
given the tournaments into the match
situation Yan
will try to play a little bit more
conservatively Rook A5 has been executed
they killed it
a rook
he said I don't play Rook C7 that's for
sure
I think his idea might be Knight C3
Knight B5 and that's precisely the
reason why Rook C7 is inferior
it was also Rook C7 might run to Knight
D4 so
I'm even flirting with Rook A7 but
unfortunately it doesn't quite work
you're just trying to give away pieces
aren't you like always I can't help it
I get it Rook D7 played I think he's
gonna go Knight C3
and then after King G7 You're Gonna Go
Knight B5
as superficial as it looks I
will challenge you to defend that A7
Pawn
seems very superficial but he's going
for it
superficial young that's why they call
him that
um
I actually have an idea so King G7
okay
the Knight B5 is meant by Rook C5 Maybe
ah and if Rook takes A7 there's a little
35 I think it's not the end of the story
or K7 Rook V6 Rook H2 oh you can't take
because of the back
ground Bishop covering the lift Square
a lot of players know all about that
incredible sequence and we're seeing it
Knight b5pr it has been played
and you know maybe there was an
alternative idea with Rook A6 clearing
the pathway for the a pawn I started
liking that a little bit more when I
spotted it Beyond sticking to his
original intention
and big moment for Magnus will we see
Rook C5
and are there other moves that also
are good I was just going for a simple
pin
um look like a good strategy to employ
but is there something Rook I mean Rook
A8 is so passive
it is and then I could even drop back to
C3 the threaten Rook takes B6 what about
Rook C5 and then Rook A6
how are you going to proceed in that
case
ah maybe G5 G4 an old friend pays pays a
visit there's also Knight C8 as well
oh wait I'll hang in Bishop 26 ignore me
yeah
you should show the blunder just so
everyone feels good about themselves
that exactly I just gave away a free
piece I said I just want to make
everybody know that Robert Hess is
blundered a piece I did say Knight C8
hanging my Bishop 26. yep yep that is
that's tough man
it is tough I just want to be honest in
one move I mean it happens to the best
of us don't worry
and the worst so I just wanted to be
very transparent with everybody I I did
hang that piece so okay Rook C5 Rook A6
does look a bit annoying now that I
can't easily defend A7
Knight
to D5 by the world champion
simply giving up the A7 funny says I
don't care about it go take it
I'm gonna focus on keeping my pieces as
centralized as possible
so what is the specific idea
well there's night before insertions
that won't be super nice to deal with I
feel like
so let's say I play Rook A7 what exactly
do you do Knight B4 first Maybe
I was also thinking maybe you could take
and go Rook A8
and if y goes Rook B7 and The Rook can
be oh look at this construction this is
crazy I don't think I've ever seen that
black woods yeah I've never seen that
before
the Bishops defend the Knight the
knights and the Knight defends the
bishop whoa
the other roof hasn't broke and yeah the
Rooks kicked off the seventh rank
wow this is like a monster
it's like a four-headed four-headed
dragon there
I think he made the a3s like the
quietest move possible yeah he's like I
don't care about anything that's going
on
I'm just keeping my composure but now
the bishop can access the C5 square if
Magnus wants to defend A7 in an active
way
I like Bishop C5 the rookon A5 reminds
me of hikaru's rook in game one against
noribbeck where it can create some
threats here and there but it might also
get trapped so Bishop C5 followed by
Bishop B6 you're getting closer and
closer to trapping that Rook on A5 and
you can throw in C3 at any moment thanks
to the Knight 95.
yeah even though there's been sort of
deviations in the individual moves it
feels like the overall Arc of the game
has favored Magnus ever since Jan played
this E3 move right
right hasn't been perfect there were
some chances for yawn but the the play
is awkward as a rook gun A5 and a knight
on B5 attacking this teeny little Pawn
on A7 whereas look at Black's pieces
nicely centralized the pawn on D2 is a
long-term Target so Magnus is sitting
and thinking right here and trying to
figure out what he should do because I
feel like
he's both a bit dejected but he's also
looking at this position like wait a sec
I feel like I've got some good chances
uh if I can find the right series of
moves listen he's going to be anointed
himself even if he manages to win this
game win the Armageddon and then defeat
Hikaru those are the standards to which
he holds himself but you can just tell
he's back in the game he knows that this
is really the best kind of position he
could possibly have asked for
and I think he's trying to decide
between Bishop C5 or your uh previous
idea Rook C5 which is still very
enticing indeed given the incredibly
precarious nature of White's Rook and
why is Jan shaking his head so much he's
bothered by something
in this game
your face he's reacting much more than
normal
pretend I didn't say that
[Laughter]
he's bothered by something well maybe
the fact that he realizes his position
has deteriorated quite a bit
and magnets with plenty of time on the
clock right he's got nine and a half
minutes or so and I'm into 43 seconds
um as I see on his clock live he did
just for the move Bishop C5 so when the
uh dgt catches up but he is doing well
in the clock he's doing well on the
board and Jan's piece is just all over
the place
yeah he's Walking the Tightrope on the
queen side his Rook could get trapped
let's not forget that that pawn on D2 is
still a long-term weakness so you can
Envision a future where the Knight moves
away from D5
and The Rook exerts tremendous pressure
on that pawn
oh man oh man Buckle in ladies and
gentlemen
strap yourselves in
I don't know what the best response to
Bishop C5 should be I just feel like I
would Panic If I Were Young to heat
Rook 86 A6
I think he's attacking the bishop I'm
not sure though
now I'm on the lookout for that you are
correct that Bishop is under attack whoa
and there are some crazy tactics if
Magnus intercepts I think there's Knight
takes A7
good call
and white breaks free of the chains so
how if not Bishop B6 does Magnus defend
the bishop on E6
well process of elimination Knight d8 on
the other move only move
I guess rookie seven is also possible
but that just seems really awkward and
the last thing you want to do is move
the Rook away from the D file
yeah that is a great move don't really
want to move my knight away from the
coverage of E5 I understand you're
giving up a minor piece for a couple
pawns but something about
that you know the dangling tactic is uh
annoying me from afar
this H5 move if yon manages to sack on
E5 Magnus is going to regret anymore
or did he
does he see something in this position
and what could it be well we have to
keep a an Eagle Eye on magnus's reaction
should yon take on A7 because that will
tell us everything we have to know and
it's such an easy thing to overlook so
donya's point of her Knight takes A7 the
bishop should not take on A7 because
Rook takes E6 you're just giving away a
piece so white gets a pawn uh there if
you take on A7 with the Rook Rook B
takes B6 seems impossible because the
Knight defends the square but then the
A7 lost its Defender and then white ends
up a pawn to the good so this is a
beautiful tactical sequence for yonda
palmushi and if he finds it he may very
well be forcing his way through to the
finals because peace are getting traded
off Knight takes A7 forces a lot of
liquidation and if Magnus tries
Shenanigans with rookie hey then
the idea Still Remains as strong as ever
Rook takes B6 and in the end again that
Bishop on E6 hangs giving the Knight
enough time to evacuate back toward B5
oh my Lance the calculation has to
continue your Bishop D5 Knight B5 Bishop
takes F3 and 502 but I I just feel like
white should be thrilled you have two
minor pieces for the rook and the Pawn's
not fast enough to see box and you have
this now new Luft Square for the King on
G2 no yeah
will accept this position with open arms
and I'm
going to almost guarantee that he plays
Knight A7 yondapon she does not miss
opportunities like these especially not
when he's in this kind of form
right no he's seeing all the tactics
today and Knight takes H7 it requires
double checking triple checking and he
doesn't play it and I jinxed it
commentator's curse but his move might
actually not be bad at all he might see
Knight takes A7 and he might be saving
it for the next move
so if Knight C7 you're still taking on
A7 is your point that I think is Jan's
Point what an insane sequence and The
Rook on see it is undefended
then does the Knight get trapped on C8
like Knight A6 Knight C8 Bishop A5 or C5
something like that
I evacuate
oh your Bishop on C2 protects your Rook
I just completely forgot about that
although uh I guess yeah I mean white
black is slightly better there I think
but it should be drawable
should being the operative word bang
bang bang bang you win the pawn back but
white has been passive pieces but okay
maybe
uh if you can trade that pawn then of
course but the bishop and H2 the point I
was gonna make is terrible so even in
certain end games or you know positions
with a rook end game with uh pieces on
both sides of the board it's going to be
bad for white because of that Bishop on
H2
I'm really really curious what it is
that Disturbed him about Knight takes A7
and we might very well follow that line
and there's Knight takes a seven
Agnes takes the Rook
Bishop C5 we're going exactly down this
variation
but at the end Robert that moved D3 that
might be the game changer that might be
the only reason that Jan will save this
game
yeah D3 is huge
because with the pawns on one flank the
role of the relative activity of the
pieces the impact of that is so greatly
diminished
there it is and Magnus very upset yeah
he's seeing Pieces come off the board he
is not happy about it so maybe Rook B7
is wrong you don't want to trade too
much so how about Rook D6 instead that
way without question I think you should
go Rook D6 it doesn't even matter what
the objective assessment is you have to
keep Rooks on the board you have to make
it as difficult as possible for Yan to
liquidate further
it's what Yan did in game two remember
after Bishop takes C6 in that position
instead of doing Queen H7 to trade Queen
to a queen G7 which was objectively
worse the engine says nope that's wrong
but was practically the best decision
possible to keep uh his chances alive so
um maybe that was one of the moves of
the day but for Magnus he's gonna have
to take one of the yon's book and play
him with like Rook D6 keep the pieces on
the board
but the only big operative difference is
that Jan has left himself with 10
minutes on the clock five more minutes
coming in just a couple of moves and
that might be the game changer if John
had two minutes in this point
then I feel like I would rank magnus's
winning chances probably as at least
being 50 as it stands given neon's
confidence given his form given the time
situation
I think Jan should be able to hold this
with accurate play
and Jan's the only player who like
leaves his chair everyone else yeah I
know is like stapled there they don't
have a choice but Jan uh goes around
Charlie just tries to you know get some
walking in try to just keep relaxed and
Magnus teams anything but relax and Rook
D6 is there another move besides Rook
six Rook B7 is a non-starter it's a
non-starter and you want to win the pawn
on A3 back right you don't want to allow
white to play like A4 A5
so I simply don't see another
alternative I think Magnus is
contemplating Rook B7 he's evaluating
that position with pawns on the same
plate no Rook to d8
is his choice
he wants to leave the D6 Square open for
his Knight potentially
95s instantly with Knight to five
you have to take that thing right
I would imagine you do because if you
play Bishop A3 that's also non-starter
due to rookie 196. and Madness
you were right that was his idea
and what about D3 here oh D3 there might
be Bishop takes D5
and C3 is that possible
bang bang bang
okay if this Pawn can be captured then
white is out of the woods officially but
Rook B3 there is some sort of Bishop D
form that's what I'm looking at oh but
then I take it it would be six
the bishop wins the game ridiculous
at last it has waited for its moment in
the Sun and that moment arrives
now here's another thought
can white play the sort of plebeian
Knight C3
takes or K1
yes
this doesn't win a peace block as this
move but
this should not be looted should not
present too many difficulties for white
I think no you're happy to trade off as
many pieces as you can now this is
exactly what John would want no it looks
like Jan is
just playing great chess today not
perfect chest but he's playing very well
what two games in black and now here
with white in game four Magnus is gonna
have to find a winning idea at a thin
air
yeah and if D3 happens with the pawn
gone from C4 winning this position with
all of the pawns on the same flank
is going to be a Herculean task of epic
proportions
I think God's calculating D3
if he gets to trade off those pawns yes
that is what the doctor ordered what
else could he play besides D well
nothing he played D3
he's done it
he's done it he's on move 28 plenty of
time his time management Robert another
thing that we should keep shouting out
it has been nothing short of Exquisite
doesn't matter who he's been playing and
to manage your time like this against
the world champion
is amazing
it is and if Magnus cannot take this one
right and I agree with the feature chat
if anyone can grind water from the stone
it's Magnus of course uh what I was
gonna say if he is unable to do that
then he ends up in the consolation match
and he'll play noribeca abdusetaro which
I think a lot of people would be happy
to see now the main spectacle will be
Hikaru Nakamura against the under
palmshi if yon does not lose this game
and deservedly so playing for official
random World Championship so Jan would
have two World Championships to play for
in recent times but Magnus against
nordibeck come on that's also super
exciting oh it absolutely is I mean no
if I could design the ideal consolation
match it would involve the world
champion of the world rapid champion
uh so we are in for a treat tomorrow as
well can I show you a crazy line I was
thinking as you were talking I promised
I was listening about the move Knight
takes E4
and the point is you're attacking F2 and
after Bishop before Bishop D5 if you can
force the trade black has chances but
white plays Rook D1 black plays Knight
C7 and Knight takes E5 Saves the Day for
white and essentially wins the game as
well
because at the end of the line you also
Hit The Rook of the bishop
well that's actually a beautiful
sequence and that actually might be a
detail that Magnus overlooked because
without that he has to allow uh the
symmetrical ons on the same flank
and without those pawns you know four on
four on the king side looks like a very
easy hold for yawn
mag's nervously fiddling with a pawn in
his hand
trying to find an idea anything that
allows the game to continue winning
chances to stay alive he's got three
minutes for the next couple moves but he
also will gain five minutes when he
reaches move 30 but time is not the
issue right now it's the position trades
are being offered and without pieces
remaining and that Knight on A6 Donya
that's the problematic piece right now
for Magnus and also let's not forget
that Magnus is not recaptured on A3 yet
in a classical game I think if anybody
is contending for an actual Advantage it
is white nepo is going to bail out if
given the opportunity but that pod on A3
is not easy to capture because of this
constant threat of Rook A1 skewering the
minor pieces
very annoying
two and a half minutes for Magnus I
don't think he sees anything I don't
think there's anything to see
no
I think at best he equalizes this
position and he can't afford to make a
draw so he can't even you know mix
things up create complications the
position is becoming dry
and Magnus you can tell he knows it well
there's the water his face
water
the swipe from Magnus but he's not
swiping right on his position that's for
sure most definitely not
most definitely not and now he's below
two minutes
he seems to have had that pose that the
pre-move pose for a long time but he
just doesn't know what to do and to
squeeze water from
uh a stone Robert as you said you
actually need some spark you can't just
do it you know with pawns on the same
side of the board
and even Magnus won't be able to produce
any chances here I'm afraid look at him
he is more or less resigned to the fact
that he is not going to be able to win
this game uh he's looking bothered not
often I don't even know how many times
ever happened where Magnus has a lead in
a match and he does not win that match
but Jan napomishi what a performance
from him game one was not particularly
great from the white side he was missing
tactics that Magnus capitalized on but
in games two and three with the black
pieces he was just a beast I'll be real
with you after nepo loses game one with
white you just start thinking about
their world championship match and you
know okay Magnus he's starts from a
clean slate today no more blunders all
of a sudden the total 180 credit to yawn
credit to his second so I'm sure had a
conversation with him after that initial
loss calmed him down and Jan re-emerged
as a Three-Headed Beast in games two and
three
and if we look at this position what
Magnus is claiming even though he's down
this a pawn is that his minor pieces
will be better than whites if he gets
that Knight to C6 you see just Knight on
C6 Bishop C5 96 Bishop E6 all those
pieces in close contact with one another
and the bishop on H2 is still not a very
good piece
I think this is the most
insofar as there is any way to keep some
Life Alive Black's position is in the
Intensive Care Unit I mean it's on life
support but with his pieces remaining
active there are always going to be
chances for some kind of Swindle in the
center maybe bishop D5 and E4 maybe a
timely F5 Magnus is going to exhaust
every last chance here that you know for
a fact
right but
for Jan you've already reached to move
30 you have 11 minutes on your clock
you're feeling good
and as fioric sharp said John has I mean
everybody at the top has had games where
they've blundered away
a win or a draw in a position where the
results seems to be a bygone conclusion
no we're not saying that this game is
over
no it's not Knight D7 just trying to
figure out where the pieces belong
there's a possibility for the future G5
some expansion for black you mentioned
F5 not easy to get away with because E5
will be loose but Jan look at those eyes
he is calculating he is looking
at this board and he is trying to rely
on his uh
calculation not on just oh it should be
good enough like he cannot afford to let
his guard down
and something that you I think have
pointed out before the one thing you
can't afford to do let your guard down
but you also can't afford to start
looking only for bailout options if you
start playing unobjectively and you go
for peace trades that's how Magnus gets
a little squeeze even if it's an
objectively drawn position Jana has to
draw this from a position of strength
and that means he's got to nurture his
Advantage here and I think Knight D2 is
an excellent way to do that eliminating
any possibility of Bishop takes D5 and
E4
also probably understood that Magnus
might want to move the Bishop from C5
and put a knight on that square hitting
the bishop on D3 in the pawn E4 so bring
the Knight back to D2 defends the pawn
on e4 and I think this is a great
decision
I mean Jan is just making one excellent
move after another I think he is
determined
to not give Magnus even an Iota even a
scintilla of a chance to complicate the
game Rook A8 Knight C7
oh
wow that would be a really
way to end this match Bishop A7 by
Magnuson
he's going along with your idea trying
to stick that Knight on C5 and undermine
the support of the D5 Knight
makes perfect sense I think white can
play Knight C4 just offer some trades
yeah probably is about that time what if
Knight C4 I take it
and then go Knight C5
okay you're not threatening Knight takes
E4 because Rook B7
but yeah probably not
although I kind of am
you kind of are you kind of not yeah I
actually think that's a good move no I
am because at the end of the line you're
going to experience problems with your
back rank
the bishop on H2 is so bad that's a
terrible piece
if only it was like on G3
pen White would have zero issues
or if the king would be on H1 white
would be able to play F3 and Bishop G1
but white is it quite in time after he
runs into the discovery
that's right huh
wait a second
we've seen Magic from Magnus now for
well over a decade does he have a little
nasty left in him
to complicate this ostensibly
unwinnable end game
and look at Jan playing Knight B3
covering the C5 Square If You're Gonna
Play Knight C5 it's melee going to be
removed from the board he goes G5 so mag
at long last expands of the king side
but you see the evaluation bar expanding
in White's favor yeah
and I'm not sure exactly what Magnus is
aiming for here I think it's time for
Yan to fix the problem once and for all
of his H2 Bishop Robert that is exactly
what he does moves the king away
and if he gets these two moves in that's
it that will eliminate any last
many chances micro chances that black is
hoping to generate with his kingside
play and the bishop on D3 is so well
placed he defends The Rook on B1 covers
the E4 Pawn as well uh just keeps
everything together and
I'm trying to come up with some ideas
for Magnus that where can the knights
jump to where does The Rook belong but
yeah F5 makes E5 so weak
that is true and white could meet that
probably with F3 although something like
Knight C7 might be a more ambitious
approach
no this is
this is looking mighty Grim maybe G4
after F5 I love that movie knight C7
it's really a clever one
yeah I can show that I guess because the
bishop drops back you lose the F5 and
the moment you take you have this gaping
hole on E6 that white is going to
swing his Knight to with a fork
this is looking grim
look at that Bishop D5 and Knight B6
trying to win this Pawn on D5 and that
Bishop on H2 still out of play so if
Magnus can snag this D5 Pawn even
material once more and we have some
imbalances
yeah no this is perhaps the last
remaining hope
for Magnus but there's another sip of
water Yan seems incredibly relaxed he's
got the situation fully under control
and plenty of time on his clock to
figure out these last few challenges
on route to holding his own and winning
the match
so what can he do here Knight C5 makes a
lot of sense to me trying to hop right
into E6 with a fork I'll play King F7
D3 can't find
that diagonals you know the A2 G8
diagonal yeah that's a bit annoying
actually
that's a bit annoying
and black is threatening to recapture on
D5 at last
if the king shifts away from G7
oh wait you're not threatening Knight D5
actually so because it might be
separation yes it's actually really nice
so A5
Knight takes D5 Knight B7 is really nice
beautiful this is amazing if you take
you get forked and you know what's super
cool as well in this position oh I'm
counter-attacking your Bishop Bishop C4
and that picks up A7 and that moved King
G1 that's such a money decision by yawn
because it eliminates all of the back
rank problems yep bringing the king
towards the center making sure that he
can escape and as you're showing here
trading the knights was the point for
the seventh ranked check so he played
Knight A5 instead of Knight C5
so he's setting for C6
oh and after Knight D5 I think he's got
that Knight B7 idea
you called it you think Knight C6 is
coming and then Knight B7 happens like
oh gosh gotta resign now A little
misdirection I guess Magnus has to put
his Rook on the seventh rank that might
be his only move
and that does finally reinforce the
threat of Knight 65 at last
night
it's over after Knight B7 and he plays
it instantly yes and Magnus resigned I
think Magnus allowed it just because he
couldn't play for one another any other
way Jan de palmishi is our second
finalist Magnus has had enough of Fisher
random for the day and Jan neponishi
Hikaru Nakamura that is your
Championship Sunday Showdown
and what a showdown it's going to be
both of these players are in phenomenal
form there is nothing better Robert than
a match between two players who are just
knocking everybody out this must feel
amazing for Yan obviously in a little
Revenge a little nasty there for Jana
pomnishi as he knocks Magnus Carlson off
forcing him to play the consolation
match
this has been incredible honestly
incredible
yeah three wins in a row I mean the
important ones were rounds two and three
it's kind of like two wins in a row and
the third one's like a a
0.75 right it's like the game could have
been a draw but maggots couldn't afford
it but the point is that when his back
was against the wall John the Palm she
loses game one he strikes back
immediately and not only in one game in
the second one in the third game as well
you see vitzugov you see photo chest
Maria millionova there as well it's a
Jubilation in yonda palmistry's Camp he
has won three to one and he unless that
was a draw offer right that could have
been a draw for by John after Knight B7
like okay you're gonna lose so we might
as well either way Jan makes it through
he is ecstatic and he has a chance at
two different world championship titles
and he is just writing one of the
greatest ways perhaps the greatest wave
of success in his entire chess career
and it has been a long chess career from
the candidates to the RCC to the
official random World Championship it
seems like everything Yan is touching
turns into gold and perhaps this streak
of success the only person it's matched
by is of course Hikaru Nakamura this is
going to be a final for the ages Robert
tomorrow
that's right and we will get
confirmation of whether that was a
resignation or an agreement by draw it
doesn't matter because Yonder Palm she
still wins the match we would like to be
accurate but no matter what it is yonda
palmshi Hikaru Nakamura they are going
to be duking it out for a prize of 150
000 and of course this Fisher random
World Championship crown and Wesley so
he'll join as with all the players they
will have Sunday matches because each
prize is different in the field it's not
like seventh and 8th just share the pot
no no no so each prize is different and
we actually have confirmation it was a
resignation from Magnus Carlson it is
three to one Jana palmchi hikar Nakamura
Dania it's going to be so exciting of
course we're gonna focus on the hikarana
banushi match we are definitely going to
keep you up to speed on all of the
consolation matches but the star of the
show the stars of the show tomorrow are
nepo and Hikaru Nakamura in this last
year we've just had so many epic
rivalries so many epic matchups and I
think this format really caters uh to
the kind of entertainment value that
chess fans have come to expect from
these types of tournaments I can't wait
these 24 hours less these 60 now's
cannot go by fast enough Robert I just
cannot wait for the gong to sound
tomorrow and for 11 A.M Eastern to
arrive oh it's going to be super
exciting as we mentioned a hundred fifty
thousand dollar prize for first 85 000
to the runner-up not bad and Magnus
Carlsen already back up to sitarov and
everybody else in the field they will be
playing for prize money or the
difference between third and fourth is
15 grand otherwise it's five grand in
the matchups we'll see Federal save will
take on Wesley so Matthias bluebaum will
take on Gilbert Stein gretcherson the
Icelandic Local Hero the number one
player from Iceland so it's going to be
a lot of fun but before we get to
tomorrow's action in the Fisher random
World Championship the women's
candidates continues Anna music scored a
huge victory in game four of her match
wow she leveled the score against humpy
conero it is 2-2 that means we have
Armageddon and the players in this
competition they are trying to make
their way all the way through started
with eight players in the women's
candidates one player can ultimately win
and that player will take on Zhu and
June for the Women's World Championship
but on a music pumpy Corner tie break
Sunday that's going to be a very
important and fun match as well so keep
your Sunday wide open not because it's
the NFL but because there is a ton of
Chess to watch this coverage of the
official random World Championship on
chess.com is brought to you by Brave
Donya any final thoughts before we say
goodbye to everybody watching I can't
believe it's been something like six
hours since we joined the call this has
gone by in a Flash I feel like I always
say that I've said that at the last
couple of days
and guess what Robert I am not shy about
admitting this when Fisher random first
became a thing when it sort of
came to popularity a couple of years ago
my first instinct was I don't really
like this I don't like the way the
pieces are uncoordinated I don't like
the lack of opening Theory I don't like
the weird tactics and as time has gone
on as I've gained experience playing
fisheranda but most importantly as I
have gotten the privilege to watch these
incredibly strong top players duke it
out in these unconventional positions I
have gained a great appreciation for the
uniqueness or the richness just for the
amazing qualities that fisher random
brings out on the board and for the
qualities that it forces the players to
display as they try to navigate their
way through the complexities Yanda
palmnushy ikaranakamura they have
demonstrated these qualities in full
force this tournament and I cannot wait
to see which one of them is going to
outlast the other come tomorrow
no it will be an epic showdown for a
world championship title whether it
Beyond the Palm Street Nakamura remains
to be seen we hope that just the start
of more Fisher random events because
they are exciting uh they are confusing
a little bit but the players they work
through those complications and allow us
to Marvel at everything that happens so
we'll be back tomorrow same time same
place here on chess.com this coverage
brought to you by Brave we will see you
then
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign